AND BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE NUMBER
FIVE WILL COME TO ORDER GOOD
MORNING. MEMBERS IN RESPONSE TO
THE COVE IN NINETEEN EMERGENCY
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FEES
COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUE TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
WE'RE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH SOME OF OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I BELIEVE ONE MAYBE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY WHICH
WOULD BE SENATOR MELENDEZ. IN
THE SENATE CHAMBER WITH ME
THOUGH ARE SENATORS WHO DOCILE
BATES GROW ALLEN ARCHULETA
CORTESE DOLLY DODD MCGUIRE MAN
NEWMAN. RUBIO SKINNER- BURKE
WHAT KASKY AND BECKER. WE HAVE
LIMITED TIME FOR TODAY'S
HEARING SO WE MUST WRAP UP BY
NOON UNFORTUNATELY SO THAT THE
CHAMBER WILL BE READY FOR
ANOTHER HEARING AT ONE O'CLOCK-
WILL TRY TO KEEP US ON A TIGHT
SCHEDULE SO WE'LL TRY TO FINISH
EACH PANEL AND ABOUT. UNDER AN
HOUR. WE WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR MEMBER
QUESTIONS EACH MEMBER WILL HAVE
ONE QUESTION THAT THEY CAN ASK
AT AND IF WE HAVE MORE TIME GO
AROUND FOR A SECOND. ROUND OF
QUESTIONS AS WELL. WE ALSO HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL PEER REVIEW GROUP. THE SAN
JOAQUIN REGIONAL RAIL
COMMISSION. CALTRAIN AND ELLIE
METRO. WHO ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. FOR REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MEET YOUR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS WILL
GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. AFTER EVERY
TIME YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZE
IT USE THE RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURED IN THE PROGRAM. EACH
TIME YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK A POP UP WINDOW. WILL
APPEAR ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO UN MUTE. WE SELECT MENU
BEFORE YOU SPEAK R. I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU'RE DONE. ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME. AND
THEN YOU'RE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL JUSTICE THING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WE WILL
BE USING A TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON YOUR COMMITTEE WENT
IN OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT
WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
AND I'LL ANNOUNCE IT NOW.
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS
ONE EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT FOUR
FOUR. TWO NINE ONE. SIX THREE
SIX FOUR. AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS EIGHT SEVEN SIX. EIGHT NINE
FOUR ONE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES THE WORKS
PLEASE REPORTED REFER TO THE
SENATE COMMITTEE WEBSITE. FOR
TODAY'S HEARING WILL BE HEARING
ALL OF THE PANELS OF WITNESSES
ON THE AGENDA PRIOR TO TAKING
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT. ONCE WE
HAVE HEARD ALL OF THE WITNESSES
WE WILL HAVE A PUBLIC COMMENT
PERIOD FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO
COMMENT ON THAT. ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY IN AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING. HEARING
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM AS WELL DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE.
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
A CONDUCTOR HEARINGS AND AS
CLOSE. TO THE MATTER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES SO WE JUST ASK FOR
EVERYBODY TO BE RESPECTFUL. AND
SO ALL PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
OKAY SO GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
TODAY'S HEARING IS A JOINT
HEARING AGAIN. WOULD SENATE
BUDGET BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
NUMBER FIVE. TO REVIEW THE CALS
CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY'S REVISED DRAFT
TWENTY TWENTY. BUSINESS PLAN.
CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED RAIL IS
THE LARGEST INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECT IN THE COUNTRY AND
WOULD BE THE NATION'S. FIRST
TRUE HIGH SPEED RAIL SYSTEM.
THE PROJECT CONTINUES TO FACE
SERIOUS CHALLENGES THOUGH. LACK
OF FUNDING. COST OVERRUNS
SCHEDULE CHANGES AND PROJECT
MANAGEMENT ISSUES. IN THE
COMING YEAR THE LEGISLATURE MAY
BE ASKED TO TAKE A BUDGET
ACTION. TO MOVE THE CURRENT
PROJECT FORWARD. NOW IS THE
TIME FOR US TO TAKE A HARD LOOK
AT WHERE WE ARE AT. WHAT IS IT
AUTHORITY DELIVERING. FOR THE
OVERALL BENEFITS TO THE STATE.
OR THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
BECOME A TRUE. FUNDING PARTNER.
TODAY WE WILL HEAR ABOUT
CURRENT CONSTRUCTION AND FUTURE
PLANS. WE WILL ALSO HEAR
CONCERNS FROM OUR TRUSTED
OVERSIGHT PARTNERS. MEMBERS WE
HAVE VERY IMPORTANT DECISIONS
TO MAKE TODAY AND WE ASK THAT
EACH OF YOU. ASK THOSE
QUESTIONS AND HARD QUESTIONS
AND ENSURE WE GET THOSE ANSWERS
WE NEED. I'LL NOW TURN IT OVER
TO SENATOR THAT ALSO FOR ANY
OPENING REMARKS. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR GOOD MORNING
COLLEAGUES- MANAGER APPRECIATE
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND- YOU'RE
PULLING THIS HEARING TOGETHER.
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT IS
OBVIOUSLY AN ENORMOUS
UNDERTAKING. A MASSIVE PROJECT
THAT HAS CREATED. THOUSANDS OF
GOOD PAYING JOBS AND IS
TRANSFORMING THE TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE CENTER
ABOUT THE CENTRAL VALLEY. ISN'T
AN AMBITIOUS BET ON THE FUTURE
OF TRANSPORTATION AND HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO RESHAPE THE
STATE'S TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM.
THE CHALLENGE THE AUTHORITY
FACES AND DELIVERING ON ITS
PROMISE IS DAUNTING. AND THE
AMBITION TO DO SO IS
COMMENDABLE. GIVEN THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE PROJECT ITS
COST AND ITS POTENTIAL IMPACT
IT IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY. TO
TAKE A LONG HARD LOOK AT THE
PROJECT AND MAKE SURE WE KNOW
WHAT WE ARE BUILDING. WHAT IT'S
GOING TO COST AND WHEN WE ARE
GOING TO SEE THE BENEFIT WE
MUST RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS A
STATE PROJECT. BUT NOT ALL
PARTS OF THE STATE WILL BENEFIT
FROM THE PROJECT AT THE SAME
TIME OR IN THE SAME WAY. MY
DISTRICT FOR EXAMPLE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WILL NOT
BENEFIT DIRECTLY FROM THE
PROJECT. UNTIL THE COMPLETION
OF PHASE ONE SOMETIME IN THE
TWENTY THIRTIES. EVEN AS THE
STATE CONTINUES TO SPEND
BILLIONS OF TAXPAYER DOLLARS.
ADDITIONALLY THE STATUS
SPENDING A QUARTER OF ITS CAP
AND TRADE REVENUE ON THE
PROJECT. EVEN THOUGH WE WON'T
SEE REAL CLIMATE BENEFITS FROM
THE PROJECT FOR A DECADE OR
LONGER. AT THIS POINT I EXPECT
A BETTER SENSE OF WHAT SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA READ IS RESIDENTS
WILL GET OUT OF THE PROJECT.
AND WHEN THEY WILL SEE THE
BENEFIT. OF THE SAME WAY THAT I
EXPECT ALL RESIDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA EXPECT. I LOOK
FORWARD TO TODAY'S GOOD
DISCUSSION AND EXPLORING THESE
ISSUES IN GREATER DETAIL THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU
SENATOR THE RUSSELL AND I DON'T
SEE OUR VICE CHAIRS HERE SO WE
WILL MOVE ON- AGAIN TO ENSURE
THAT OUR WITNESSES HAVE THE-
TOLL FREE NUMBER FOR ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO PARTICIPATE
CALLING NOW PLEASE- YOU CAN
DIAL. TOLL FREE EIGHT FOUR FOUR
TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX
FOUR. WHEN PROMPTED PLEASE USE
ACCESS CODE. EIGHT SEVEN SIX
EIGHT NINE FOUR ONE. NOW WE
WILL HEAR FROM OUR FIRST
PRESENTER BRIAN KELLY CEO OF
THE CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY TO GIVE AN OVERVIEW
OF THE BUSINESS PLAN THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER KELLY FOR
JOINING US. YOU'RE ON. THANK
YOU ADJOURNMENTS CALLS AND A
JERK IT ALSO IT IS MY PLEASURE
TO BE HERE TODAY I'M- ALWAYS
HONORED TO APPEAR BEFORE THE
SENATE. HOUSE IN WHICH I WORKED
FOR EIGHTEEN YEARS OF MY CAREER.
I SHOULD BE BEFORE YOU TODAY. I
HAVE A BRIEF POWER POINT- THAT
I WILL MOVE THROUGH. QUICKLY IN
THE INTEREST OF TIME BUT THIS
IS. INTENDED TO SUMMARIZE WHAT
IS IN THE DRAFT. REVISED DRAFT
TWENTY TWENTY BUSINESS PLAN
THAT WE RELEASED ON FEBRUARY
NINTH SO WITHOUT. FURTHER ADO
WE'LL GET RIGHT INTO THE
PRESENTATION. FIRST LIGHT
PLEASE. I JUST BY WAY OF TIME
LINE WE INTRODUCED AS REVISED
DRAFT PLAN ON FEBRUARY NINTH AT
OUR BOARD HEARING WE ARE IN A
THIRTY DAY PUBLIC REVIEW
PERIOD- THAT ENDS ENDED ON
MARCH TWELFTH HOWEVER OF COURSE
WE CONTINUE TO HAVE THE-
OVERSIGHT HEARINGS WITH THE-
LEGISLATURE. MY BOARD WILL
RECONVENE ON MARCH TWENTY FIFTH
TWO REVIEW COMMENTS THAT WE'VE
HEARD ABOUT THE DRAFT PLAN
SINCE THEY'VE BEEN OUT. AND THE
BOARD WILL CONSIDER. ANY
CHANGES TO THAT DRAFT PLAN
WHERE REQUIRED UNDER THE
AGREEMENT NOW WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE LEADERSHIP TO
SUBMIT THE FINAL. DRAFT PLAN TO
THE LEGISLATURE ON APRIL
FIFTEENTH. JUST A COMMENT ABOUT
THIS NOT WITHSTANDING. THE
ADOPTION OF THE PLAN THERE WILL
OBVIOUSLY BE AN ONGOING
CONVERSATION. WITH THE
LEGISLATURE THROUGH THIS BUDGET
PROCESS IS WE- SEEK. THE
REMAINING- PROP ONE A. BOND
FUNDS WE CAN COMPLETE THE
CONSTRUCTION WORK IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY SO. AGAIN NOT
WITHSTANDING THE ADOPTION THE
BUSINESS PLAN WE KNOW THERE'S A
LONGER CONVERSATION OF ONE
LIKELY GO THROUGH THE ENTIRETY.
OF THE CURRENT BUDGET PROCESS
NEXT LIKE. THE BUSINESS PLAN
DOES TALK ABOUT SEVERAL
ELEMENTS OF OUR PROGRAM
INCLUDING HOW WE WERE IMPACTED
BY THE COPA NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
WHAT WE ARE NOT AN OPERATING
TRANSIT ENTITY YET CERTAINLY
OUR ENTERPRISE WAS IMPACTED
SEVERELY. BY VARIOUS PARTS OF
COPING NINETEEN. WE RECORDED
SOME TWO HUNDRED NEARLY TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY- WORKERS IN
TWENTY TWENTY- WE HAD A AT
LEAST A CASH FLOW HIT ABOUT.
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS TO. CAP AND
TRADE REVENUE THAT MARKET WAS
IMPACTED SEVERELY RIGHT WHEN
THE- COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC
BEGAN LAST MARCH AND THE FIRST
ARJUN WAS EXTREMELY. LOW THOSE
AUCTIONS HAVE GOTTEN BETTER AND
BETTER WITH THE SUBSEQUENT
AUCTIONS BUT FOR TWENTY TWENTY
WE WERE DOWN ABOUT. TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY EIGHT MILLION VERSUS
PRIOR YEAR AUCTIONS ONE COMMENT
ON THIS THE WAY TO A- CAP AND
TRADE AUCTIONS WORK. THE
ALLOWANCES THAT WERE NOT SOLD
IN TWENTY TWENTY WE EXPECT TO
BE SOLD SO WE DO THINK. WE WILL
RECOVER MUCH OF THIS THIS MONEY
OVER TIME HOWEVER DOES REFLECT
THE CASH FLOW IMPACT. THAT THAT
WE REPORT IN THE BUSINESS. WE
ALSO DID PUSH BACK OUR ALSO.
FOR SEVERAL OUR PROJECTS
SECTIONS UP AND DOWN THE STATE
IN RESPONSE TO REQUESTS FROM
COMMUNITIES AND STAKEHOLDERS.
ARE MORE TIME TO REVIEW THOSE.
AND WE PUSH BACK OUR TRACKING
SYSTEMS PROCUREMENT CONTRACT.
BUT NOW READY- THAT NOW SAID TO
BE. HEARD BY OUR BOARD IN THE
THIRD QUARTER OF TWENTY A
TWENTY ONE. AND OF CURSE SOME
OF OUR RIGHT OF WAY
ACQUISITIONS WERE AFFECTED BY.
LIMITED COURTHOUSE HOURS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL SO ENTERPRISE WIDE
A QUITE AN IMPACT FROM COCA
NINETEEN THAT- CERTAINLY
IMPACTED OUR OUR SCHEDULE NEXT
SLIDE. WE OPTED IN THE BUSINESS
PLAN ON WHERE WE ARE ON
CONSTRUCTION SCHEDULE. WE HAVE
THREE CONSTRUCTION PACKAGES
UNDER WAY IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. CONSTRUCTION PACKAGES
ONE. TWO THREE AND FOUR A
COMBINED TO BE A HUNDRED NINETY
MILES OF THE- CIVIL WORKS THE-
BRIDGES AND SORT OF STRAX SUB
WORK THAT'S NECESSARY- TO-
ALTERNATELY GET THE SYSTEM UP
AND OPERATING IN CENTRAL VALLEY
WE ARE IN CONSTRUCTION OF A
HUNDRED OF A- HUNDRED NINETY
MILES OF THAT. SEGMENT DEBT NOW
THROUGH THESE THREE PACKAGES
THIS CHART OF THE BOX ON THE
RIGHT SHOWS ARE OUR
CONSTRUCTION SCHEDULE WE
ANTICIPATE COMPLETING. C. P.
ONE AND TWO AND THREE BY THIS-
OF TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND
CONSTRUCTION PACKAGE FOR- JUST
THIRTEEN MONTHS FROM NOW WILL
BE SUBSTANTIALLY COMPLETE WITH
THAT- THAT'S THE TWENTY ONE
MILES IS THE FURTHEST. SOUTH OF
THE HUNDRED NINETY MILE SET OUR
TRACKING SYSTEMS CONTRACT AWARD
AS I MENTIONED EARLIER WE'RE
HOPING TO AWARD LATER THIS FALL
AND ALLOW WORK TO COMMENCE AS
EARLY AS TWENTY TWENTY TWO ALL
I KNOW THE TRACKING SYSTEMS
INSTALLATION ELEMENT. OF THE
BOX ON THE RIGHT THERE IS OUR
CURRENT ENVIRONMENTAL
COMPLETION STATUS WE HAVE
CLEARED A HUNDRED NINETY NINE
MILES OF THE FIVE HUNDRED MILE
SEGMENT. TO DATE INCLUDING A
TWO SEGMENTS THAT WERE CLEARED
DURING THE END OF TWENTY
NINETEEN AND TWENTY TWENTY WE
HAVE TWO MORE SEGMENTS ON THIS
MAP THE ORANGE LINE. AT THE
BOTTOM OF THAT CENTRAL VALLEY
STRETCH INTO PALMDALE THIS IS
OUR INITIALS ENTREE IF YOU WILL
INTO SOUTHERN. CALIFORNIA WE
EXPECT TO CLEAR THOSE THIS
SUMMER FROM THE PALMDALE
EXTENSION AND A LITTLE BIT
LATER IN THE YEAR FROM BURBANK
TO LOS ANGELES EXTENSION THOSE
COMBINED TO BE A ROUGHLY A
HUNDRED MORE MILES. BUT NINETY
ONE MORE MONTHS. OF THE BEST IT
WILL CLEAR THE WAY. SO THAT ALL
FORTY NINETY FOUR WILL BE. UP
BY THE END OF TWENTY TWO IN THE
FIRST QUARTER OF TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. NEXT SLIDE. WE
IDENTIFIED IN OUR DRAFT PLAN A
CONSTRUCTION COSTS. AGAIN THIS
IS ALL WITHIN THE- ALLOCATION
OF FUNDS OF THE PROJECT.
CURRENTLY HAS BUT WE WILL. WANT
TO ADJUST WE CALL OUR BASELINE
BUDGET- TO ME CONSTRUCTION
COSTS THAT ARE. WE'VE
IDENTIFIED KNOWN COSTS ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS AND WE ALSO ARE
PROPOSING. TO INCREASE OUR WHAT
WE CALL OUR RISK CONTINGENCY.
PUT MORE MONEY INTO RISK
CONTINGENCY TO THE TUNE OF
ABOUT A BILLION DOLLARS SO WE
WOULD MOVE OUR CENTRAL VALLEY
BUDGET FROM TWELVE POINT FOUR
THIRTEEN. POINT EIGHT AGAIN A
BILLION DOLLARS OF THAT IS WHAT
WE CALL RISK CONTINGENCY AND
THE DONATION HERE IS THE. SEE
THAT WE MUST GET DONE TO FINISH
THE WORK IN THE RISK ELEMENT IS
RECOGNIZING THAT THOSE ARE
STILL SUBJECT TO COMMERCIAL
NEGOTIATION THE FUTURE THERE'S
SOME. RISK IN THOSE NUMBERS SO
WE WANT TO HAVE A CONTINGENCY.
TO DEAL WITH THAT AS WELL AS
SOMETHING WE LEARNED FROM
COPING NINETEEN WHICH IS THAT.
THE RISK IS ALL AROUND US YEAH
IT DOES SOMETIMES YOU CAN
ANTICIPATE THE IMPACTS PROGRESS
THERE ARE KNOWN AND SERVE AS A
SORT OF PRUDENT PRACTICE WE
WANT TO EXPAND. THAT RISK
CONTINGENCY POT. NEXT SLIDE.
THIS AGAIN IS OUR- OUR SCHEDULE
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL DOCUMENT
COMPLETION. YOU SEE IN THE
MIDDLE COLUMN THERE THAT. IN
TWENTY TWENTY- WE PUT OUT FOR
DRAFTING FORMAL DOCUMENTS. TO
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TO IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA GETTING
INTO THE BAY AREA. WE WILL
COMPLETE THAT WORK OR BRING
THOSE TO OUR BOARD. FOR WHAT WE
CALL RECORD OF DECISION OR ROD
CERTIFICATION. AT THE- AB
SECOND AND FOURTH QUARTERS OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IN THE FIRST
PART OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO. AT
THE FINAL TO. PASS WILL BE
RELEASED LATER THIS YEAR AND-
WE HOPE TO FINISH THAT WORK AND
CERTIFY THOSE RIGHTS THE END OF
TWENTY TWO BEGINNING OF A
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. NEXT SLIDE.
IN FEBRUARY WHEN WE PUT OUT OUR
DRAFT PLAN AND EVEN OUR LAST
PROJECT UPDATE REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE. FROM TWENTY
NINETEEN WE INDICATED AN
INTEREST. TO MOVE THE HUNDRED
NINETY MILES THAT ARE CURRENTLY
IN THE IN CONSTRUCTION THE
BALLOT. TO EXTEND THOSE TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE MILE IN A
ROOM SERVICE AND THAT IS SO WE
CAN GET ELECTRIFIED HIGH SPEED
SERVICE GOING. IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY CONNECTING THE CITIES OF
MERCED. FRESNO AND BAKERSFIELD.
WE DID AN EXTENSIVE ANALYSIS OF
THIS WITH A- OPERATING ENTITY
THAT OPERATES HIGH SPEED RAIL
IN GERMANY TODAY. AND WE CAME
UP WITH THE PROPOSAL TO MOVE
FORWARD ON THIS EARLY OPERATING
SYSTEM THAT WOULD. REDUCE
TRAVEL TIME COMPARED TO THE
CURRENT. SERVICES IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. BETWEEN NINETY
AND A HUNDRED MINUTES. A WE
WOULD INCREASE THE FREQUENCY OF
SERVICE FROM SEVEN DAILY TRIPS
TODAY. THE UP TO EIGHTEEN DAILY
TRIPS. WE WOULD CONNECT THREE
THE FASTEST GROWING CITIES IN
THE STATE. DO THE GREATEST
RIDERSHIP INCREASE AND FAREBOX
BENEFIT. FROM THE SMALLEST
INVESTMENT. COMPARED TO
INVESTING THOSE SAME DOLLARS IN
OTHER CORRIDORS. AND IT
PROVIDES FOR INTERIM CONNECTION
TO PARTSNORTH OF THE IN THE
SAN JOAQUIN SERVICE WHICH MEANS
WE WOULD CONNECT WITH THE SAN
JOAQUIN SYSTEM IN MERCED- THAT
SYSTEM WOULD CONTINUE ON UP TO
SACRAMENTO AND OAKLAND. AND THE
AC SYSTEM WHICH IS NOW BEING
EXTENDED TO MERCED WOULD ALSO
ULTIMATELY GO THAT NOW GOES TO
THE BERRY WOULD ALSO HAVE TRIPS
TO SACRAMENTO IN THE FUTURE
YEAH DUBBED THAT CAN ACTUALLY
BE NAY AT PERCENT. THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE HUNDRED
SEVENTY ONE MILE SEGMENT IS
EXPECTED TO GENERATE SOME
CHILDREN THREE THOUSAND JOB
YEARS. NEARLY FORTY BILLION IN
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY. NEXT SLIDE.
THE OTHER IMPORTANT PART OF
THIS EXTENSION IS WHAT WE CALL
GETTING OUT OF THE ORCHARDS AND
INTO THE CITIES. AND THAT IS AT
POPLAR AVENUE PICTURE THERE ON
THE TOP LEFT. IS A PHOTO OF THE
CURRENT TERMINATION POINT. FOR
THE HUNDRED NINETEEN FIRST
CONSTRUCTION SEGMENT HUNDRED
NINETY MILE. CONSTRUCTION
SEGMENT. PART OF EXTENDING
FURTHER INTO THE- BAKERSFIELD
DOWNTOWN AREA IS REALLY THE
IDEA OF. THOSE EIGHTEEN MILES
GET THE TRAIN INTO A POPULATED
AREA. IN A STATION WHERE
CONNECTION POINTS TO LOCAL. A
TRANSIT OPTIONS ARE EASILY
AVAILABLE AND BUSES TRAVELING
FURTHER SOUTH. TO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA SO THE IDEA IS TO
MOVE. INTO THE URBAN DOWNTOWN
AREA YEAH AND OUT OF THE
ORCHARDS THANKS FOR. SIMILARLY
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WHAT GO
BACK ONE PLEASE. THIS IS
SIMILARLY IN NORTHERN THE
NORTHERN TERMINUS POINT THAT
ROAD TWENTY SIX IDENTIFICATION
IS THE- CURRENT TERMINUS IN
MADERA- IT IS IN A SUBDIVISION
AND CLOSE TO. UP A GOLF COURSE
AND AGAIN BY EXTENDING THIRTY
FIVE MILES NORTH INTO DOWNTOWN
MERCED OUR INTENTION IS TO. GO
TO THE STATION IN MERCED
MEETING THE SAN MARKINGS IN A
SYSTEMS THERE THEY GO FURTHER
NORTH TO THE BAY AREA IN.
SACRAMENTO AND SO AGAIN THESE
ARE SOME OF THE ELEMENTS OF.
MOVING FROM ONE NINETEEN TO ONE
SEVENTY ONE GET YOU INTO THE
DOWNTOWN URBAN AREAS. WHICH WE
THINK MAKES THE MOST SENSE FOR.
APPLE NEXT TO SLIDE. WE DID
EVALUATE SOME QUESTIONS THAT
WERE RAISED BY THE LEGISLATURE
IN THE PEER REVIEW GROUP- BASED
ON OUR PROPOSAL TO DO THE
HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE MILE
STRETCH WE WERE ASKED TO HAVE A
INDEPENDENT PEER REVIEW OF OUR
RIDERSHIP FORECASTS FOR THAT
CENTRAL VALLEY. HUNDRED SEVENTY
ONE MILE STRETCH. AND WE ALSO
ENTERED A MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY. M. S. N. WORKING JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY. FOR TO DEFINE
THE INTER SERVICE ROLES OF EACH
AGENCY AND RESPONSIBILITIES AND
SO WE HAVE A HIGH LEVEL AND-
YOU THAT LAYS THOSE OUT. IN
THAT INTERVIEW ITSELF CALLS FOR
FUTURE MORE SPECIFIC IMHO USES
WE GET CLOSER TO OPERATING UP
WORKING THROUGH OUR OUR SISTER
AGENCIES HERE THAT WOULD BE
PART OF THE OPERATING SERVICE-
THANKS LIGHT. THE END
INDEPENDENT PEER REVIEW- ENTITY
THAT LOOKED AT OUR COST
ESTIMATES THAT ARE A IDERSHIP
ESTIMATES. OF FOR THE CENTRAL
VALLEY SEGMENT- AGAIN WE WERE
ASKED BY THE LEGISLATURE WE
CONTRACTED WITH RESOURCE
SYSTEMS GROUP ARE SG- WORKED
WITH THE PEER REVIEW GROUP TO
IDENTIFY THEM AND IDENTIFY DOES
GO. OF THEIR REVIEW- THAT THIRD
PARTY RESEARCH AND ANALYTICS
FIRM ASSESSED WHETHER OUR
ASSUMPTIONS AND RESULTS
REASONABLE. THEIR CONCLUSIONS
WERE THEY FOUND NO FATAL FLAWS
WITH THE- APPLICATION OF THE
MODEL AND THE RIDERSHIP NUMBERS
THAT WE- WE- PUT FORTH LAST
YEAR. RIDERSHIP ESTIMATES ARE
WITHIN THE RANGE IS FOR TRAVEL
TIME. AND FREQUENCY AND
IMPORTANTLY THEY CAN CURRENT
THAT- OUR APPROACH TO MOVE TO
THE HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE MILES
IN THE VALLEY. OBTAINS THE
HIGHEST FORECAST GAIN IN
RIDERSHIP AND DOES SO AT THE
LOWEST INCREASE IN COST. A NEXT
LIFE. SOME OF THESE STUDIES AN
AVERAGE REAFFIRMED VALUE FOR US
OF THE MERCED TO BAKERSFIELD
INTERIM SERVICE- THESE
EXTENSIONS ARE ENVIRONMENTALLY
CLEARED TODAY- AND WE RECOMMEND
IT BE DANCING THE DESIGN WHICH
WILL INCLUDE. ENGINEERING TO
ALLOW US TO GET THE- WORK WITH
THE COMMUNITIES AND GET THE
PROGRAM ALIGNMENT INTO
CONFIGURATION ALLOW US TO.
REFINE COST ESTIMATES TO MAP
RIGHT AWAY IDENTIFIED UTILITY
RELOCATIONS. EXECUTE THIRD
PARTY AGREEMENTS THAT ESTABLISH
AS I SAID EARLIER THE PROJECT
CONFIGURATION OF THE PROJECT
FOOTPRINT. THIS WILL HELP US
REFINE OUR COST ESTIMATES AND
PREPARE THESE EXTENSIONS FOR
PRE CONSTRUCTION ACTIVITIES
NEXT SLIDE- ARE FUNDING
ESTIMATES IN THE BUSINESS PLAN
WHEN WE LOOK AT WHAT IS
AVAILABLE TO THIS PROJECT FROM.
CURRENT FEDERAL FUNDS. FROM THE
CAP AND TRADE DOLLARS THAT WE
HAVE THE PROGRAM. AND FROM ALL
THE REMAINING BOND FUNDS BUT WE
HAVE A TOTAL RANGE OF FUNDING
AVAILABLE BETWEEN TWENTY ONE
AND TWENTY THREE BILLION. R.
COSTA SUBMIT TO COMPLETE THAT
MERCED BAKERSFIELD LINE IS IN
THAT RANGE TWENTY ONE TO TWENTY
TWO POINT EIGHT. BILLION AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER THE IMMEDIATE
ASKED THAT WILL HAVE A THE
LEGISLATURE LATER THIS SPRING
DURING MAY REVISE. WILL BE TO
APPROPRIATE THE REMAINING
PROPOSITION ONE A. FUNDS THAT
THOSE OF THE BOND FUNDS FROM
HIGH SPEED RAIL BOND ACT. OF SO
THAT WE MAY COMPLETE THE
CONSTRUCTION WORK- IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY THAT HUNDRED
NINETY MILE SEGMENTS SO THAT
WILL BE THE QUESTION THAT WILL
SURELY BECOMING FOR THE
LEGISLATURE- IN THE MAY REVISE.
ONE TIME I. NEXT SLIDE- TO KNOW
THAT- WHILE WE CALL INTO ABOUT
CHALLENGEFROM THE COPA
NINETEEN EXPERIENCE THERE'S
ALSO BEEN GREAT PROGRESS ON
THIS PROJECT AND THAT THIS
CHARGE DESIGNED JUST TO SHOW
YOU HOW WE WOULD DANCE. THE
FIRST COLUMN IS WHERE WE WERE
IN DECEMBER OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THAT SECOND COLUMN IN GREEN
REFLECTS WHERE WE WERE WHERE
ARE AS OF DECEMBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY YOU CAN SEE THAT THE
TOTALCONSTRUCTION JOBS CREATED
BY THIS PROJECT MOSTLY IN. THE
CENTRAL VALLEY THESE ARE WHERE
WERE ENACTED CONSTRUCTION OF
MORE THAN DOUBLED- WE'VE
TRIPLED THE NUMBER OF
STRUCTURES THAT ARE EITHER
COMPLETED OR UNDER CONSTRUCTION
WERE MOVING QUICKLY ON THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DRAFT DOCUMENTS
AT THIS POINT WITH THE DRAFT
OUT AND IN CERTIFIED FINAL RODS
COMING THIS YEAR. WERE DANCING
THE RIGHT AWAY PARCELS AS WELL
GETTING THOSE IN HAND IN
GETTING TO THE FINAL NUMBER WE
NEED FOR CONSTRUCTION AND THE
MILES A GUIDE WAY OR UP ABOUT
60% ARE MONTHLY AVERAGES
EXPENDITURES THROUGH TWENTY
TWENTY FOR THE DESIGN BUILD
CONTRACTS AS THE CONSTRUCTION
EXPENSES ALONE HAS MORE THAN
DOUBLED IN THE LAST THE LAST
TWO YEARS SO CERTAINLY THERE'S
CHALLENGES BUT THERE'S ALSO
BEEN IMPORTANT PROGRESS. NEXT
TO SLIDE. JUST A QUICK SO OF
SOME THAT WE EXPECT ACHIEVE IN
THE NEXT TWELVE TO FIFTEEN
MONTHS. WE ARE REQUIRED UNDER
FEDERAL AGREEMENT TO MATCH ALL
OF THE FEDERAL FUNDS WE
RECEIVED ON THIS. PROJECT WITH
STATE FUNDS WERE REQUIRED TO DO
THAT BY THE END OF THIS. TWENTY
TWENTY TWO- WE LOOKS LIKE WE
WILL MEET THAT REQUIREMENT
YEAH. IN THIS QUARTER OF THIS
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE- PERHAPS
THE SECOND QUARTER BUDGET WE'RE
VERY CLOSE RIGHT NOW. OUR
SUBSTANTIAL COMPLETION OF THE
FIRST CONSTRUCTION PACKAGE IN
THE VALLEY. IS THE ESTIMATED TO
OCCUR FOURTEEN THIRTEEN MONTHS
FROM NOW. WE WILL
ENVIRONMENTALLY CLEAR EARLY
SPRING OR BOARD THE FINAL RODS
FOR. BAKERSFIELD TO PALMDALE
AND BURBANK TO LA. AND WE LOOK
TOWARD OUR TRACKING SYSTEMS
CONTRACTS SO THAT. PRETTY
CONSTRUCTION WORK CAN COMMENCE-
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO. AND WE
WANT TO ADVANCE THE DESIGN WORK
ON THE MERCED AND BAKERSFIELD
EXTENSIONS. SO WE GET A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING WHAT'S IN FRONT
OF US THERE NOW BEFORE WE GET
INTO. THE CONSTRUCTION
ELEMENTS. FINALLY BY THE END OF
THIS CALENDAR YEAR IN DECEMBER
WE EXPECT TO HAVE EIGHTY THREE
OF NINETY THREE STRUCTURES.
EITHER COMPLETED OR UNDER
CONSTRUCTION. AND A HUNDRED SIX
OF A HUNDRED NINETY MILES OF
GUIDEWAY OPEN. FOR WORK THANKS
A LOT- THIS JUST AS A SLIDE
THAT SHE AGAIN WHERE WE ARE
WITHOUT THE STATE MATCH.
REQUIREMENT FOR THE FEDERAL
FUNDS WEEK SPENT WE HAVE
SUBMITTED TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THE ENTIRETY OF THE
MATCH TWO POINT FIVE. BILLION
DOLLARS IN STATE- INVOICES
MATCHING FEDERAL FUNDS WE
RECEIVED THE OPERATE OF LARGELY
INTO THE BARGAIN MINISTRATION
HAS APPROVED. A ONE POINT FIVE
NINE ONE MILLION OF THAT NEARLY
ONE POINT SIX BILLION ABOUT
SIXTY FOUR PERCENT. AND THEY
HAVE- THEY ARE PROCESSING NOW
THE REMAINING 36% ABOUT NINE
HUNDRED NINE MILLION SO WE ARE
ON A- PLANE TO COMPLETE THAT
WORK WELL IN ADVANCE OF OUR-
NEXT FLIGHT. THE BY THE
MINISTRATION CERTAINLY DOES
PRESENT A KEY OPPORTUNITY FOR
THIS PROJECT AND AN ABILITY. TO
RE ESTABLISH A FUNCTIONAL
FEDERAL PARTNERSHIP. OF THE
AUTHORITY IS ENGAGING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON SEVERAL
THINGS. BUT ONE JUST A
RESTORATION OF OVERSIGHT- ROLES
AND RESPONSIBILITIES AND A FULL
PARTNERSHIP ON THIS PROJECT-
WE'RE LOOKING TO SETTLE
LITIGATION. THAT WAS BROUGHT
DURING THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
WHEN. THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
TRIED TO D. OBLIGATE. THAT
NEARLY A BILLION DOLLARS FROM
THIS PROJECT WE TOOK THEM TO
COURT. WE ARE NOW IN TALKS TO
SETTLE THAT LITIGATION WITH THE
F. OR A TODAY. AND WE ARE ALSO
SEEKING- UP A LITTLE THE
DELIVERY SCHEDULE FLEXIBILITY
FROM THE UP ALREADY. SO THAT WE
CAN COMPLETE OUR WORK. IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY UNDER THE UP
PROCESS AND TIMELINES THAT MAKE
THE MOST OF BUSINESS SENSE. FOR
US. LASTLY WE'RE WORKING WITH
CERTAINLY WILL BE WORKING IN
OUR WORK TO PROVIDE TEAM ON. IN
THE UPPER FOR INCREASED FEDERAL
INVESTMENT. ELECTRIFIED HIGH
SPEED RAIL NATIONALLY BUT
CERTAINLY IN CALIFORNIA WHERE
WE ARE. FUNDING 80% OF THE
PROJECT THIS TIME AND ARE
LOOKING FOR A LONGER MORE
STABLE A FEDERAL COMMITMENT TO
THIS PROGRAM. OF COURSE
CALIFORNIA'S WILL PREPARE TO
BENEFIT. NOT JUST FOR THIS BUT
FOR ALL CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAMS. THAT ARE UNDERWAY
HERE IN TRANSIT PROGRAMS
UNDERWAY HERE WITH THE- REST OF
S. B. ONE B. CONTINUE WITH. CAP
AND TRADE REVENUES. ALL OF THAT
HELPS CALIFORNIA MATCH UP
FEDERAL MONEY THAT THEY BE
AVAILABLE FREE PRESCRIPTION.
EXCELLENT THIS IS JUST A QUOTE
THAT JOBS WAS TO US INTO HERE
IT'S ALSO APPLY TO PROJECT ARE
IT HAPPENS IT ALWAYS SEEMS
IMPOSSIBLE UNTIL IT'S DONE BUT
WE CONTINUE TO DO THE WORK IT
BASS THE WORK AND- ARE LOOKING
FORWARD TO GETTING THE PROJECT
COMPLETION SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAMS CHAIR AND I AM
PLEASED TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
THANK YOU MISTER KELLY WE
APPRECIATE THAT THE
PRESENTATION AND- WILL MOVE ON
TO OUR NEXT PANELIST WAY
BELIEVE IS BRAND ANNIS CHIEF
FINANCIAL OFFICER FOR THE
AUTHORITY- IF HE WOULD LIKE TO
COME ON AND THEN AFTERWARDS WE
WILL- BEGIN WITH MEMBER
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. YEAH GOOD
THAT. SHARES IN COMMITTEE I
DON'T HAVE ANY FURTHER REMARKS
BEYOND AT MISTER KELLY'S I
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS SO
DURING QUESTION TIME. OKAY
THANK YOU MISTER AND S. SO
WE'LL OPEN IT UP TO MEMBER
QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME- WE WANT
TO BE DONE. WITH THIS PANEL BY
ABOUT TEN O'CLOCK BUT- I DON'T
SEE ANY HANDS ARE MIKE'S REYES
PLEASE. RAISE YOUR MIKE'S IF
YOU'D LIKE TO OKAY SENATOR DOT
PLEASE YEAH I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT- WE CALL IT AS
WE SEE IT HERE YEAH AND WE HAVE
BEEN DOING THAT FOR A LONG TIME
ON THIS PROJECT IN A COUPLE
YEARS AGO WAS NOT FUN TO BE
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS PROJECT.
ANYWAYS J. PERFORM. YEAH I JUST
THINK- YEAH MISTER- KELLY AND
MR ANAS HAVE BROUGHT A NEW
VITALITY TO- THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL YOUR PROGRAM I'VE GOT-
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE CONFIDENCE
IN THIS PROGRAM GOING FORWARD
THAT I HAVE BEEN A LONG TIME I
WAS AN EARLY SUPPORTER- BUT
YOU'VE GOT ALL YOU GOT TO LOOK
AT THE DATA YOU GOT A LOOK AT
THE COST. AT THE END OF THE DAY
FOR ME THIS IS ALL ABOUT
LEAVING SOMETHING FOR THE NEXT
GENERATION. AND WHILE IT'S VERY
VERY HARD TO SEE IN TERMS OF
WHERE THIS WAS GOING TO GO I
THINK SENATOR. THE RISE OF
SENATE VERY VERY CLEARLY IT
DOESN'T HELP. YEAH EVERY AREA
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. NOW
BUT I THINK IN TIME IT WILL
ADD- I JUST REALLY WANT TO
THANK- MISTER KELLY MR AND IT'S
FOR. A JOB WELL DONE IN- KEEP
MOVING FORWARD KEEP STAYING ON
A BUDGET THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR DODD I'M GONNA MOVE
OVER TO SENATOR DOLLY. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I. I
GUESS I JUST WANT TO MAYBE
BRING A LITTLE COMMON SENSE TO.
MAYBE LOW FARMER LOGIC SINCE
I'M A FARMER THIS. WHOLE
PROJECT IS LIKE A FARMER GOING
OUT AND TRYING. TO GROW.
SOMETHING THAT'S NEW IN THIS
FIELD. ANY IT ENISA HE HAS A
GROWN THE HIS TRY SOME NEW
BECAUSE IT'S THE NEW WAY. AND-
BUT WHEN THE CALL COMES UP IT
SNOT JR. WELL IT'S AND IT'S NOT
DUE WELL IN AND SO YOU HAVE
MAKES A DECISIONS. ALONG THE
WAY. I THINK IT'S TIME THIS
LARGE TO THIS I MEAN. WE WENT
FROM A PROMISING. TWENTY TWENTY
HIGH SPEED RAIL AND LOOK IT
DOESN'T SERVE ALL STATE I DON'T
CARE ABOUT THAT LET'S GET IT
RIGHT WERE AT. NOW 80% OF THE
COST IS ON CALIFORNIANS. MAYBE
IT'S TIME THAT WE YOU KNOW PLOW
THAT DOWN IN PLANT SOMETHING
DIFFERENT AND TAKE A MASSIVE
AMOUNT OF RESOURCES. THAT IS
BEING USED OUT OF OUR CAP AND
TRADE FUNDS AND PUT THEM TO
GOOD USE IS WHERE WE KNOW WE
CAN DO A BETTER JOB. BUT I KNOW
THE VOTERS TO PUT THIS ON THE
BALLOT BUT THEY THIS IS NOT
WHAT THEY EXPECTED I THINK THEY
WERE SOLD SOMETHING THAT.
DEFINITELY HAS NOT COME
THROUGH. AND I THINK IT'S TIME
TO THE LEGISLATURE MAYBE GOES
BACK TO THE VOTERS TO FIND OUT
IF IT'S REALLY SOMETHING THEY
WANT TO. CONTINUE WITH BECAUSE
AT THE END OF THE DAY. I DON'T
BELIEVE. WILL EVER SEE THIS
COMPLETED IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
A DOUBLE TRACK. AND NOW WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A SINGLE TRACK.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TIMES. FOR
TRAINS TO MOVEPEOPLE THAT ARE
GOING TO MOVE HIM IN THE FACE
IN THE FASHION THAT. WAS
PROMISED AND SO I THINK IT'S
TIME THAT YOU KNOW FOR ME I'M
READY TO WALK AWAY FROM IT BEEN
READY TO WALK AWAY FOR AWHILE
AND I SERVE ON THE SENATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION AND
YOU KNOW WE CAN BLAME CODE FOR
EVERYTHING BUT AT THE END OF
THE DAY THIS ISN'T A COVERT
PROBLEM. THIS IS A PROBLEM WITH
BEING ABLE TO DELIVER
SOMETHING. IN A TIMELY MANNER
AND THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO BE
PARTNERS THAT ARE WERE BEING.
WE'RE GOING TO BE AVAILABLE
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE PRIVATE.
INVESTMENT WE HAVE NOT SEEN AND
WE WON'T SEE SO I THINK IT'S
TIME THAT WE JUST DO A REALITY
CHECK HERE MAYBE PLOW THIS BILL
DOWN. AND GO TO SOMETHING
DIFFERENT BECAUSE- AT THE END
OF THE DAY. WE'RE ALL GOING TO
BE SITTING HERE FOR I GOT THREE
MORE YEARS OF THIS TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR I'M OUT HERE AND I
WILL GUARANTEE YOU. I WOULD BET
MY WHOLE FORM ON IT THAT WE
WON'T BE WHERE WE'RE SAYING
WE'RE GOING TO BE TODAY. IN
FOUR MORE YEARS. OR IN TEN
YEARS. AND THE COST WILL
CONTINUE TO RISE IN THERE
ALWAYS BE A REASON THAT IT
DOESN'T WORK OUT. I THINK THE
VOTERS A CALIFORNIA. REALLY
DON'T LIKE THIS PROJECT AND I
THINK THEY'RE REALLY WAKING UP
TO THE FACT. THAT WE CONTINUE.
TO JUST LISTEN TO THIS.
NARRATIVE THAT IT'S GOING TO.
IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN SOONER.
AND IT ISN'T. LET'S BE REAL
HERE. SO I JUST WANT TO GET IT
ON THE RECORD THAT HATE. THIS
PROJECT. IS A BOONDOGGLE. AND
IS NOT GOING TO DO WHAT. THEY
SAY IT'S GOING TO DO. SO FOR
THOSE REASONS I THINK WE SHOULD
JUST SCRAP THIS WHOLE PROCESS
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
SENATOR DOLLY FOR COMMENTS I
BELIEVE US SENATOR NEWMAN. DID
YOU HAVE YOUR MAKE UP I DO
THAT. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR BY
I WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
MY COLLEAGUE CENTER DIED. AND
SENATOR RISE SO- I APPRECIATE.
SENATOR DONNELLY'S COMMENTS- I
THINK IT'S ALSO TRUE. THAT WE
ARE NOT WHERE WE WANTED TO BE-
BUT WE ARE FULLY INVESTED AS A
STATE IN THIS PROJECT. THAT WE
ARE IN FACT MAKING PROJECT
PROGRESS. THE AND IS SENATOR
DODD MENTIONED WE ARE IN GOOD
HANDS- WAS SECRETARY. A KELLY-
AND BRIAN ANDERSON- AND SO WE
NEED TO. THE NONE OF US SEE THE-
OF THIS PROJECT DURING A TERMS
IN OFFICE. BUT THE STATE WILL.
AND OUR JOB IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT DOES THANK YOU MENTION.
THANK YOU SENATOR NEWMAN
SENATOR AKOWSKI. R. D. THE
REPORT POINTS OUT THAT THE
HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVEN SEGMENT.
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO BE
ACCOMPLISHED BE BEYOND THE
FUNDING FROM THE PROP ONE A. R.
A AND THE CAP AND TRADE
PROGRAMS AT THE PIER THIRTY ONE
OF THE SLIDES THAT YOU HAD
UPSET THAT MIGHT BE THAT MIGHT
BE POSSIBLE WITHIN THE IF WE
HAD IF WE HIT THE OLD LOW
AMOUNT. PUTTING ASIDE ANY
ASSISTANCE FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THE. THE N.
ACCEPTING THE. THE REPORT THAT
PRIVATE INVESTMENT IS PROBABLY
AT BEST THREE OR FIVE YEARS OFF
WHAT. MAY YOU SAY ABOUT THE NEW
STATE SOURCES OF FUNDING WHICH
THE REVIEW IDENTIFIES AS A GAS
TAX SALES TAX VEHICLE TEXTURE
TEXT EXCEPT THE ROCK CENTER-
THAT MIGHT BE A SOURCE OF
FUNDING AND WHAT WOULD YOU WHAT
WOULD BE YOUR PITCH SAID
LEGISLATURE. WELL FIRST I WANT
TO JUST CLARIFY A POINT I THINK
THAT B. THE ESTIMATE THAT WE
HAVE IN OUR BUSINESS PLAN DOES
NOT RELY. ON NEW SOURCES OF
STATE REVENUE FOR THE MADERA TO
BAKERSFIELD STRETCH THERE ARE
AND WE DO ARE CLEAR THAT WE
NEED EVERY DIME WE HAVE TO
BUILD THAT THAT SEGMENT. AND
ONE OF THE REASONS I HEARD IT
MENTIONED THAT- YOU KNOW IT'S
NOW A ONE TRACK SYSTEM AGAIN I
WANT TO BE CLEAR ULTIMATELY THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL SYSTEM WILL BE
A TWO TRACK. SYSTEM BUT THE
QUESTION IS AND THE APPROACH
HERE IS TO WORK TOWARD AN
OPERATING SEGMENT IN A WAY THAT
WORKS WITHIN OUR BUDGET AND
BELOW TODAY. WE HAVE A KNOWN
ESTIMATE OF REVENUE BETWEEN
TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY THREE
BILLION. DOLLARS AND OUR
INTENTION IS TO- PUT IN PLACE
AN OPERATING SEGMENT BETWEEN
CITIES THAT. CAN BE DONE FOR
THAT UP THAT MAY MEAN THAT WE
FACED THE TRACK WE'RE GOING TO
HELP OUR BIDDERS. INCLUDING IN
THEIR BIDS WHAT EACH ELEMENT
WOULD LOOK LIKE ONE TRACK NOW
THE SECOND TRACK LATER VERSES
TO TRACKS NOW SO WE CAN MAKE AN
EDUCATED DECISION- BUT WE ARE
NOT. I'M NOT ADVOCATING FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL. THEY FUNDING ONE OF
THE THAT WE SAY THIS BUSINESS
PLAN AND WE SAID IN PRIOR
BUSINESS PLANS. BECAUSE WE GET
A PORTION OF CAP AND TRADE
FUNDS NOW. MAKING THAT REVENUE
SOURCE MORE STABLE AND SECURE
IS IMPORTANT. SO IF THE
LEGISLATURE AND ONE OF THE MOST
STABILIZING THINGS THE
LEGISLATURE EVER DID. FOR THE
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM WAS
EXTENDED TO TWENTY THIRTY. IF
THERE IS AN ADDITIONAL
EXTENSION- THIS PROJECT WOULD
BENEFIT GREATLY FROM. THE
ABILITY TO FINANCE OFF OF THAT
REVENUE. STREAM SO WE CAN BRING
DOLLARS FORWARD SOONER. AND SO
AN EXTENSION OF CAP AND TRADE
BEYOND TWENTY THIRTY WOULD BE
STABILIZING. THE ABILITY TO
FINANCE OFFER THAT WOULD BE
STABILIZING. THAT WOULD
CERTAINLY ALLEVIATE ANY BUDGET
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT THE MERCED
BAKERSFIELD. STRETCH TODAY. YOU
KNOW TALKING ABOUT NEW. FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR- FROM STATE
RESOURCES FOR THIS PROJECT. I
CANDIDLY WOULD WAIT AND SEE
WHERE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
ON THIS- I DISAGREE WITH THE.
THE CHARACTERIZATION THAT THE
PROJECT HAS NOT GOTTEN ARE NOT
SOUGHT OR RECEIVED HELP FROM
OTHER SOURCES WE HAVE RECEIVED
THREE AND A HALF BILLION
DOLLARS. FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ON THIS PROJECT WE
ARE WORKING WITH THE BUYING
TEAM TO ENSURE WE KEEP EVERY
DIME OF THAT. AND I THINK AS WE
GO FORWARD CALIFORNIA ALL OF US
POLICY MAKERS ME MY BOARD. THIS
GOVERNOR WE WOULD ALL BENEFIT
FROM UNDERSTANDING WHERE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS ON THIS
TECHNOLOGY IN THIS PROGRAM.
GOING FORWARD BEFORE I WOULD
SEEK ADDITIONAL. STATE
RESOURCES BEYOND WHAT'S ALREADY
DEDICATED TO THE PROGRAM. BOB
THANK YOU MISTER KELLY THANK
YOU SENATOR AKOWSKI OGLE- NEXT
TO SENATOR MEN. THANK YOU
MISTER KELLY I APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY AND I
APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE TIME
TO SIT DOWN WITH ME EARLIER
THIS WEEK ON SOON- TO GO OVER
THIS. I'M NEW TO THIS ISSUE- I
HAVE TO ADMIT IS A FORMER NON
ELECTED AS A LAY PERSON I WAS
STRUCK BY THE HIGH COSTS. WE'VE
ALL READ ABOUT- IT THE SOARING
COSTS OF THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
PROJECT IN- I APPRECIATED YOUR
EXPLANATION MEAN I WAS HOPING
YOU JUST MIGHT REPEAT THAT IN
BRIEF. WHAT WOULD YOU SAY WERE
THE COST DRIVERS HE MAIN
LESSONS YOU TOOK AWAY FROM OUR
PREVIOUS EXPERIENCES WITH HIGH
SPEED RAIL AND WHAT ARE YOU
DOING TO CORRECT THAT. THANK
YOU CENTER I WOULD CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THAT QUESTION. A LOT
WE HAVE. THE FIRST BUSINESS
PLAN I PUT OUT SINCE I'VE BEEN
HERE TWENTY EIGHTEEN. AT AN
ENTIRE CHAPTER IN A COLD SWEAT
LESSONS LEARNED. AND THE KEY
LESSON LEARNED ON THIS PROJECT
WAS. WHEN CONSTRUCTION FIRST
STARTED THERE WAS A LOT OF
PRESSURE TO SPEND. THE
AVAILABLE FEDERAL FUNDS AND I
SHOULD SAY THAT AT THAT TIME.
BECAUSE OF LITIGATION THE
AUTHORITY DID NOT HAVE ACCESS
TO OTHER STATE FUNDS AVAILABLE
FOR THE PROJECT. SO WE HAD DID
THEY THEY HAD TO RELY AT THAT
TIME ON AVAILABLE FEDERAL FUNDS
THAT ALSO HAD. A SPECIFIC
DEADLINE BY WHICH THOSE HAD TO
BE SPENT- AND SO WE GOT THEY
GOT A NEW CONSTRUCTION A LITTLE
AT A SEQUENCE IS HOW I WOULD
DESCRIBE- IT MEANS THAT THEY
STARTED CONSTRUCTION WHERE THEY
COULD- BUT IT WAS A BIT AT
RISK. AND WHEN I SAY THAT RISK
I MEAN. THEY GOT INTO
CONSTRUCTION BEFORE THE
ENTIRETY OF THE- SEGMENTS WERE
FULLY DESIGNED. FOR ALL THE
RIGHT AWAY NEEDS WERE
UNDERSTOOD. AND AS A RESULT OF
THAT OVER TIME- THERE'S BEEN
SCHEDULE DELAYS AS CONTRACTORS
HAVE BEEN WAITING FOR RIGHT
AWAY. AND AS DESIGN
CONSIDERATIONS HAVE BEEN
FURTHER FURTHER REVIEW- I WILL
SAY THAT THOSE DESIGN
CONSIDERATIONS ARE. NOT JUST
THE- FAULT OF ANYONE PARTY BUT
WHEN YOU DESIGN AND PUT IN
PLACE A PROGRAM LIKE THIS YOU
NEGOTIATE. WITH LOCAL PARTNERS
CITIES AND COUNTIES THE FREIGHT
UTILITIES AND OTHERS WHO ALL
PUSH FOR VARIOUS GO CHANGES.
THOSE WERE NOT ALL IN PLACE AT
THAT TIME WHEN I STARTED HERE.
THE CENTRAL VALLEY SEGMENT WAS
45% DESIGN. IT'S HARD TO KNOW
HOW MUCH RIGHT AWAY YOU
ACTUALLY NEED. WHEN YOU'RE ONLY
THAT FAR ALONG. TODAY WE ARE
95% DESIGN WE KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
WE NEED. TO GET TO CONSTRUCTION
AND FINISH THIS WORK- AND WE
ARE NOW OPERATING IN A WAY. TO
GET THAT DONE THE SECOND THING
I WOULD SAY SO THAT'S KIND OF
WHERE WE WERE ON THIS PROJECT
AND HOW IT GOT STARTED. TODAY
AS I SAID WE HAVE THE RIGHT
AWAY BETTER IN HAND. WE ARE
NEARLY A 100% DESIGN WILL BE BY
APRIL- AND GOING FORWARD. TO
ENSURE THAT WE WILL NOT MAKE
THE SAME MISTAKES CHAPTER SIX
OF OUR BUSINESS PLAN. TALKS
ABOUT A COUPLE THINGS WE'RE
PUTTING IN PLACE. A ONE IS AN
ENTERPRISE RISK MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM FOR THE AUTHORITY. WILL
DO MORE DISCIPLINED WORK ON
UNDERSTANDING WHAT RISKS. ARE
IN FRONT OF IT. THE WORST
AVERAGING A RISK COMMITTEE THAT
WILL REPORT PUBLICLY TO OUR
BOARD. ABOUT WHERE WE SEE RISKS
AND WHAT MITIGATION MEASURES
WERE PUTTING IN IN PLACE
SOONER- AND SECONDLY AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY. AS WE GET INTO THE
FUTURE CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS-
WE ARE INSTIGATING SOMETHING
CALLED A STAGE GATE.
PROCUREMENT PROCESS WHICH
MEANS. WE WILL ONLY DO THIS IN
METHODICAL SORT OF INCREMENTAL
PIECES. THE FIRST IS TO GET THE
DESIGN WORK FURTHER ADVANCED.
IDENTIFY THE RIGHT AWAY THAT
YOU NEED TO UNDERSTAND THE
UTILITIES THAT NEED TO BE
RELOCATED. AND DO THOSE THINGS
FIRST. THEN WE'LL MOVE TO WHAT
WE CALL THE EARLY WORKS WHICH
IS ACTUALLY STARTING TO
PROCURE. THAT RGHT AWAY AND
STARTING TO EXECUTE THIRD PARTY
AGREEMENTS AND START TO MOVE-
THE- UTILITIES THAT NEED TO BE
MOVED- AND THEN AND ONLY THEN
WILL WE GET INTO. A
CONSTRUCTION A PROCUREMENT
CONTRACTS AND SO CONSTRUCTION
WILL NOT COMMENCE AT RISK LIKE
IT DID BEFORE. YEAH AND- WE
WILL MOVE FORWARD IN A MUCH
MORE METHODICAL WAY THAT I
THINK WE'LL HAVE THIS NOT
REPEAT. THE MISTAKES OF THE
PAST. THANK YOU I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT AND THAT MR
KELLY IN THAT- I THINK YOU HAVE
A SWEET A LOT OF MY CONCERNS
OBVIOUSLY THERE WERE A LOT OF
MISTAKES MADE PREVIOUSLY WITH
THIS PROJECT. I'LL THIS
EDITORIALIZED DURING SAY THAT.
YOU KNOW THIS COUNTRY AND THIS
STATE USED TO BE KNOWN FOR ITS
LEADERSHIP ON INFRASTRUCTURE WE
CREATED THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
WAS A CLASS OF THE WORLD. AND
NOW WE'RE SAYING THAT SOMETHING
OTHER COUNTRIES ARE DOING THAT
IS STANDARD ACROSS THE WORLD.
IT'S SOMETHING WE CAN'T DO. AND
TO ME THAT'S NOT AMERICAN WAY
THAT'S NOT THIS. THAT MAY THIS
KIND AFTER SUPERPOWER THAT IT
IS AND TO BUILD ON THE ANALOGY
USED BY MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BEAVER. I DON'T THINK AMERICA
IN CALIFORNIA GOT TO WHERE WE
ARE BY GIVING UP BECAUSE THEY
CROP DIDN'T SUCCEED. WE GOT TO
WHERE WE ARE BY LEARNING FROM
OUR LESSONS IN OUR MISTAKES.
AND SAY WE CAN'T DO THIS WE
HAVE A PRESIDENT RIGHT NOW THAT
WANTS TO BUILD FIRST CLASS
INFRASTRUCTURE UNITED STATES. A
WE HAVE A SPARE RIGHT NOW THAT
SAYS WE CAN'T DO THIS. AND WE
WANT TO LEAVE SOMETHING BEHIND
BUILDING ON MY COLLEAGUE FROM
NAPA'S ANALOGY. WE WANT TO
LEAVE SOMETHING MEANING FOR
THAT FOR NEXT GENERATION THIS
IS OUR OPPORTUNITY. IF WE STAY
WITH THE STATUS QUO WE'RE
LEAVING BEHIND TRAFFIC AND
GRIDLOCK. AND HIGH GHG EMITTING
INFRASTRUCTURE. THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO REALLY
MAKE CALIFORNIA A LEADER AGAIN
SO I STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS PROJECT. THANK YOU MANAGER.
THANK YOU SENATOR MEN AND GREAT
QUESTION IT'S REALLY GOOD TO
HEAR ABOUT THE RISK MITIGATION
COMMITTEE- AND THE WORK THEY
WILL DO AHEAD SO. I'M GOING O
GO NEXT TO SENATOR RUBIO- AND
THEN TO UP TO TWO OTHER
SENATORS. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND DIVE WANTED JUST LINE MY
COMMENTS WITH THE SENATOR FROM-
MISTER MAN I JUST WANTED TO
THINK- FIRST OF ALL THE CHAIR
IN THE YOU KNOW CO CHAIR FOR
PUTTING THIS TOGETHER AND I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
LEARN ABOUT IT- AND I
UNDERSTAND ALL THE CONCERNS UP
AND STATED AS A PERTAINS TO A
FUNDING ISSUE SCHEDULING ISSUES
DESIGN ISSUES BY THE END OF THE
DAY I THINK THAT THIS IS SUCH
AN IMPORTANT PROJECT FOR
CALIFORNIA YOU KNOW WE'VE
CERTAINLY NEED CONNECTIVITY
ACROSS THE STATE WE NEED SPEED.
AND THERE WILL BE CHALLENGES
BUT AT THE SAME TIME T IS
STILL IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT WILL
CREATE SO MANY GOOD PAYING JOBS
AND IT WILL DEFINITELY- AND
VITALITY TO OUR ECONOMY
ESPECIALLY AT A TIME WHEN WE
NEED IT BUT YOU KNOW I WANTED
TO YOU KNOW SHARE I KNOW THAT
MANY HAVE STATED THAT WE WILL
NOT ENJOY THE BENEFITS OF THIS
PROJECT AND WE MAY NOT SEE IT
BUT YOU KNOW THROUGHOUT HISTORY
WE HAVE PROJECTS THAT HAVE
DEALT WITH RESISTANCE YOU KNOW
LIKE THE SIXTEEN CHAPEL THERE
WAS RESISTANCE THERE BUT YET
GENERATIONS HAVE ENJOYED YOU
KNOW THE BEAUTY OF WHAT IS THE
SIXTEENTH CHAPEL NOW INSULT
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT I THINK
IS NOT NECESSARY FOR US BUT- WE
DEFINITELY WANT TO LEAVE
SOMETHING FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS TO BE ABLE TO. TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF BUT I DO HAVE ONE
PARTICULAR QUESTION IF I MAY-
UM I KNOW WE'VE HEARD ALL THE
RESISTANCE ON THE CONCERNED AND
THEY'RE VALID IS THERE ANY
PUBLIC CAMPAIGN THAT'S PLANNED
TO EDUCATE CALIFORNIANS SHARE
WHAT'S GOING ON AS A PERTAINS
TO THIS PROJECT ENGAGE LOCAL
MUNICIPALITIES. CAN SOMEONE
ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU SEE WHAT RUBIO DISTRICT MR
GALLAGHER HAD. I APOLOGIZE- I
WILL DO THAT YEAH. THE BEST I
CAN TO SORT OF ANSWER THAT YOU
KNOW WE- YUP WE HAVE AN
EXTENSIVE STAKEHOLDER OUTREACH
A PROCESS- OUR YOU KNOW ODDLY
AND BENEFICIALLY THROUGH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROCESS IS ALSO.
A WAY THAT WE ENGAGE WITH THE
COMMUNITIES ON WHERE WE ARE BUT
I WANTED AND SO THERE'S A
CONSTANT AND CONTINUOUS
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW THE
PROJECT WILL DEVELOP. AS IT
GETS BEYOND THE VALLEY IN THE
BAY AREA AND INTO THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA REGION WE DO A LOT
OF WORK WITH OUR COMMUNITY
PARTNERS AND- CITIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE ON STATION PLANNING.
A WHICH IS. A BIG AND IMPORTANT
PART OF THEIR COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT AND OBVIOUSLY A
VERY IMPORTANT PART OF OUR
FUTURE OPERATIONAL. SYSTEM WE
ALSO PROVIDE- THROUGH OUR
WEBSITE A SERIES OF. DATA A
POINTS THINGS LIKE- UPDATES ON
WHERE WE ARE WE DO HAVE
CONSTRUCTION UPDATE- VIDEO OF
THAT WE UPDATE CONSTANTLY-
THERE ARE SERIES OF VIDEOS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE AND YOU TO BETTER
WEBSITE. ABOUT THE ADVANCEMENT
OF THE PROJECT- AND SO THERE'S
A SORT OF A CONTINUING. EFFORT
TO EXPAND THE WORD. AS WE
ADVANCE THAT CAN FURTHER IN THE
VALLEY- YOU THEY'LL BE MORE
MORE. EVIDENCE OF THAT AND OF
COURSE WE ALSO REPORT PUBLICLY
WHERE WE ARE AT EACH OF OUR
BOARD HEARINGS EACH MONTH
INVITE THE PUBLIC TO
PARTICIPATE IN THOSE- AND THE
REPORTS THAT WE ISSUE TO THE
LEGISLATURE EACH YEAR. A
PROVIDE A CONSTANT UPDATE OF
WHERE WE ARE SO THERE'S-
SEVERAL THINGS WE BRING TO
THIS- I THINK AS WE- ARE IN THE
COMING MONTHS FORMULATE A
CLEAR. A PICTURE WITH OUR
FEDERAL PARTNERS I THINK YOU'LL
BE. THE REASON HAND AND
EVIDENCE OF HIGHLIGHTED- SORT
OF. A PROGRESS GOING FORWARD
AND SO I THINK THAT'S THE BEST
I CAN SAY ABOUT IT AT THIS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND AGAIN
AND I THAT'S YOU'RE DOING
FANTASTIC WORK IN TERMS OF
REACHING OUT BUT- YOU KNOW
ORDINARY CITIZENS SOMETIMES
DON'T GET THE BENEFIT OF THIS
INFORMATION UNLESS YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR IT AND I THINK IT
WOULD BE IMPORTANT. AT SOME
POINT TO FIGURE OUT A STRATEGIC
PLAN TO ENSURE THAT. THE
ORDINARY CITIZEN HERE'S THIS
INFORMATION AND REALLY
UNDERSTANDS THE BENEFIT TO.
CALIFORNIA AS A WHOLE BUT I'LL
LEAVE IT AT THAT THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO SENATOR CORTESE. THANK
YOU VENTURE. TO ME JUST SAY. I
HAVE A QUESTION FOR MR CAL
ABILITY JUST SAY. OF FIRST OF
ALL THAT- I DO BELIEVE THAT
ALTERNATELY- THE VISION FOR
FUTURE SHOULD INCLUDE. THIS
PROJECT AS ORIGINALLY
ENVISIONED- I AND I THINK IT'S
A MATTER OF COMPETITIVENESS
FOR. OUR CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN I'D AGREE WITH-
CENTER NEWMAN'S- NOTION THAT
THE THIS IS THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING. WE SEE TO FRUITION
PER IN OUR TENURE NECESSARILY.
IT'S GOING TO BE LOOKED AT AS-
WHETHER OR NOT WE WANT OUR
GRANDCHILDREN TO BE COMPETING.
WITH THOSE. CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN OTHER PLACES IN
THE WORLD WHERE THEY'VE
SUCCESSFULLY CONNECTED MAJOR
ACADEMIC CENTERS A MAJOR
ECONOMIC CENTERS- WITH WITH
THIS KIND OF HIGH SPEED
TECHNOLOGY THAT SAID- SENATOR
DOLLARS COMMENTS ABOUT THE MOOD
OF THE STATE IN THE DISRUPTIONS
OF THE PROJECT ARE WELL TAKEN.
AND WHEN I LISTEN TO THE
PRESENTATION- HAVING BEEN A
LOCAL OFFICIAL. A REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION OFFICIALS AND
LOCAL TRANSPORTATION OFFICIALS
FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS.
CERTAINLY TRACKING THIS PROJECT
ALONG. IT'S HARD TO UNDERSTAND
HOW A DECISION. LIKE THE END
POINT OF THE PROJECT BEING IN
AN ORCHARD OR IN DOWNTOWN
BAKERSFIELD. TAKES THIS LONG TO
MAKE. IN IN IN JUST I HEARD.
ESADE AND REITERATE YOU KNOW
THERE'S A NEW SHERIFF IN TOWN
THERE'S A NEW- THERE'S NEW
LEADERSHIP- DESIGN IS NOW
ADVANCED- BUT THAT'S THAT'S AN-
AWFUL LONG TIME TO. TAKE TO
MAKE A FUNDAMENTAL DECISION AS
TO WERE. THE START POINT
STOPPED PLANNING IS FOR THE
PROJECT SPECIALLY WHEN THE
CHOICES ARE THAT STARK IN THAT
OBVIOUS. SO MY QUESTION IS
WHICH I THINK IS ON THE MIND OF
ALL CALIFORNIANS WHAT ASSURANCE
CAN YOU GIVE US. IN AN ETHNIC I
KNOW PART OF THE ANSWER IS. HI
BRIAN KELLY I'M HERE NOW. BUT
THIS PROJECT IS GOING TO WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT GO WELL BEYOND
THE TENURE NOT ONLY OF THE
SENATE BUT OF THOSE FOLKS WHO
ARE RUNNING THE PROJECT NOW
WHAT ASSURANCE CAN YOU GIVE US.
THAT THE PEOPLE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ARE NOT GOING TO BE
DISAPPOINTED OVER AND OVER AND
OVER AGAIN WITH NOT JUST CHANGE
ORDERS BUT CHANGE OF DESIGN AND
CHANGE OF VISION OF THE PROJECT.
I THANK YOU SENATOR I
APPRECIATE THAT THE QUESTION.
YOU KNOW I THINK THE CHALLENGE
DOZENS OF FIRST I WANT TO
ESTABLISH- WHY WHY THERE'S THE
HUNDRED NINETY MILE FOOTPRINT
THE FIRST. UP THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT- APPLIED FOR
VARIOUS SEGMENTS TO START
CONSTRUCTION ON THIS PROJECT
AROUND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THE FRA
IN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AT
THAT TIME AWARDED A CALIFORNIA
TWO AND A HALF BILLION DOLLARS
TO START UP IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY SEGMENT WHERE WE
STARTED- THAT WAS BECAME
DEFINED IN AGREEMENTS. BETWEEN
THE AUTHORITY THE STATE AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. SO THAT
INITIAL STRETCH THAT HUNDRED
NINETY MILES WAS THE FIRST
CONSTRUCTION SEGMENT THAT. THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT REQUIRED-
CALIFORNIA TO COMMENCE- TO DO
WORK ON AND TO- TO DEVELOP.
YEAH AND THAT IS THEWORK THAT
WE HAVE HAD. UNDER WAY- SINCE
THAT SINCE THAT INITIAL
AGREEMENT CNSTRUCTION
COMMENCED WITH A UP GROUND
BREAKING IN IN IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN SO UNDER OUR FEDERAL
FUNDING AGREEMENT. WE GOTTA
FINISH THE CIVIL WORKS THAT
HUNDRED NINETEEN WE HAVE TO LAY
A TRACK ON THAT HUNDRED
NINETEEN AND WE FINISH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORK EVERYWHERE
STATEWIDE FROM SAN FRANCISCO TO
LA AND ANAHEIM- SO. THE CALL
HAS BECOME WHAT WE DO BEYOND
THAT ONE NINETY BECAUSE THAT
HUNDRED NINETEEN. THAT PICTURE
I USED IN THE PRESENTATION WAS
DESIGNED TO SHOW YOU KNOW IT IS
NOT. THE PREMIER OPERATING
SEGMENT- THE END SO YOU KNOW
WHAT DO YOU DO BE ON YOUR
FEDERAL MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS
AND DO YOU HAVE FUNDING. TO GET
A BETTER OPERATIONAL RUN GOING-
BEAMER SAID TO BAKERSFIELD-
CONTEMPLATION IS HAS GONE
THROUGH NOW ANALYSIS AND PEER
REVIEW IT'S ESTIMATED TO NEARLY
DOUBLE THE SYSTEM WIDE
RIDERSHIP IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
TODAY WITH JUST THE SAN
JOAQUIN'S. UP SERVICE IT'S
THERE. AND IT WILL REDUCE
TRAVEL TIME SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASE RIDERSHIP
SIGNIFICANTLY SO IT WAS US YOU
KNOW ARE COMING FORWARD WITH
HOW DO WE GET SOMETHING THAT'S
OPERATIONALLY BETTER- INSTILL.
YOU KNOW WE HOPE ACHIEVABLE- IN
IN THE BUDGET WE HAVE WHAT WHAT
WE ALSO LIVE WITH A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY AND I WHAT I MEAN
BY THAT IS. YOU KNOW OUR CAP
AND TRADE DOLLARS ARE HAVE BEEN
BOLA TIE WITH CERTAIN TIME
CERTAINLY BEFORE WE EXTENDED IT
TO. TWENTY THIRTY WAS ALL THE
TILE AND CERTAINLY THE
UNEXPECTED GLOBAL PANDEMIC AND
IMPACT ON THOSE BUT IF THOSE
DAYS STATE STABLE- AND WE
RECEIVE THAT FUNDING BETWEEN
NOW AND TWENTY THIRTY- WE DO
FEEL LIKE WE CAN GET AN
OPERATION RUN. IT GOING BETWEEN
MERCED AND BAKERSFIELD AS THE
FIRST BUILDING BLOCK AND I
GUESS THAT'S THE OTHER POINT I
WANT TO MAKE. THIS IS NOT THE
END OF THE SYSTEM IT'S THE B.
BEGINNING. LIKE MOST TRANSIT
SYSTEMS AROUND. YOU KNOW TAKE
BART IN THE BAYAREA YOU KNOW
INITIALLY BAR WAS FUNDED AND
CONSTRUCTED AS A MOSTLY EAST
BAY INTO SAN FRANCISCO COMMUTER
SEGMENT. NOW IT TOUCHES UP.
MORE CHARGES WERE EVERY AIRPORT
IN THE BAY AREA AND EXTENDS NOW
INTO SENATE CLEARANCE AND WE
SAN JOSE. IT IS NOW GOING ALL
THROUGHOUT THE BAY AREA THE
RIDERSHIP NUMBERS ARE MUCH
DIFFERENT THAN THEY WERE AFTER
THEIR FIRST BUILDING BLOCK. SO
SIMILAR WE ARE CONSTRAINED BY
BUDGET. AND WE HAVE TO
ARTICULATE WHAT THE NEXT
SEGMENT PIECES ARE. WE GET A
LONG TERM FEDERAL FUNDING
PARTNER ON THIS. I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO GETTING INTO THE BAY
AREA SOONER- BECAUSE THAT'S
WHEN RIDERSHIP NUMBERS REALLY.
GO NORTH. NAY IN A BIG WAY- BUT
WE HAVE ENOUGH TO GET AN
OPERATING SEGMENT GOING NOW-
WHAT I CAN. YOU KNOW I DON'T
MAKE GUARANTEES BUT WHAT I CAN
SAY IS THAT- I WILL ALWAYS
EXPRESS IN A TIMELY WAY WHAT
ARE. THE OPPORTUNITIES AND
CHALLENGES ARE. AND WE ARE
COMMITTED TO GET THIS
OPPORTUNITY SEGMENT GOING IN
THE VALLEY. AND WILL. USE OUR
BEST JUDGMENT GOING FORWARD
ABOUT HOW TO ACHIEVE THAT.
KNOWING THAT ULTIMATELY WE'RE
STILL HEADED. FOR A SAN
FRANCISCO TO LOS ANGELES RUN.
THAT CAN MOVE PEOPLE BETWEEN
THOSE TWO POINTS IN UNDER THREE
HOURS. WE HAVE TO START
SOMEWHERE WE ONLY HAVE SO MUCH
BUDGET TODAY. AND WE'RE
APPLYING THAT BUDGET IN A WAY
TO GET AN OPERATING RUN GOING
AS SOON AS WE CAN. RECOGNIZING
THAT WE THEN WANT TO EXPAND OUT
TO FULFILL THE VISION THAT WAS
IN. THE. BOND FUND FROM A TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT. THANK YOU
MISTER KELLY SENATOR DID YOU
HAVE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. RIGHT I DO BUT WITH
RESPECT TO YOUR ORIGINAL
INSTRUCTIONS- ALL HOLD OFF
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR QUESTIONS- SENATOR
ARCHULETA. THANK YOU- MADAM
CHAIR. I THINK BRINGING US ALL
TOGETHER- AND OBVIOUSLY- WITH
THE- THE CHAIR AND ON THE
BUDGET- SENATOR RUSSELL JIM
FORTIN YOUR COMMENT. AND IT
HOME BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT
YOU ASKED ABOUT SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. SO MY QUESTION IS-
MANY BUT YOU ANSWERED SO MANY
IT WHAT A GREAT PRESENTATION.
YOU AND LIKE MAY ON WHERE WE
ARE IN OUR STATUS MISTER KELLY
THE THING IS THAT I THINK
PERCEPTION VERSUS FACT. THE
PERCEPTION YOU'VE HEARD THE
NEGATIVE- YOU CAN HEAR AND FEEL
THE POSITIVE. BUT THE GENERAL
PUBLIC IS LOOKING FOR THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL TO BE COMPLETED AND
WHEN. AND AS AN EXAMPLE WHEN
YOU STARTED THERE WAS A-
MENTION OF TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS THAT. WAS
LOST BECAUSE OF PANDEMIC BUT
IT'LL BE MADE UP. MY QUESTION
IS HOW- AND HOW QUICKLY CAN WE
GO AHEAD AND NOW XCELERATED.
THE CONSTRUCTION ACCELERATE-
THE OVERALL PLANS NOW THAT
WE'RE CLOSING THE DOOR ON THE
PANDEMIC HOPEFULLY SO WHAT DOES
THAT LOOK LIKE OVER THE NEXT
THREE YEARS AND I'M NOT ASKING
FOR FIVE OR TEN BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY IT'S GONNA TAKE A
LITTLE WHILE. TO LOOK BACK AT
THE PANDEMIC AND RECOVER FROM
IT SO GIVE ME AN IDEA OF WHAT
IT LOOKS LIKE OVER THE NEXT
THREE YEARS AND FINISH WITH-
HOW IT CAN HELP THE SOUTHERN%
CALIFORNIA ISSUES- WITH
TRANSPORTATION AS WE'RE GOING
ALONG. THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
THINK THE FIRST ISSUE I WOULD
ADDRESS WAS THE QUESTION ABOUT
THE- CAP AND TRADE REVENUE WE
DID TAKE A HIT IN TWENTY TWENTY
BECAUSE THE OPTIONS.
PARTICULARLY THE SINGULAR
AUCTION RIGHT AFTER THEY OPEN.
A PANDEMIC STRUCK IN MARCH OF
TWENTY. I THINK THAT SUBSEQUENT
AUCTION WAS MAY AND IN THAT ARE
SHOULD WE- RECEIVED ONLY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THIS
PROJECT OUT OF THAT ARCHER. NOW
TYPICALLY WE HAD BEEN ON A PACE
WHERE WE WERE RECEIVING MORE
LIKE A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
MILLION PER AUCTION. AND IN
THAT WHEN WE GET SIX SO.
SUBSEQUENT AUCTIONS HAVE GOTTEN
BETTER THE CAP AND TRADE MARKET
IS STABILIZING. YEAH BY
EVIDENCE OF THE SUBSEQUENT
AUCTIONS THAT ARE BROUGHT THE-
REVENUE BACK. TO OUR PROGRAM
HEADING BACK TO WHERE IT WAS
PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC. THE
REASON WE SAY WE ULTIMATELY
WILL MAKE UP A LARGE PART OF
THAT TWO EIGHTY EIGHT THAT WAS
LOST. IS THE WAY THE ARCH
INWARDS WORKS THESE ALLOWANCES-
GET SOLD WHAT HAPPENED ON THE
IMMEDIATE- THE IMMEDIATE
AUCTION AFTER THE COVERT
NINETEEN WAS THAT. THOSE
ALLOWANCES DID NOT GET SOLD-
HOWEVER. OVER TIME AS LONG AS
THE AUCTIONS AND I'M NOT NOT
THIS REALLY THE EXPERT IN THIS
MARKET MECHANICS. BUT AS THOSE
AS ALL AVAILABLE ALLOWANCE
ALLOWANCES GETS SOLD IN THE
AUCTION PROCESS. YOU CAN GO
BACK AND YOU CAN SELL. SELL AND
BUY UP ALLOWANCES THAT WERE
PREVIOUSLY ON SO. AND SO OUR
EXPECTATION JUST AS WE- SAW SAW
BEFORE- IS THAT GOING FORWARD-
THE ALLOWANCES WILL. GET SOLD.
AND WE WILL MAKE UP THE LOS. A
TWO EIGHTY A SO IT IT DOES
PRESENT A IS A FLOW. IT'S
TELLING EIGHTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLAS WITH WE'D HAVE THE BANK.
TODAY WE DO NOT AND SO AGAIN
THE WAY THE MARKET MECHANISM
WORKS WE SEE THAT GETTING THAT
OVER TIME WITH THE ALLOWANCES
GETS ALL. IN TERMS OF
DESCRIBING HOW THINGS WILL LOOK
OVER THE COURSE OF THE NEXT.
YOU YEARS AYE AYE I WOULD SAY
THIS- YOU WILL SEE IS COMPLETE.
OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS YOU
WILL SEE IS COMPLETE. THE
CONSTRUCTION WORK THAT IS
UNDERWAY CURRENTLY IN THE
VALLEY THE HUNDRED NINETY MILE.
CONSTRUCTION WORK WILL GET
DONE. WE WILL COMMENCE THE WORK
TO LAY DOWN A TRACKWE BELIEVE
THAT TRACK. SHOULD BE
ELECTRIFIED IN PREPARED. FOR A
LECTURE ELECTRIFIED SERVICES.
BOB WE HAVE TWO BIDDERS THAT
ARE OUT IN THE MARKET NOW. THAT
ARE BIDDING ON DOING THE
TRACKING SYSTEMS WORK. AND OUR
BOARD WILL RECEIVE THOSE BIDS
LATER THIS YEAR. AND WE WILL
EVALUATE HOW TO GO FORWARD ON
THOSE OUR HOPE. IS THAT WE ARE
CONSIDERING HAVING THEM BIT IT.
AS ONE TRACK FIRST AND A SECOND
TRACK LATER- THAT IS A WAY TO
SAVE SHORT TERM DOLLARS. AND
GET AN OPERATIONAL SYSTEM
GOING- BUT WE WANT TO COMPARE
WHAT THOSE COST DIFFERENCES
WILL BE. THE IDEA IS TO TAKE A
CAREFUL APPROACH ON THIS. AND
DO THIS METHODICALLY- AT THE
SAME TIME YOU WILL ALSO SEE THE
COURSE THE NEXT EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY FOUR MONTHS US COMPLETE.
THE ENVIRONMENTAL WORK FROM SAN
FRANCISCO ALL THE WAY TO LA AND
ANAHEIM. THAT IS A SIGNIFICANT
MILESTONE BECAUSE WHEN WE DO
THAT. WE CAN THEN START ON ALL
THE SEGMENTS TO ADVANCE THE
DESIGN WORK EARLY. A START TO
IDENTIFY WHAT THE NEEDS ARE IN
EACH SEGMENT. AND WHEN I SAY
NEEDS I MEAN. RIGHT AWAY MAKING
SURE THE DESIGN IS MOVING
FORWARD IN A PLACE IN A WAY
THAT IS CONSISTENT WITH
COMMUNITY WANTS. BUT AGAIN
IDENTIFYING FUTURE RIGHT AWAY
WHAT UTILITIES NEED TO BE
RELOCATED- WHAT KIND OF THIRD
PARTY AGREEMENTS DO WE HAVE TO
ENTER INTO. TO GET THAT WORK
DONE. AND REALLY AND THIS IS
IMPORTANT. ALLOWING US TO DO
THAT TRYING TO WORK SO THAT WE
CAN REFINE COST ESTIMATES AND
YOU CAN ONLY DO THAT WHEN YOU
ADVANCE THE DESIGN. FURTHER AND
SO THOSE THOSE ARE IMPORTANT
STEPS WILL BE TAKING IN EACH
SEGMENT. AS THE ENVIRONMENT
WORK. COMPLETES I WANT TO DO I
DO WANT TO SAY THIS ABOUT THE
STATEWIDE BENEFITS. MISTER
KELLY WE COULD JUST BE A LITTLE
BIT BRIEF WE HAVE THREE MORE
MEMBERS WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK AND
WE NEED WE NEED TO TURN OVER
YOUR NEXT PANEL SORRY ABOUT
THAT. OVERALL I JUST WHICH
WOULD SAY THAT THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REALIZE THERE ARE
CONSIDERABLE ECONOMIC STATEWIDE
BENEFITS. FROM THE WORK WE HAVE
GOING A LONG. STATEWIDE RIGHT
NOW WE ARE MAKING INVESTMENTS
IN PROJECTS IN THE BAY AREA AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. TODAY THE
ADDAMS OUT OF OUR PROGRAM- AND
THAT- THAT ALSO HAS INVESTMENTS
FOR EXAMPLE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA TODAY- WE'VE-
IDENTIFIED MORE THAN SEVEN
THOUSAND JOB YEARS OF
CONSTRUCTION AND ONE POINT
THREE BILLION. IN ECONOMIC
OUTPUT IT'S TRUE THE MOBILITY
BENEFITS WILL COME WHEN WE
ACTUALLY GET THERE LATER BUT
THERE ARE IMPORTANT STATEWIDE
BENEFITS THE PROGRAM. NOW THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER KELLY MR
TWO LETTER. UP YOU MENTIONED
SINGLETRACK VERSUS DOUBLE TRACK
THE SINGLE TRACK GIVE ME AN
IDEA HOW THAT ARE TO LET IF WE
CAN- JUST. KEEP IT TO ONE
QUESTION FOR EACH MEMBER WE
HAVE. THREE MORE MEMBERS WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK I'M SORRY TO CUT
YOU- ARE YOU I CHAU. OKAY I'M
SORRY THAT THE YOU VERY- AND
WE'RE A LITTLE LATE ON TIME.
NEXT PANELS- WILL GO TO OUR
NEXT FEW MEMBERS. I WILL GO TO
VICE CHAIR BATES. THANK YOU UN.
ON MADAM PRESIDENT OF THE
GERMAN- OF IN VERY QUICK TIME
I'M ON THE SINGLE TRACK ISSUE
ALSO THAT I THINK SENATOR
ARCHULETA. WANTED TO BRING UP
AND- MY QUESTION IS PROBABLY
SOMETHING THAT YOU CAN GET BACK
TO US ON BET. THE CAPITAL
INVESTMENT PLAN FOR YOUR GOING
TO COMPLETE THIS SEGMENT. WAS
JUST ONE TRACK. ABA MAKES SOME
SENSE TO CUT THE COSTS BUT AS
WE GO FORWARD. AT SOME POINT IN
TIME WE'LL BE LOOKING AT
OPERATIONS SITUATION. AND I AM
CONCERNED THAT WE WON'T BE ABLE
TO CONSIDER THIS HIGH SPEED
RAIL. AND ACTUALLY ENCOURAGE
WRITERS TO BE ON IT. AND THOSE
REVENUES WILL BE VERY VERY
IMPORTANT. IN TAKING A LOOK AT
THE REDUCTION OF THE CAPITAL
INVESTMENT. AND ALSO OPERATIONS
GOING FORWARD. SO IT'S
SOMETHING I THINK OF NOT TODAY
I'D LIKE TO HAVE A FURTHER.
DISCUSSION ON THE SITUATION.
THAT IS PROCESS PRESENTS ITSELF
WITH JUST ONE TRACK. ALSO IN
TERMS OF OUR- WRITERS OUT THERE
ARE TAXPAYERS. A CONSTITUENTS
WHO ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO. AN
ALTERNATE. TRAVEL MOTIF ALL
CROSS THE STATE. OUR THIS IS
HARDLY GOING TO MEET I THINK
WITH THE PROMISE WAS. SO I
THINK MOE EXPLANATION. ON THAT
IS DUE US AND- I WILL. ASK THE
CHAIRMAN IF WE MIGHT PUT THAT
FORWARD BECAUSE TODAY'S NOT
THE- PROBABLY PROPER PLACE TO
DISCUSS. CAPITAL VERSUS
OPERATIONS THOSE ARE ALWAYS
MAJOR MAJOR PROBLEMS WITH RAIL.
NOT ONLY IN OUR STATE BUT
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU- MADAM
VICE CHAIR I APPRECIATE THAT SO
WILL- LEAVE THAT ON HOLD FOR
NOW FOR A AT LEADER DISCUSSION
I'LL- NEXT. GO TO CHAIRED
RUSSELL- THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
OF. I THINK THAT THERE ARE. WE
CAN BE DONE BY THE- EXCITEMENT
AND THE INSPIRATION OF HAVING
THE US STATE OF A STATE WIDE A
PROJECT LIKE THIS BEING
COMPLETED AND I DO BELIEVE IN
DOING THE IMPOSSIBLE BUT I ALSO
BELIEVE IN THE- THE REALISTIC
SIDE OF MAKING SURE THAT WE DO
THE IMPOSSIBLE- IT APPEARS
THAT. FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WERE
WERE SORT OF HOPING AND PRAYING
THAT BECAUSE WE HAVE SUCH A OF
WELCOMING ADMINISTRATION AS THE
BY THE MINISTRATION THAT
SOMEHOW WE'RE GOING TO GET
FUNDING THERE WE KNOW THAT CAP
AND TRADE AS BALA TILE- I JUST
DON'T SEE THAT YOU HAVE
PROVIDED US. A PLAN THAT ON THE
ONE HAND STILL ASSUMES
COMPLETION OF THE VALLEY TO
VALLEY LINE BY TWENTY THIRTY
ONE AND THE SERVICES GO TO LA
BY TWENTY THIRTY THREE I
HAVEN'T HEARD YET REALLY HOW
WE'RE GOING TO GET THERE AND
HOW YOU GONNA MEET SUCH AN
AMBITIOUS ODD TIME LINE- AND I
THINK THAT THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF ISSUES RAISED. BY THE-
SENATOR FROM. SAN JOSE- THAT WE
REALLY HAVE TO PAY ATTENTION
TO- THE KIND OF DESIGN THAT WAS
BUILT I MEAN. YOU YOURSELF
SAID- WE'RE GONNA AND END UP
YOU KNOW ON THE FIRST FIRST
PROPOSAL WAS TO AN ORCHARD AND
UP IN AN ORCHARD I JUST. THINK
THOSE ARE VERY- IRRESPONSIBLE
SO- AGAIN IT LOOKS LIKE THERE'S
A LOT OF HOLES HERE WHEN IT
COMES TO THE FUNDING AND
WISHFUL THINKING. THANK THAT
ALSO MISTER KELLY WOULD YOU
LIKE TO RESPOND. WELL I WOULD
JUST SAY THIS- AGAIN IT'S WHY
WE ARE MOVING FORWARD IN A
BUILDING BLOCK APPROACH WE LOOK
AT THE REVENUES THAT WE SEE
AVAILABLE TO THE PROGRAM BUT
TODAY IT IS WHY WE ARE
PROPOSING TO GET BEYOND THE
HUNDRED NINETEEN MILES THAT WAS
IN THE FEDERAL GRANT AGREEMENT
AND INTO. THE CITIES OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY FOR AN OPERATING
RUN THAT MAKES SENSE THAT WOULD
GIVE CALIFORNIA'S THE
EXPERIENCE OF HIGH SPEED
ELECTRIFIED RAIL- AND WOULD
CONNECT TO IMPORTANT TRANSIT
DESTINATIONS GOING ELSEWHERE
THAT'S THE FIRST BUILDING BLOCK
THERE'S NO QUESTION AND WE SET
IT FOR MY ENTIRE TIME YEAR IN
BUSINESS PLAN AFTER BUSINESS
PLAN THAT. THE ON THAT SEGMENT
AND BEYOND OUR BUDGET WE WILL
NEED MORE BUT WE WILL NEED MORE
FOR THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. AND
OTHER PARTNERS TO COMPLETE THE
SYSTEM OUTSIDE OF THE VALLEY
SEGMENT. THAT IS TRUE I THINK
THE BEST THINGWE CAN DO IS
IMPROVE OUR PERFORMANCE ADVANCE
THAT WORK IN THE VALLEY GET A
USABLE SEGMENT GOING- AND THEN-
AND CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
FEDERAL PARTNER- TO EXPAND THE
ON- BEYOND THAT VALLEY SEGMENT-
BUT I CAN ONLY DO WITH WHAT I
HAVE AND- RIGHT NOW WEHAVE. A
WE THINK ENOUGH TO GET A
SEGMENT GOING WHERE WE ARE
CURRENTLY UNDER CONSTRUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER KELLY THANK
YOU CHAIRED THE RUSSELL AREN'T
OUR LAST QUESTION FOR THIS
PANEL WILL BE FROM SENATOR
BAKER. I IN INTERESTED TIME
O'CLOCK KEEP IT SHORT- MICHELLE
UNITES IS MENTION RIGHT AWAY SO
I JUST WANT TO MENTION WORK
THAT. CONVERSATIONS YOU AND I
HAVE HAD- JUST GIVEN THE FACT
THAT IN MY- DISTRICT WE'VE GOT
SEVERAL HOUSING PROJECTS READY
TO GO. TODAY THIRTY FIVE
HUNDRED UNITS OF HOUSING AND-
WE JUST REALLY WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE ARE NOT HELD UP BY.
THE FUTURE HIGH SPEED RAIL
PLANNING SORT PRESHOW YOUR TEAM
WORKING. WITH MY OFFICE ON THAT.
THANK YOU SENATOR BAKER GREAT
WELL THAT ENDS OUR FINAL PANEL-
WE CLEARLY HAVE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS STILL MORE QUESTIONS
TO ASK FOR FUTURE DISCUSSIONS
AS WELL SO I APPRECIATE THE
MEMBERS WHO'VE ASKED THOSE VERY
THOUGHTFUL QUESTIONS AND WE'VE
IDENTIFIED OF COURSE A LOT OF
AREAS OF OPPORTUNITY BUT ALSO A
LOT OF AREAS WHERE WE CAN FEEL
INSPIRED. A BIT- BY THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL MOVING FORWARD- SO
OUR NEXT PANEL WILL BE FROM-
WILL BE THE FISCAL AND PROGRAM
ANALYSIS OUR FIRST PANELIST IS
HELEN CAST TIME PRINCIPLE
FISCAL AND POLICY ANALYST FOR
THE L. A. O. LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE I THANK YOU I
MISS CASTING PLEASE. BEGIN GOOD
MORNING KAREN TEARS AND
SENATORS MY NAME IS HELEN
CHRISTINE WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR INVITING ME TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS MORNING'S
HEARING. I WANT TO FOCUS MY
BRIEF REMARKS ON A KEY DECISION
THAT'S FACING THE LEGISLATURE
WHICH IS HOW TO APPROACH AN
UPCOMING REQUEST FOR THE
APPROPRIATION OF ALMOST ALL OF
THE REMAINING PROPOSITION ONE A
FENCE. SO THIS UPCOMING
APPROPRIATION REQUEST PRESENTS
A NATURAL OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO EVALUATE THE
PROPOSED DIRECTION OF THE
PROJECT AND ENSURE THAT IT
ALIGNS WITH LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES. WE KNOW THAT
ANOTHER SUCH NATURAL
OPPORTUNITY MAY NOT EMERGE FOR
SEVERAL YEARS. FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE THERE ARE TWO KEY
CONSIDERATIONS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER AS IT
MAKES DECISIONS ABOUT THIS
APPROPRIATIONS REQUEST. FIRST
THE LEGISLATURE WANT TO
CONSIDER ITS LEVEL OF
CONFIDENCE THAT AVAILABLE
FUNDING WILL BE SUFFICIENT TO
SUPPORT THE MERCED TO
BAKERSFIELD SEGMENT. SO I DO
HEARD THE LAST. THE THIRTY X.
THAT THE EXIST FUNDING BE ROUGH
STIFF. TO COMPLETE THE REVISED
SCOPE OF THAT WERE SENT TO
BAKERSFIELD SEGMENT. AS YOU
ALSO HEARD THAT'S REALLY A
SINGLE TRACK WITH PROBABLY
PRETTY BASIC STATION PLATFORMS.
HOWEVER HISTORICALLY PROJECT
COSTS HAVE INCREASED OVER TIME
FOR THIS PROJECT. THE EXPECTED
FINDING WHAT MATERIALIZE FOR
EXAMPLE WE HEARD ABOUT CAP AND
TRADE AND HOW IN CERTAIN THAT
POTENTIALLY COULD BE- SO I
WOULD KNOW THAT. THAT IF THAT
HAPPENS AT THE EXISTING FUNDING
MIGHT NOT BE SUFFICIENT TO
COMPLETE EVEN THE MERCED TO
BAKERSFIELD SEGMENT. SECOND THE
LEGISLATURE WANT TO CONSIDER
ITS COMMITMENT TO FULLY FUNDING
THE PROJECT THIS INCLUDES ITS
LEVEL OF COMMITMENT TO MEETING
A FUNDING GAP IF ANY THAT COULD
EMERGE IN CONSTRUCTING THE
RECEPTIVE BAKERSFIELD SEGMENT.
AS WELL AS ITS COMMITMENT TO
MEETING DEFINING FUTURE
SEGMENTS SUCH AS THE BALLOT
VALLEY LINE IN PHASE ONE WHICH
WILL CERTAINLY REQUIRE NEW
FUNDING SOURCES. IF THE
LEGISLATURE IS COMMITTED TO
FINDING WERE SENT TO BACKERS
FIELD EVEN IF THE FUNDING GAP
EMERGES. AND IS ALSO COMMITTED
TO FINDING FUTURE PROJECTS
SEGMENT. THAT WE THINK THAT
ORTIZ APPROACH APPEARS
REASONABLE AND LIKELY MAKE
SENSE TO APPROPRIATE THE
FUNDING THAT'S EXPECTED TO BE
REQUESTED BY THE AUTHORITY.
HOWEVER IF THE LEGISLATURE
DOESN'T WANT TO MAKE A
COMMITMENT TO FINDING MERCED TO
BAKERSFIELD AND FUTURE SEGMENTS
AT THIS TIME. WE SUGGESTED MAY
WANT TO TAKE ANOTHER APPROACH
TO MAXIMIZE THE STANDALONE
VALUE OF WHATEVER
INFRASTRUCTURE IS COMPLETED.
AND ALSO PROVIDE THE
LEGISLATURE WITH FUTURE
FLEXIBILITY. IN THIS CASE WE
THINK THERE ARE TWO MAIN
OPTIONS. FIRST THE LEGISLATURE
IF THE LEGISLATURE HAD THE
SPECIFIC ALTERNATIVE APPROACH
THAT IT WOULD LIKE TO PURSUE
FOR EXAMPLE NARROWING THE
PROJECT SCOPE TO WHAT'S
REQUIRED BY THE FEDERAL GRANT
AGREEMENT AND THAT'S BASICALLY.
BASIC TRACK IN THAT ONE
NINETEEN MILES. IT COULD ADOPT
STATUTORY LANGUAGE DIRECTING
THE AUTHORITY ACCORDINGLY.
SECOND IF THE LEGISLATURE
DOESN'T HAVE A SPECIFIC
APPROACH THAT WOULD LIKE TO
COMMIT TO AT THIS TIME- FOR
EXAMPLE IF YOU'D LIKE TO FIND
OUT WHAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S GOING TO DO BEFORE
YOU MAKE DECISIONS- YOU CAN.
ACTION TO PRESERVE YOUR
FLEXIBILITY. THIS WOULD LIKELY
INCLUDE DELAYING ACTION ON SOME
OR ALL OF THE APPROPRIATIONS
REQUEST AND THIS WOULD PRESERVE
AND ASTRAL DECISION MAKING
POINT FOR YOU. I WOULD ALSO
LIKE NINGALOO DEDUCTING
STATUTORY LANGUAGE PREVENTING
THE AUTHORITY FROM ENTERING
INTO CONTRACTS THAT WOULD
COMMIT THE STATE TO A SPECIFIC
APPROACH SUCH AS
ELECTRIFICATION. SO FOR EXAMPLE
YOU COULD PREVENT THE AUTHORITY
FROM PURCHASING LIKE A FIVE
ROLLING STOCK AT THIS TIME OR
COMMIT COMMITTING THE STATE TO
CONSTRUCTING ELECTRIFY TRACK
AND SYSTEMS I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU MISS
CHRISTINE WE APPRECIATE THAT.
UP NEXT WE HAVE LOU THOMPSON
HE'S THE- CHAIR OF THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL HERE REVERED. REVIEW
I'M SORRY GROUP MISTER THOMPSON
PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE. YOUR VERSION OF
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY THAT I
HAVE TO APPEAR BEFORE YOU TODAY
I ALWAYS ENJOYED THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS THE-
HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT AS YOU
MAY KNOW. THE ROLE OF THE PEER
REVIEW GROUP WHICH WAS
ESTABLISHED IN OF PROP ONE A OR
A B. THREE OF TWENTY FOUR. IS
TO PROVIDE THE LEGISLATURE WITH
COMMENTS ON HIGH SPEED RAIL
REPORTS AND PROPOSALS AND I
HOPE THAT THESE REPORTS CAN ADD
TO THE DISCUSSION TODAY. OUR
LETTER COMMENTING ON THE DRAFT
REVISED BUSINESS PLAN WAS SENT
ON THE TWELFTH OF MARCH INFORMS
THE BACKGROUND OF MY REMARKS
THE DAY. LET ME BEGIN BY SAYING
THAT THERE IS SOME PROGRESS OR
POSITIVE NEWS TO REPORT OF
RIGHT AWAY AND THE THIRD PARTY
AGREEMENTS ARE COMING UNDER
CONTROL. AND THAT IS
CONTRIBUTING TO GETTING THE
EXISTING CONSTRUCTION PROGRAM
UNDER BETTER CONTROL. I DO HAVE
TO ADD THOUGH THAT THE EXISTING
CONTRACTS HAVE SEEN SIGNIFICANT
OVERRUNS AND BUDGET AROUND 70%
ON AVERAGE. AND THE SCHEDULE
DUE TO HASTE IN GETTING STARTED
FUTURE CONTRACTS WILL BENEFIT
FROM THE LESSONS LEARNED BUT
THEY HAVE BEEN PAINFUL. THE
IMBALANCE BETWEEN THE STATE'S
STANFORD CONTRACTORS IS BEING
IMPROVED IN FAVOR OF A LARGER
STUDY PARTICIPATION WHICH IS A
GOOD IDEA. THE STAGE GATE
MANAGEMENT APPROACH WILL HELP
TO ENSURE THAT FUTURE CONTRACTS
WILL PROCEED IN THE RIGHT
SEQUENCE REDUCING DELAYS AND
COSTLY CHANGE ORDERS AS BRIAN
MENTIONED. THE BIDEN
MINISTRATION IS LIKELY TO
CONSIDER REQUESTS TO RELAX
DECEMBER TWENTY TWO ERA
DEADLINE CAN BE RE OBLIGATE THE
NINE HUNDRED TWENTY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
FISCAL TWO OH ONE NO. FUNDING
MORE BROADLY THERE IS MORE
REALISM AND WHAT THE AUTHORITY
SAYS IT CAN AND CANNOT DO.
THERE IS REASON TO BELIEVE THAT
THEY CAN COMPLETE WITH THE
EXISTING FUNDING OBLIGATIONS
UNDER THEIR AGREEMENTS WHICH IS
A HUNDRED NINETEEN MILES TO
DRIVE MY ONLY SECTION OF A
TRACTOR. AND THEY COULD
PROBABLY ADD ELECTRIFICATION TO
THE HUNDRED NINETEEN MILE
SECTION PURCHASE A LIMITED
AMOUNT OF IN A ROLLING STOCK.
AND CONDUCT MORE DETAILED
ENGINEERING ANALYSIS OF ADDED
LINKS TO MERCED AND BAKERSFIELD
AND THE MORE DIFFICULT WORK
TUNNELING OUTSIDE THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. BUT THE ABILITY TO
COMPLETE THE PROPOSED LINKS
FROM THE DEER TO MERCED AND
FROM POPLAR AVENUE IN THE
BAKERSFIELD IS MORE OF A
CHALLENGE FOR A NUMBER OF
REASONS. FIRST PROJECTED COST
TO COMPLETE THE AUTHORITIES
WORK ARE VERY CLOSE TO THE
MAXIMUM POTENTIAL FUNDING NOW
AVAILABLE. IN THIS IS BEFORE
ADDING A REALISTIC ALLOWANCE
FOR OVERRUNS OF WORK FOR WHICH
THE ENGINEERING IS FAR FROM
FULLY DETAILED. THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT POSSIBILITY THAT
HEADED FUNDING BEYOND EXISTING
SOURCES MAY BE REQUIRED
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE THE PROJECT
HAS NOT YET TAKEN ON
ELECTRIFICATION SIGNALLING OR
ROLLING STOCK PROCUREMENT. THE
PROPOSAL TO OPERATE THE INTERIM
SYSTEM BETWEEN MERCED AND
BAKERSFIELD IS BASED ON A
COMPLEX SET OF AGREEMENTS AND
ACTIONS AMONG HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY THE SAN JOAQUIN JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY AND HE'S- THE
CURRENT IT WILL RENEW DESCRIBES
THESE AGREEMENTS BUT ACTUAL
COMMITMENTS AND FUNDING TO BACK
THEM UP ARE NOT. YET IN PLACE.
THE TICKET WERE THE PROPOSAL
CALLS FOR RELEASING THE LINE TO
AN OPERATING THAT'S ALREADY
THAT WOULD AGREE TO PAY FULL
COSTS FOR USE OF THE LIME. AND
ROLLING STOCK PURCHASE BY THE
AUTHORITY. BECAUSE THE STATE
SUPPORTS THE SAID WORKING JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY. OPERATING THE
SAN JOAQUIN SERVICES THIS MEANS
THAT THE STATE WILL ULTIMATELY
BE ON THE HOOK. FOR WHATEVER OR
IT WOULD BENEFIT FROM WHATEVER
HAPPENS TODAY OPERATING DEFICIT
ON THE LINE. MOREOVER THE
AGREEMENT MAY BE THE SUBJECT OF
LEGAL CHALLENGES UNDER THE
TERMS OF PROPOSITION ONE NAY.
IN ANY EVENT IS NO DOUBT THAT
THE AUTHORITY WILL NEED ADDED
FUNDING BEYOND EXISTING SOURCES
IF IT IS TO GO BEYOND THE
MERCED THE BAKERSFIELD SUCTION.
WITH THIS IN MIND A REPORT
EMPHASIZES SEVERAL POINTS THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER. ASSUMING THE BINDING
MINISTRATION APPROVES A
RELAXATION OF THE ERA DEADLINE
THERE WILL NO LONGER BE ANY
MAJOR TIME PRESSURES THERE IS
TIME TO THINK. ALTHOUGH THE
AUTHORITY DOES APPEAR TO BE
INCREASING ITS CONTROL OVER THE
CONSTRUCTION PROGRAM THE
LEGISLATURE COULD BE MORE
CONFIDENT IN THE COST AND
SCHEDULE PROJECTIONS IF THAT IS
DEMONSTRATED OVER A LONGER
PERIOD OF TIME. GOVERNOR NEWSOM
HAS DIRECTED THAT A SIGNIFICANT
PROGRAM TO COMBAT CLIMATE
CHANGE INCLUDING CHANGES TO THE
STATE TRANSPORT NETWORK BEING
DEVELOPED BY JULY THE FIFTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THIS REPORT
SHOULD CLARIFY THE GOVERNOR'S
VIEW OF THE ROLE OF HIGH SPEED
RAIL AND THE OVERALL STATEMENT
AND HIS IDEAS FOR FINDING IT.
THIS COULD BE AN IMPORTANT
BASIS FOR THE LEGISLATURE'S
CONSIDERATION. THIS CLEARLY
IMPLIES THAT THERE WILL BE AN
AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
THAT THE PROJECT WILL GO AHEAD
EVENTUALLY IF NOT THE PROJECT
SHOULD BE REASSESSED. THE
EXISTING EMOJI MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING NEEDS TO BE
TRANSLATED INTO A DETAILED
AGREEMENT WITH FOR MANAGEMENT
AND FUNDING COMMITMENTS FROM
THE STATE SEN LOOKING FOR
DOLLARS OR THIRTY AND ACE. THE
ECONOMIC VIABILITY OF THE
PROPOSED INTERIM OPERATION IS
ENTIRELY DEPENDENT ON THE
ACTORS AND FUNDING THEIR
ELDERLY THE CONTROL OF THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REALIZE THAT 75%
OF ALL OF THE WRITERS ON THE
OVERALL OF THAT ARE PROJECTED
TO INCREASE AS A RESULT OF THE
INTEROPERATION ARE ACTUALLY ON
THE NINE I SPEED SECTION.
OVERRIDING ALL OF THIS IS THE
SIMPLE FACT THAT EXISTING
FUNDING SOURCES MAY WELL NOT BE
ADEQUATE EVEN TO FINISH THE
ADDED LINKS IN THE INTERIM
PROPOSAL. AND THEY WILL
CERTAINLY NOT PERMIT ADDING
LINKS OUTSIDE MERCED THE
BAKERSFIELD. NEW FEDERAL
FUNDING AND RECONSIDERATION OF
ERA AND THE FISCAL TWENTY TEN
MONDAY IS A POSSIBILITY THAT
MAY EMERGE MORE CLEARLY IN THE
NEXT SIX MONTHS OR SO. AND IT
IS REASONABLE TO THE FIRST OPEN
STATE FUNDING DECISIONS UNTIL
WE KNOW THE ANSWER. BASED ON
PAST FEDERAL PROGRAM AMOUNTS
AND STRUCTURE THOUGH. FEDERAL
MONEY ALONE MAY WILL NOT SOLVE
THE WHOLE PROBLEM ANYWAY SO ED
IN STATE FUNDING IN SOME FORM
IS A CLEAR POSSIBILITY THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD BE AWARE OF.
IN ANY CASE I WANT TO STRESS A
POINT WE'VE MADE BEFORE THAT
MANY OF THE PAST MANAGEMENT ON
THE PROJECTS HAVE BEEN CAUSED
BY FUNDING ISSUES AND IT WILL
NEVER BE POSSIBLE IN THE FUTURE
TO MANAGE THE PROJECT
EFFECTIVELY WITHOUT ADEQUATE
AND STABLE FUNDING. WHILE THESE
ISSUES ARE BEING RESOLVED WE
BELIEVE THE AUTHORITY SHOULD
THE FOR MAKING NEW BINDING
CONTRACT COMMITMENTS OUTSIDE
DISTRICT OF CENTRAL VALLEY
REQUIRED WORK. ALTHOUGH WE'VE
BEEN CHANGING HEARING IN THE
LINKS AND ON THE MAJOR CIVIL
WORKS OUTSIDE THE CBS SHOULD OF
COURSE PROCEED. GIVEN THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE PROJECT WE
BELIEVE AS WE HAVE SAID BEFORE
THAT IMPROVED OVERSIGHT BY THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD BE A GOOD
IDEA SINCE THIS IS THE LARGEST
PROJECT THE STATE HAS EVER
UNDERTAKEN AND IT IS ONE OF THE
LARGEST THE NATION HAS EVER
UNDERTAKEN. THE OVERSIGHT
FUNCTION SHOULD HAVE ADEQUATE
STAFFING IT SHOULD HAVE THE
CONTINUITY NEEDED TO OVERSEE
THE PROJECT'S. PROGRESS OVER A
PERIOD OF YEARS NOT JUST ONE
BUDGET CYCLE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ATTENTION I'LL BE HAPPY TO
TRY AND ANSWER QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE AND I WOULD ADD OF
COURSE WE'RE ALWAYS AVAILABLE
TO DISCUSS THIS WITH YOU ARE
WITH YOUR STAFF IN FUTURE IF
THAT'S USEFUL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER THOMPSON WE APPRECIATE
THAT- THIS WAS VERY INSIGHTFUL
SO WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND
START WITH MEMBER QUESTIONS WE
HAVE SENATOR DOLLY. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I JUST LIKE TO ASK
IF- IF HIS COMMENTS COULD BE
TRANSLATED TO MY OFFICE IS IN
WRITING THAT THOSE WHOSE WORDS
I HEARD. A LOT OF UNCERTAINTY-
IN THOSE COMMENTS AND I WHAT I
WANNA BE ABLE TO READ THROUGH
IT MORE SO THE IS NOT AVAILABLE.
ASSEMBLY FOR OKAY- I WOULD
APPRECIATE BEGIN MY OFFICE THE
OTHER QUESTION IS WHAT ARE THE
OTHER COMMON I HAD IS. THE I
HEARD 70% HIGHER COST AND YES
WE ALL KNOW- I ACTUALLY USED TO
WORK IN CONSTRUCTION AND- YOU
KNOW THE FACT THAT EVERY DAY-
INFLATION'S CAUSING AND- AND
THINGS GO UP AND SO. I WANTED
TO JUST BE. SHARE A THOUGHT
ABOUT. YOU KNOW THE FUTURE
GENERATIONS- MORE TWENTY TWENTY
NINE ALMOST THIRTY TRILLION
DOLLARS IN DEBT AND WE'RE GONNA
SEE INFLATION- AT SOME POINT
THERE'S NO DOUBT ABOUT IT WE'RE
JUST PRINTING MONEY- IN THE END
WE ARE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AS WELL I MEAN WE TALK ABOUT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AS LIKE
THIS. BANK THAT IS JUST SPEWING
OUT MONEY WHICH IT IS RIGHT NOW
BUT- IT'S GETS ITS TO US THAT
PAY THAT MONEY BACK AND WHAT WE
REALLY SETTLING OUR FUTURE. BY
CHILDREN WITH WE'RE SELLING
THEM WITH HUGE AMOUNTS OF DEBT.
SO I WOULD JUST BE CAUTIOUS TO-
WHAT I HEARD IS A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY IN A LOT OF
DECISIONS AT THIS LEGISLATURE
IS GOING TO HAVE TO MAKE IN THE
NEAR FUTURE ON THE FUTURE OF
THESE PROJECTS SO I WOULDN'T
THAT JUST TAKE THOSE COMMENTS
FOR THE RECORD THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR DOLLY- ARE THERE
ANY OTHER MEMBER QUESTIONS I IF
NOT I HAVE ONE BUT I'LL GO HEAD
TO SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND- THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE PROJECTS- FOR THE LACK OF
BETTER WORD IT FEELS LIKE IT'S
A LOVE AND HATE RELATIONSHIP
WITH EVERYONE. AND TO YOU KNOW
EVEN THOUGH I EXPRESSED EARLIER
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS FOR THE
STATE. YOU KNOW IT'S IMPORTANT
TO TAKE NOTE OF WHAT WE JUST%
HEARD HERE AND YOU KNOW AND
WHAT- MISTER DOLLY DOES STATED
AS WELL. YOU KNOW WHEN I HEARD
RIGHT NOW THAT WE NEED ADEQUATE
AND STABLE FUNDING IT'S
SOMETHING THAT YOU KNOW IT'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
THERE'S A LOT OF UNCERTAINTY.
SO AGAIN JUST FOR THE RECORD I
JUST WANTED TO STATE THAT AS
MUCH AS I BELIEVE IT'S
IMPORTANT AND WE WOULD LOVE TO
HAVE THIS BECAUSE CALIFORNIANS
DESERVE. FAST TRAVEL
CONNECTIVITY ACROSS THE STATE-
I ALSO HEARD THAT WE NEED TO
AVOID COMMITTING THE STATE. ARE
YOU KNOW PUTTING THE STATE INTO
CONTRACTS THEY'RE GONNA TILES
DOWN TO FUTURE- YOU KNOW DEBT
THAT WE MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
SUSTAIN SO I JUST WANTED TO.
CLARIFY THAT AS MUCH AS I
APPRECIATE THE PROJECT. I'M I'M
CONCERNED WITH WHAT I'M HEARING
IN THIS PRESENTATION IN TERMS
OF THE STABILITY OF THE FUNDING
AND SO WE NEED TO REALLY JUST
LOOK CLOSELY INTO THE PROJECT
THANK YOU. ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO AND ON THAT- I
DID HAVE A QUESTION AS TO THE-
FUTURE FLEXIBILITY WHICH
INCLUDES THE BINDING CONTRACTS
AND YOU KNOW ALL OF THAT BUT
ARE THERE IS THERE ANY MORE
THAT YOU CAN ELABORATE ON
EITHER MISTER. THOMPSON ARE
MAYES- CHRISTINE ON WHAT OTHER
FUTURE FLEXIBILITY
OPPORTUNITIES A LEGISLATURE
WOULD HAVE OR ANY OTHER
EXAMPLES. OF BINDING CONTRACTS
THAT WE SHOULD KNOW ABOUT. I
CAN TAKE A STAB AT THAT- IF
THAT'S HELPFUL SO. I IN IT IT
SAID IN A CONTRACT THAT YOU
MENTIONED THERE IS A TRACKING
SYSTEMS CNTRACT THAT'S COMING
UP WHICH IS A VERY LARGE
CONTRACT AND WOULD ESSENTIALLY
COMMIT THE STATE TO
ELECTRIFICATION. ON AT LEAST
THAT ONE NINETEEN AT THAT
INITIAL ONE EIGHTEEN SEGMENT-
THERE'S ALSO THAT AND
ROLLINGSTOCK CONTRACT WHICH IS
ANOTHER VRY LARGE HUNDRED
THAT'S COMING UP IN ADDITION TO
THAT. UNDER SOME OTHER ACTIONS
THAT THE AUTHORITY MAY TAKE ON
FOR EXAMPLE. YOU MAY START- YOU
KNOW IT AT SOME POINT
PURCHASING RIGHT OF WAY THOSE
TYPES OF ACTIONS WITH WOULD
START- OUTSIDE OF THAT ONE
NINETEEN RIGHT NOW IT'S BEEN
BASED BASICALLY FOCUSED ON THAT
ONE NINETEEN MILES. THOSE TYPES
OF ACTIONS ALSO START TO KIND
OF LIMIT THAT THE FLEXIBILITY
TO TAKE OTHER. APPROACHES IN
THE FUTURE- IN TERMS OF EITHER
APPROACH IS I THINK WE TALKED A
LITTLE BIT. THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF REFERENCES TO THAT
ELECTRIFICATION VERSES NOT. ONE
OF. THEM I THINK MAYBE FOR THAT
AND- JUST AS A LITTLE BIT OF. I
THINK THE MAIN KIND OF. THING
THAT FOLKS ARE OF ARE. FOCUSED
ON IS THIS ONE NINETEEN MILES
AND YOU ELECTRIFY OR NOT IF YOU.
JOINT IF YOU DON'T ELECTRIFY
THAT THEY GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT
MORE FLEXIBILITY BUT THEN OF
COURSE YOU WANT TO COME BACK
ELECTRIFY LATER. THAT YEAR
THERE'S AN ADDITIONAL COST TO
DOING THAT BUT IF YOU DO
ELECTRIFY THAT PIECE IT
JUST RUN ON ELECTRIFIED SERVICE
ON ONE NINETEEN MILES THAT YOU
FROM SHAFTER TO MADERA AS YOU
SAW. AND THOSE ARE REALLY
LOGICAL STARTING AND ENDING
POINTS AND YOU KNOW YOU
PROBABLY WOULDN'T WANT TO TAKE
A CONVENTIONAL TRAINS
TRANSFERRED TRANSFERRED BACK.
AND IT PROBABLY ISN'T SERVICE
THAT REALLY MAKES SENSE SO IF
YOU'RE GONNA LECTURE BY YOU
PROBABLY NEED TO ELECTRIFY A
LARGER SEGMENT AT LEAST MERCED
TO BAKERSFIELD SO ONCE YOU
START COMMITTING TO
ELECTRIFICATION. YOU HAVEN'T
REALLY PROBABLY JUST COMMITTED
TO ELECTRIFICATION THAT ONE
NINETEEN HOW DO YOU PRACTICE
YOU COULD COMMITTED. TO AT
LEAST DOING MERCED TO
BAKERSFIELD OTHERWISE YOU HAVE
A SEGMENT THAT REALLY JUST
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE THIS ONE
NINETEEN MILES. SO I DON'T HAVE
IT RIGHT A LITTLE BIT MORE
CONTEXT FOR THAT DECISION BUT
IT REALLY IS A CRITICAL
DECISION. AND ONCE THOSE YOU
KNOW THOSE CONTRACTS ARE
ENTERED INTO. THE STATE COMMITS
ITSELF TO A TRADITION OF THE
ONE NINETEEN AND CAN PRACTICE
WERE PROBABLY COMMITTING
OURSELVES TO. ELECTRIFICATION
AND REALLY RUNNING THAT MERCED
TO BAKERSFIELD THAT MAY REQUIRE
SOME ADDITIONAL FINES. AND THEN
IDEALLY IT WOULD PROBABLY BE
EXPANDED BEYOND THAT BECAUSE
EVEN MERCED TO BAKERSFIELD.
IT'S PROBABLY NOT THAT THE
DREAM OF EVERYONE HERE I THINK
YOU KNOW THERE'S CERTAINLY
VISION FOR BEYOND THAT. BUT
THAT OF COURSE WOULD COME WITH
ADDITIONAL COSTS. I DON'T KNOW
MISTER THOMPSON YOU HAVE
ANYTHING TO ADD AS WELL. IF I
MAY. I THINK WE SHOULD THAT IS
ONE WAY. ONE TO WHICH- APPROACH
THIS. THERE'S ANOTHER ONE WHICH
IS. LOOK AT IT FROM THE-
QUESTION OF WHETHER WE'RE
ACTUALLY GOING TO BUILD THE
SYSTEM OR NOT. IF THERE IS A
COMMITMENT TO BUILD THE SYSTEM
AND THIS IS A STEP ALONG THE
WAY. THEN THEM IT IT DOESN'T
MATTER IF WE TAKE OUR TIME AND
IT DOESN'T MATTER IF WE DO IT A
LITTLE BIT AT A TIME UNTIL WE
FACT THERE IS NO COMMITMENT TO
BUILD THE SYSTEM THEN WE REALLY
NEED TO THINK ABOUT- WHAT'S
GONNA HAPPEN NEXT AND HOW FAR
WE GO. WE ARE COMMITTED- TO
FAIRNESS BY THAT TO FURNISH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND OUR
COMMITMENT THE HUNDRED NINETY
MILE SECTION THAT WE- IN
PRINCIPLE WE HAVE TO DO THAT.
UP BEYOND THAT- ANYTHING
LEGISLATURE REALLY NEEDS TO
CONSIDER THE QUESTION OF ARE WE
GOING TO DO THE SYSTEM
EVENTUALLY YES OR NO AND IF WE
ARE AND IF WE CAN AGREE WITH
YOU THE LEGISLATURE CAN AGREE
WITH THE GOVERNMENT THEN
GOVERNOR. THAT'S WHAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN. THEN THEN THE TIME
THAT IS AVAILABLE TO FIGURE OUT
FIRST WHAT WILL BE THE ROLE OF
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
SECOND YOU KNOW HOW WILL WE SEE
FOR THIS PROJECT OVER TIME. BUT
I THINK IT ALL FITS WITHIN THE
QUESTION OF ARE WE COMMITTED TO
BUILD THE SYSTEM UNDER PROP ONE
EIGHTY. WE ARE COMMITTED TO
BUILD THE SYSTEM BUT THE
LEGISLATURE NEVER HAD A CHANCE
TO PASS ON THAT. NEITHER DID
THE GOVERNOR. SO PROP ONE A.
COULD AS A POSITION TO
SOMETHING WHICH WAS NOT
ADEQUATELY FUNDED AND IT DID
NOT HAVE THE COMMITMENT EITHER
OF THE GOVERNOR OF THE
LEGISLATURE. BUT NEEDS TO
CHANGE. IF WE'RE GOING TO PUT
THE SHORT TERM DECISIONS IN THE
RIGHT KIND OF CONTACTS. THANK
YOU MISTER THOMPSON I
APPRECIATE THE ANSWERS FOR
FROM- BOTH YOU MISTER MISS ACT
CHRISTINE. OUR NEXT WE HAVE
CHAIRED THAT ALSO AND THEN WILL
HAVE A SENATOR WITH KELSEY
FINISHED OFF. THANK YOU
MANAGER- BECAUSE THIS IS FOR
BOTH THE L. A. O. L. AND MR
THOMPSON- IS. I'D LIKE TO SEE
BECAUSE I'VE HEARD PIECES OF.
YES FUNDING WE HAVE SOME
FUNDING WELL WE'RE NOT SURE
ABOUT THE OTHER FUNDING WHAT
ABOUT THE FEDERAL OF FUNDING
ALL OF THAT IS JUST SO
UNCERTAIN. IT SEEMS TO ME WE
ARE TO BE PROVIDED WITH.
OPTIONS OF THAT AREN'T ALL OR
NOTHING WITH THIS PROJECT OR AT
LEAST. IF THESE ARE BUILDING
BLOCKS THEN WE OUGHT TO KNOW
MUCH MORE CLEARLY THE TIME LINE
IS IT REALISTIC. LIKE LIAM BUT
THE COST IS THE COST- ESTIMATE
FOR BAKERSFIELD TO MERCED IS
THAT REALISTIC IS A TIMELINE.
OF FOR THE COMPLETION TO
INCLUDE ALL THE WAY TO LA IS
THAT REALISTIC I MEAN. WE'RE
ETTING PIECES HERE THAT DON'T
SEEM TO. A BE REALISTIC- AND
ESPECIALLY WITH REGARDS TO THE
FUNDING SO I'D REALLY LIKE TO
SEE IS IT POSSIBLE TO GET.
THESE OPTIONS ALL THE WAY
THROUGH. I THINK WE ALL WANT. I
HAVEN'T HEARD ANYBODY SAY WE
DON'T WANT IT ALL TOGETHER AT
ALL. A STATE WIDE BUT THERE'S
SO MANY PROBLEMS THAT HAVE COME
UP THAT WE HAVE THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO ADDRESS THOSE
IN A MORE REALISTIC WAY. SO I'M
LOOKING FOR OPTIONS- AND WITH
THE FULL EXTENT OF FUNDING AND
TIMELINE THAT A REALISTIC.
THANK YOU CHAIRED RUSSELL AND
IS THAT SOMETHING- THE- MISS
CHRISTINE THAT WOULD YOU WOULD
LIKE TO ANSWER AND IS IT
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN BE
PROVIDED MAYBE PERHAPS AFTER
THE MEETING AS WELL. UNLESS YOU
WANT TO WEIGH IN AND ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS. AND I'M HAPPY THREE
WORK CERTAINLY WITH YOU AND
YOUR STAFF- SENATORS HAVE
PROVIDED SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION AND- AND HELP YOU.
AND GET WHATEVER INFORMATION BE
HELPFUL AS YOU AS YOU CONSIDER
THOSE THINGS I CERTAINLY AGREE
THAT THERE IS A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY IN TERMS OF THE
COST ESTIMATES PARTICULARLY
WITH THOSE MERCED AND
BAKERSFIELD EXTENSION. BEFORE
THOSE ARE AN EARLY DESIGNS.
AGES AND THERE'S A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT HOW MUCH IS
GOING TO COST A WHILE BACK OR
HE'S BECOME MUCH MORE CERTAIN
ABOUT THAT ONE NINETEEN AND
EVEN THERE THERE'S YOU KNOW A
BILLION DOLLARS OF EXTRA
CONTINGENCY RIGHT BECAUSE
THERE'S STILL A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY EVEN WITH THAT ONE
NINETEEN BUT CERTAINLY THERE'S
A HUGE AMOUNT OF UNCERTAINTY
WITH THE MERCED AND BAKERSFIELD
EXTENSION AND- DEFINITELY
BEYOND THAT SO. YOU KNOW THEY
HAD THERE IS THAT SORT OF
ESTIMATE OF THE TOTAL PROJECT
COSTS THAT YOU EIGHTY PLUS
BILLION BUT THAT IS SUBJECT TO
VERY VERY SIGNIFICANT
UNCERTAINTY BECAUSE THERE'S
BEEN ONLY REALLY PRELIMINARY
WORK- FOR A LOT OF PHASE ONE. I
TELL ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH YOU
ON THAT CERTAINLY THE TIMING
THAT THAT DIED TWENTY THIRTY
THREE DAY BATTLE THAT IT SEEMS
FULL FUNDING WHICH IS NOT WHICH
AS WE'VE HEARD AND IN THIS
PANEL SO FAR AND IN THE
PREVIOUS PANEL DOESN'T EXIST
AND SO EVEN IF THEY HAD THAT
THAT THE FORTIES ESTIMATE IF
THEY HAVE ALL THE MONEY IN HAND
TODAY READY TO GO. EVEN THAT
MIGHT BE AMBITIOUS AND BY
CERTAINLY WITHOUT YOU KNOW
WITHOUT FULL FUNDING WHICH IS
THE REALITY OF THE SITUATION
NOW AND THAT'S UNLIKELY THAT TO
COME TO PASS SO I'M DEFINITELY
AGREE WITH WHAT YOU AND
INDICATED THEY'RE HAPPY TO WORK
WITH YOU HAD TO THINK ABOUT
OPTIONS- IF THAT'S HELPFUL.
THANK YOU MISS CHRISTINE AND
YES I THINK WHAT WE'RE ASKING
FOR IS THE SCENARIO PLAN I KNOW
THAT SEEMS EASY ENOUGH BUT
THERE ARE A LOT OF DIFFERENT
POTENTIALS. THAT COULD BE- THE-
DURING THIS PROCESS THAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE A THING
VISUAL. SO THAT OBJECT. AND
MISTER KELLY WILL HAVE A YEAH
NO I JUST WANT TO A AS HE
QUESTIONS I WILL ARE A IN THE
BUSINESS PLANS TO BOTH YOU KNOW
LAY OUT WHAT WE HAVE WHAT THE
VISION IS A BE ON THIS PROGRAM
TO GET ALTERNATELY TO THE PHASE
ONE SYSTEM THAT THE VOTERS
APPROVED AND THAT'S HOW WE
REPRESENT THE STOP THE BUSINESS
PLAN IT IS FAIR AND A GOOD
QUESTION AND A GOOD POINT. FOR
BOTH L. A. O. AND THE PEER
REVIEW GROUP SHOULD KNOW THAT
THERE ARE RISKS I HAD ALONG THE
WAY ON THIS AND I JUST WANT TO.
VOLUNTEER MY TEAM AND MY STAFF
TO TALK ABOUT IT BE PART OF
THIS DISCUSSION. ON BUT HOW WE
INCREMENTALLY GO FORWARD IN THE
TIMING. BECAUSE I THINK THERE
ARE IMPORTANT THINGS TO PEEL
APART. IF YOU DON'T DO CERTAIN
THINGS IT MEANS SOME COSTS ARE
SIMPLY DEFERRED IF YOU DO
CERTAIN THINGS. LET'S MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN COVER THAT AND-
HAVE A GREATER LEVEL OF COMFORT
ON THE ESTIMATES FOR THAT SO
FOR EXAMPLE I WANT ONE TO. NOT
MOVE FORWARD ON ADVANCED DESIGN
WORK THAT WOULD ANSWER A LOT OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT COST AND OTHER
THINGS. BECAUSE WE'RE NOT DONE
WITH THE ONE NINETEEN YEAH WE
SHOULD DO THOSE CONCURRENTLY.
SO I THINK THERE ARE I THINK
WHAT I'M ASKING IS. THAT THE
AUTHORITY BE A PARTICIPANT WITH
L. PRG LEGISLATIVE OFFICES
ABOUT LEADING OUT WITH THOSE
INCREMENTAL STEPS COULD LOOK
LIKE AND I WOULD. APPRECIATE
THAT OPPORTUNITY THAT'S ALL
THANK YOU MISTER KELLY AND- I'M-
MADE. I THINK ALREADY HAS IF
YOU CAN BE BRIEF IN WE HAVE
ONE- AND WILL ONE THING IS LIVE
WITH OF IN THE RECOMMENDATION
THAT WE MADE TO THE LEGISLATURE
IN WHICH I THINK BRIAN MOSTLY.
KERR'S THERE. THERE ARE STILL
MORE UNCERTAINTY IS OF THAT
WILL BE ADDRESSED IN THE NEXT
SIX MONTHS OR SO THAT WILL MAKE
IT. CLEAR WHAT YOU MIGHT WISH
TO DO. ONE IS THE FEDERAL ROLE
I HOPE IT WILL BE CLEARER YOU
WILL HAVE A BETTER IDEA OF WHAT
KIND OF WORK THEY WILL BE. THE
SECOND IS BRIAN PROPOSES IS TO
DO A LOT MORE ENGINEERING WORK
AND BETTER COST ESTIMATES OF
THOSE LINKS AND ON THE TUNNEL
SOLD HAVE A BETTER SENSE OF.
HOW REALISTIC IT IS THAT THEY
CAN LOOK UP WHAT THEY CAN
ACCOMPLISH. WITH NEW EXISTING
MONEY. OF THE THIRTY. IS
GOVERNOR REPORT IN OF JUNE.
WHICH COMES AND GOES. THE
STATE'S DECISION. WILL BE MUCH
CLEARER IN. IS THE LEGISLATURE
REQUEST THE GOVERNOR'S VIEW ON
HELD ADDITIONAL FUNDING MIGHT
BE PROVIDED. IN THE FINAL EIGHT
POINTS IS THE MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING THE KEY OPERATING
AGREEMENT FOR THE INTERIM
SYSTEM WHICH SHALL. IS A
MEMORANDUM BY A NUMBER OF THOSE
ISSUES COULD BE MUCH FURTHER
CLARIFIED SO THE LEGISLATURE
WOULD HAVE. MORE CONFIDENCE IN
WHAT IS OPTIONS. REALLY ARE AND
WHAT IT WANTS TO DO. THANK VERY
MUCH MR TA. SYNNEX ARE GONNA GO
TO OUR LAST QUESTION FOR THIS
PANEL SENATOR MCCARTHY. GARCIA
I GUESS THE KEY QUESTION FOR
THE DECISION MAKERS HERE IS
WHAT WE DO WITH THE REQUEST FOR
FULL FUNDING ON THE ONE A- AND
I. REALLY SAYS IT FOR ALL IN
THE MERCED TO BAKERSFIELD THAN
OBVIOUSLY APPROVAL ALL THE
FUNDING AND KEEP YOUR EYE ON
THE BALL- I DON'T KNOW IF WE'RE
AND IF THE LEGISLATURE IS
WILLING TO ACCEPT THAT RISK
AND- ACCEPT THE OPPORTUNITY.
THE INVITATION THAT THEY MAY
HAVE TO COME UP WITH MORE
FUNDING. IN ADDITION TO ALL THE
OTHER FUNDING SOURCES WE'VE
TALKED TO- I GUESS MY QUESTION
IS THAT. IS THERE A NUMBER THAT
PEOPLE ARE THINKING ABOUT AS WE
WAIT FOR OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS
TO DECIDE WHETHER THEY'RE GOING
TO BE AMBITIOUS OR AS IS THE
MISTER KELLY'S AT STATED
THERE'S SOME ENVIRONMENTAL WORK
AND SOME OTHER NON CONSTRUCTION
WORK THAT IS VERY VALUABLE FOR
US TO DETERMINE COSTS SO- I GET
THE EASY ANSWER FOR ALL LAND
FUNDED ALL I GUESS THE QUESTION
IS THAT SHE'D AGREE FOR THE LA-
IF THEY CAN. HELP US WITH. WE
DON'T WANT TO RUIN THE
STABILITY OF EXPECTATIONS WE
DON'T WANT TO RUIN THE-
RELATIONSHIP A POTENTIAL
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT BUT HOW DO WE- HOW
DO WE DISCUSS THIS AMONG
OURSELVES AND IF WE PLAY WITH
THE NUMBERS. I THINK PERHAPS
ONE THING TO CONSIDER IS THAT
THE THIRTY NOT GONNA NEED THAT
THE ENTIRE FOUR POINT ONE
BILLION IN. THAT YEAR- AND I
THINK IN FACT THERE'S SOME
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT EXACTLY HOW
MUCH OF THAT THEY WILL NEED-
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THEIR THEIR-
PAST HISTORY OF NOT REALLY
SPENDING UP THERE PROJECTED.
LEVELS AND SO. FOR EXAMPLE THE
LEGISLATURE COULD APPROVE YOU
KNOW PORTION OF THAT WHATEVER-
IS A TERM HE BEING NEEDED YOU
KNOW IF ANY TO SORT OF GET THE
AUTHORITY THROUGH THE FISCAL
YEAR. AND THEN. COULD HOLD OFF
ON THE DECISION ABOUT THE
REMAINING FRIENDS THAT WERE AT
YOU KNOW AS WE SAID WE PROVIDE
ANOTHER NATURAL OPPORTUNITY FOR
LEGISLATURE COME BACK NEXT
YEAR- I THINK ONE THING TO DO
YOU TO CONSIDER THEIR TO YOU
THOUGH IS WHETHER IT'S- THE
LEGISLATURE WANT TO PROVIDE
DIRECTION TO THE AUTHORITIES
SPECIFICALLY NOT. GOING TO
ENTER INTO ANY THIS CONTRACT
THAT WOULD BIND THE LEGISLATURE
I'M REALLY TO A SPECIFIC
APPROACH BECAUSE ESPECIALLY
LIKE WE KNOW THAT THEIR
TRACKING SYSTEMS CONTRACT IS
COMING UP. THE ROLLING STOCK
PROCUREMENT IS COMING UP IF
THEY PROCEED WITH THOSE
COMMITMENTS SPAN AND THEN
REALISTICALLY PROBABLY THE
PROJECT ASSISTANT ON OF HAVE TO
GO IN ONE DIRECTION WHICH IS
NOW. AFTER FIVE YEARS AT THE
BAKERSFIELD. SO I THINK KNOW
WOULD HAVE TO DO ALL ALL OR
NOTHING THE FOR FREE YOU COULD.
YEP CERTAIN. AND YOU COULD YOU
COULD DESIGNATE THOSE FUNDS TO
YOU COULD HAVE OR YOU COULD SAY
YOU KNOW WE WANT TO PORTION OF
THEM TO GO TO CERTAIN
ACTIVITIES IF YOU. REALLY VALUE
THAT ADVANCED DESIGN WORK YOU
COULD. YOU COULD TRY TO MAKE
SURE THAT WAS PRIORITIZE IN IN
WHATEVER YOU FIND. SO YEAH I
THINK THERE'S PROBABLY SOME
OPTIONS DEPENDING ON THE
PRIORITIES OF THE LEGISLATURE
IN ITS COMFORT LEVEL AGAIN
WITH. WITH WHETHER IT WANTS TO
COMMIT TO OUR CENTURY HERSELF
AND REALLY ALL OF PHASE ONE- OR
AT LEAST OUT OF THE VALLEY AND
COULD EVEN MERCED TO BAKER
STILL THIS PROBLEM ESPECIALLY
AS CURRENTLY ENVISIONED A
SINGLE TRACK OR SAID TO
BAKERSFIELD WITH VERY BASIC
STATIONS. IT IS IT'S PROBABLY
NOT FOLKS IS A SORT OF END GAME
HERE AND I DON'T THINK IT'S
EVEN YOU KNOW THE AUTHORITIES
ENGAGEMENTS AS THEY'VE
INDICATED THEY THINK VIEW THIS
AS A STEPPING. BLOCK APPROACH-
WE MAY BARELY GET ENOUGH TO DO
THAT. POTENTIALLY BUT EVEN THAT
WOULDN'T. BE WHAT WOULD REALLY
WANT RESET THE BAKERSFIELD AND
CERTAINLY NOT FOR THE ENTIRE
SYSTEM SO. I THINK IT'S OUR
TIMES WITH ACTUALLY CRACKED. WE
NEE TO THINK ABOUT WHAT IS
THAT COMMITMENT- AND IF TO THE
EXTENT THAT WE CAN DELAY THAT
DECISION TO GET MORE
INFORMATION THAT'S WONDERFUL.
AND I THINK THAT WE PROBABLY
CAN'T BE A LOT MORE FLEXIBILITY
NOW DESPITE NAY MINISTRATION.
YOU HAVE TO TAKE SOME MORE TIME
TO MAKE THOSE DECISIONS- AND-
PRESERVE SOME OF THAT
FLEXIBILITY SO I THINK THAT WAS
ALSO AN EXCELLENT POINT. THANK
YOU MISS CHRISTINE. THANK YOU
SENATOR AKOWSKI OKAY THAT.
COMPLETES OUR SECOND PANEL WE
APPRECIATE. THOSE COMMENTS AND
THE OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK AT
OPTIONS AS WELL- WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO OUR LAST AND FINAL
PANEL ON THIS IS MADE UP OF A
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
PARTNERS. FIRST WE WILL HEAR
FROM STACEY MORTENSEN FROM THE
SAN JOAQUIN REGIONAL RAIL
COMMISSION. THE OPERATORS OF
THE SAN JOAQUIN AMTRAK SERVICE
IN THE EAST TRAIN SERVICE.
SECOND WILL BEAT JIM HARTNETT
FROM CALTRAIN IN THE BAY AREA
AND FINALLY WE WILL HEAR FROM
OUR FRIENDS AT DELHI METRO
WELCOME ALL AND LET'S START
WITH MS MORTENSEN. THANK YOU
BOTH ESTEEM CHAIRS AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I CAN
APPRECIATE THE MENTAL
GYMNASTICS YOU HAVE TO GO
THROUGH TO. KEEP THIS ALL IN
PERSPECTIVE- THROUGHOUT THIS
LAST DIFFICULT YEAR OUR VALLEY
RAIL PROGRAM HAS BEEN MOVING
ALONG AND IT'S IN KEEPING HER
SPIRITS HIGH AS WE EMBARK ON.
NEW IMPROVEMENTS AND RAIL
CONNECTIONS IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. FOR ORIENTATION
VALLEY RAIL OR THE GREEN AND
PURPLE LINES YOU SEE SORT OF IN
THE CENTRAL PART OF CALIFORNIA
THERE. THOSE LINES COME OUT OF
MERCED WHICH WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT. AND THE BRANCH OFF INTO
OAKLAND SAN JOSE AND THEN THEN
A THOMAS AREA NEAR THE
SACRAMENTO AIRPORT. WE'RE ALSO
IN CHARGE OF THE THRUWAY BUS
PROGRAM FOR CALIFORNIA. WHICH
YOU SEE IN THOSE DASHED GREEN
LINES THAT GO TO THE FAR
REACHES OF THE STATE. AND ALSO
ALLOW US TO CONNECT WITH OUR
PARTNERS THE PACIFIC SURFLINER
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. BUT I
THINK MORE IMPORTANTLY AS A
PASSENGER OUR NETWORK CONNECTS
PEOPLE TO MANY DIFFERENT
SERVICES TO CALTRAIN VTA BART
CAPITOL CORRIDOR THE FUTURE
VALLEY LINK SERVICE- AND THE
SACRAMENTO AIRPORT. AND THE
SEMI CANCEL THEY CURRENTLY
OPERATE OUT OF BAKERSFIELD BOTH
ACE IN THE SAN JOAQUIN WILL
OPERATE IN THE FUTURE OUT OF
MERCED. AS THEY MEET THE
TERMINUS OF THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
PROGRAM. IN A RECENT BIG BIG
BILLS TO OUR PROGRAM IS CALLED
THE STOCKTON DIAMOND GRADE
SEPARATION I'LL JUST SORT OF
PUT YOU TO WHERE IT IS ON THE
MAP WHERE ALL OF THE GREEN AND
PURPLE CONVERGE THERE. IN
STOCKTON. WE HAVE SOMETHING
SIMILAR TO COLTON CROSSING DOWN
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA BIG BIG
BOTTLENECK- TERRIBLE PROBLEM
FOR FREE CONGESTION. UNITY OF
OBSTRUCTIONS AT CETERA WHEN YOU
LOOK AT IT FROM THE PLAN VIEW
THAT YOU SEE HERE YOU KNOW
SEEMINGLY IT LOOKS LIKE NO
MAN'S LAND- IT REALLY IS ONE OF
THE BIGGEST ISSUES THAT THE
CITY OF STOCKTON HAS BEEN
FACING. THIS GIVES YOU UP THE
SCENARIO OF UNION PACIFIC IN
THE MIDDLE THERE GOING UP AND
OVER THE BURLINGTON NORTHERN
SANTA FE AND WELL IN THIS VIEW
FROM THIS PERSPECTIVE YOU CAN
SEE HOW. NOT ONLY WAS A CHOKING
OUT ALL TRAINS RUNNING AT THAT
CROSSING IT CERTAINLY WILL BE
BLOCKING THE WHOLE CITY OF
STOCKTON DOWNTOWN INTERSECTIONS
AND INTERSECTS WITH THAT THE
MAJOR TWO MAJOR HIGHWAYS SO.
THIS PROJECT FOR US IS VERY
EXCITING WE GOT A FEDERAL BILL
GRANT RECENTLY ONE OF THE ONLY
RAIL GRANTS LIKE THAT IN THE
COUNTRY. AND THEN IT IT BOOSTED
AN ADDITIONAL HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN STATE FUNDING SO
THIS PROJECT IS REALLY BUILDING
SOME MOMENTUM AND WE'VE HAD A
LOT OF SUPPORT. AND EVEN
STATEWIDE. I HE LIVES. HM SAN
JOAQUIN SPOKE OPERATES ON THE
FREIGHT LINES THE CORPORATION
OF BURLINGTON NORTHERN SANTA FE
AND UNION PACIFIC ARE CRITICAL
AND OVER THE LAST TWO DECADES
WE DEVELOP GOOD RELATIONSHIPS
WITH THEM SO THAT NOW WE'RE AT
A POINT WHERE WE'RE GETTING
READY TO UNDERTAKE THIS VERY
MASSIVE EXPANSION PROGRAM FOR
US THEY'VE WORKED WITH US ON A
SERIES OF PHASED IMPROVEMENTS
TO LET US START SERVICE WHICH
IS CAN BE UNUSUAL A LOT OF
TIMES THE FREIGHT RAILROADS ONE
ALL OF THE IMPROVEMENTS UP
FRONT BEFORE ANY SERVICE CAN
START. AND SO I THINK EVEN AS
HIGH SPEED RAIL IS LOOKING AT A
PHASED APPROACH WE'RE THANKFUL
WE CAN LOOK AT A PHASED
APPROACH AND GET SOME SERVICE
TO THE PASSENGERS SOONER SO
WE'RE LOOKING AT ABOUT FOUR
WAVES OF SERVICE ALL OF THEM
HAPPENING AND REALLY IN THE
TIME FRAME OF. TWENTY TWENTY
THREE TO TWENTY TWENTY SIX AND
THEN EACH SECTION THAT I'M
GOING TO TALK ABOUT IT
GENERALLY INCLUDES NEW DOUBLE
TRACK SECTIONS SIGHTINGS WHERE
THEIR SINGLE TRACK BRIDGE WHITE
NING'S ALONG WITH STATIONS AND
LAYOVER FACILITIES I'M GONNA
START WITH WAIT TILL ONLY
BECAUSE I'D LIKE TO START IN
THE NORTH REALLY WAVES ONE AND
TWO AND I'LL TALK. ABOUT ARE
GOING TO GO SIMULTANEOUSLY. BUT
THIS ROUTE IS FOR FROM SAP.
DOWN TO STOCKTON. THE PURPLE
AND GREEN LINE THAT YOU SEE
WITH THE OTHERS KIND OF MAGENTA
AND GREEN THAT IS GOING TO BE
THE NEW. RAIL ROUTE OF THE
FUTURE THIS IS A ROUTE THAT'LL
ALLOW US TO ADD MANY MORE TRAIN
FREQUENCIES. THIS IS A UNION
PACIFIC SEGMENT THEY'VE OFFERED
THAT WE COULD NEGOTIATE WITH
THEM TO GO UP TO A HUNDRED AND
TEN. MILES AN HOUR BUT GIVEN
THE SPACING PROBABLY NINETY TO
NINETY FIVE IS MORE LIKELY BUT
THAT'S FASTER THAN WE RUN
TODAY. AND THEN THESE- THIS
ALIGNMENT GIVES US. BETTER
SERVICE TO THE SACRAMENTO
AIRPORT WHICH WOULD NOT HAVE ON
THE FORMER LINE AND IT ALSO
ALLOWS US TO WORK WITH YOU
COUNTY FOR POTENTIAL EXPANSIONS
UP TO. A YUBA CITY AND MERRY'S
VEIL WHICH THE CURRENT LINE
DOES NOT DO SO FROM A FUTURE
STANDPOINT. THIS RAIL LINE WELL
LET'S NOT USE NOW WILL OPEN UP
SERVICE T A LOT MORE PARTS OF
THE STATE. AND MORE CONNECTIONS
TO BE MADE. OUR WAY TO THE
STATE IN YELLOW YOU SEE THE
ACE. EXISTING SERVICE. AT THE
LATER OF AREA WE BRANCH OFTEN
GO SOUTH SO OUR WAVE ONE OF
CONSTRUCTION IS THE DOTTED
GREEN LINE THAT TAKES US DOWN
TO SERIES. THAT'S ABOUT TWENTY
FIVE MILE EXTENSION. AND THEN
OUR OUR WAGE THREE IS THE
PURPLE SECTION FROM SERIES DOWN
THE MERCED YOU CAN SEE THAT
THAT'S LONGER IT'S GOT RIVER
CROSSINGS- SO THAT IS GOING TO
BE A LITTLE BIT OF A BIGGER
LEFT. BUT IT GETS US TO OUR
INITIAL SERVICE TO MERCED. AND
THE PRIMARY STATIONS. OUR PHASE
FOR WHICH WILL BE AFTER TWENTY
TWENTY SIX. WILL BUILD IN ALL
OF THE PLANNED STATIONS WHICH
IS FOURTEEN. AND THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO HAVE SIX
TRAINS DOWN SOMERSET. YOU SEE
THE LITTLE INTERSECTION DOWN
THE BOTTOM OF THE SLIDE MERCED
LOOKS VERY SIMPLE- BUT OF
COURSE IT ISN'T AS YOU HEARD.
EARLIER A LOT OF COMPLICATIONS
WHEN YOU BUILD REYES. WHEN- THE
B. WHICH IS OUR SAME MUCH RUN.
AND THE U. P. WHICH IS OUR ACE
RUN WHEN THOSE TWO LINE COME
DOWN TOMORROW. THEY ARE NOT AT
THE SAME LOCATION SO YOU SEE ON
THE SITE HERE IT'S CALLED OUT
WHERE THE MERCED STATION WILL
BE FOR HIGH SPEED RAIL ON THE
U. P. LINE. THERE IS A GAP FROM
THE BNSF. WHERE WE NEED TO
CLOSE THE GAP FOR THE SAN
JOAQUIN SENATE'S ABOUT FOUR
THOUSAND FEET SO THIS IS THIS
IS ONE OF OUR BIG LAUGHS RIGHT
HERE. HOW TO FIGURE OUT MAKING
THIS CONNECTION THAT'S A LITTLE
TOO SOON TO GIVE A FINAL COST
ESTIMATE AND FIGURE OUT YOU
KNOW HOW HOW WELL FUNDED WE ARE
AND WHAT OUR GAP IS. BECAUSE WE
NEED TO KNOW IF HIGH SPEED RAIL
WILL COME IN A GRADE. ELEVATED
IN A TRANSIENT SO AS- AS BRIAN
WAS TALKING ABOUT DOING THIS
ADDITIONAL WORK TO GET TO THE
END POINTS. THAT HELPS US A LOT
FIGURE OUT WHAT OUR FINAL PHASE
OF THE PROJECT WILL BE. TO MAKE
THIS REALLY IMPORTANT
CONNECTION. SO BACK JUST IN
SUMMARY WE HAVE- A ONE POINT
THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN HAND
TO DATE. AND WE ESTIMATE WE
NEED ABOUT ONE POINT EIGHT BUT
LIKE I SAID WE'RE WE'RE STILL
WORKING WITH THAT NUMBER SO
THAT IS A LOT TO JUST GET
ROLLING WITH. WE DO HAVE SIX
NEW LOCOMOTIVES AND TWENTY ONE
RAIL CARS ON ORDER SO WE'RE
READY FOR THAT EXPANSIONIN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. THE STOCK
INDICTMENT WHICH REALLY IS THAT
I LOVE THIS PROJECT I LIKE TO
BUILD THINGS AND SO THIS ONE'S
GOING TO BE TERRIFIC. THE NEED
WILL BE CONCLUDED THIS FALL IN
THE FINAL ENGINEERING WILL
START. EARLY NEXT YEAR AND THEN
OUR CONSTRUCTION WAVES ONE AND
TWO WILL BE BEGINNING AND-
EARLY TWENTY TWENTY TWO SO. THE
LADY THAT LIKES TO BUILD STUFF
A LOT OF THINGS WILL BE IN
ACTION. A LITTLE LESS THAN A
YEAR FROM NOW SO WE'RE EXCITED
ABOUT ALL THAT'S GOING ON N
OUR NEIGHBORHOOD. WE'D BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE ABOUT OUR PROGRAM OR
THE COORDINATED WORK THAT WE'RE
DOING WITH BRIAN AND HIS FOLKS
AT HIGH SPEED RAIL AND THINK I
THINK. THANK YOU MISS MARTIN
SAID WE APPRECIATE THAT AND I'M
NEXT UP WE HAVE JIM HARTNETT
MISTER HEARTED FROM CALTRAIN. I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- CHAIRS AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO SUPPLY HER
TO APPEAR BEFORE. A JOINT
COMMITTEE AGAIN HI IN OUR
REGULAR REPORT. ALL RIGHT IT'S
A PLEASURE TO BE HERE FOR A
NUMBER OF REASONS- AS YOU KNOW
I REPRESENT CALTRAIN LINE WHICH
RUNS FROM SAN FRANCISCO TO SAN
JOSE- ON AB RIGHT AWAY THAT WE
OWN. HI AND WE ALSO OPERATE ON
U. P. LINE FROM SAN JOSE TO
GILROY. FROM OUR LINE IS A VERY
OLD BY. IT STARTED OUT WHEN
ABRAHAM LINCOLN WAS ON OFFICES-
IN. BEING OUT OF AN OLD BLIND
IT COME WITH A TREMENDOUS
CHALLENGES BUT WHAT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT ABOUT IT IS I RUN
THROUGH ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT ECONOMIC REGIONS. IN
THE WORLD. AND ITS IMPORTANCE
HAS ONLY INCREASED OVER TIME WE
PURCHASED THE LINE IN THE
NINETEEN NINETIES FROM SAN
FRANCISCO TO SAN JOSE. AND ON
THAT LINE- WE HAVE BEEN RUNNING
AN OLD DIESEL FLEET. ANOTHER
OLD DIESEL LEADERS SERVICE WELL
BECAUSE WE HAVE OVERTIME BILL
ABOUT OUR SERVICE UP TO BE IN
THE SEVENTH LARGEST COMMUTER
RAIL SERVICE IN THE COUNTRY.
AND ONE OF THE MOST EFFICIENTLY
RUN. BY IT'S TIME COME AND GONE.
AND IT IS NOW TIME THE FUTURE
CALTRAIN LINE AND DUE TO THE
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE STATE AND
HIGH SPEED RAIL AND WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND B. IN
THE NORTHERN BOOKEND FOR HIGH
SPEED RAIL WE ARE NOW IN A NEW
ERA. WE ARE IN THE MIDST OF OUR
ELECTRIFICATION PROJECT WE ARE-
BUILDING THE INFRASTRUCTURE
PUTTING IN THE POWER SYSTEMS-
BOARDING AND SIGNAL SYSTEMS AND
WE ARE HAVING OUR ELECTRIC
VEHICLES MANUFACTURED SUCH THAT
WE WILL BE UP AND RUNNING IN
ELECTRIFIED SERVICE I INNER
BLENDED SERVICE FOR HIGH SPEED
RAIL- WHEN IT COMES OUR WAY.
BUT THIS WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
POSSIBLE WITHOUT THE INVESTMENT
OF THE HIGH SPEED RAIL FUNDS.
INTO OUR SYSTEM- AND OTHER
FUNDS FOR HIGH SPEED RAIL IS A
TREMENDOUS PARTNER POOREST-
SENATOR DODD TALKED ABOUT HIGH
SPEED RAIL BEING WORK THE NEXT
GENERATION BEING BUILT FOR THE
NEXT GENERATION WELL- I HI I
HOPE IT'S STILL WORK MY
GENERATION I'M LOOKING FORWARD
TO SEEING IT. BUT I WILL TELL
YOU THAT THE INVESTMENT IN THE
BOOK AND THEN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA IS CLEARLY AN
INVESTMENT FOR THIS GENERATION
IT WILL PROVIDE A CLEAR
SERVICE. MORE FREQUENT SERVICE
RELIABLE SERVICE THROUGH THE
HEART OF SILICON VALLEY ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT REGIONS IN.
THE WORLD. WE SHOULD. OUR
PARTNERSHIP TYSON RAIL. WE ARE.
RATIFIED HAVE THAT WE WORK OUT
REGULARLY WITH THEM- HI AND WE
SUPPORT THE APPROACH OF HIGH
SPEED RAIL IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AS WELL- WELL DIED THE
BOOKENDS ALWAYS WANT MORE
INVESTMENT. AND WE WILL ALWAYS
WANT MORE INVESTMENT AS PART OF
THAT. THE CENTRAL VALLEY IS AN
IMPORTANT PART OF HIGH SPEED
RAIL THE SPYING OF IT IN
WITHOUT THAT'S FINE THERE IS NO
SYSTEM. AND SO WHILE THERE ARE
DIFFICULTIES TO OVERCOME. BUT
WE THINK IT IS THE RIGHT THING
TO DO WHILE THE INVESTMENTS
HAVE CONTINUED. IN THE IN THE
BOOK AND SEND PARTICULARLY IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE-
SUBMITTED WRITTEN MATERIALS FOR
YOUR REFERENCE JUST WILD READ
OUR POINT- BUT WE JUST WANTED
TO GIVE YOU A BRIEF.
HIGHLIGHTED WHERE WE ARE RIGHT
IN THE MIDST OF OUR
ELECTRIFICATION AND OUR
PARTNERSHIP WITH HIGH SPEED
RAIL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY. TO BRIEFLY
ADDRESS YOU TODAY. THANK YOU
MISTER HER AT WE APPRECIATE AND-
NEXT OUR FINAL. IS GENET- OWENS
FROM DELHI METRO MISS OWNS.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
GONZALEZ SHARED YOUR IDEAS
SENATORS AND CHAINS FOR TATIAN
COMMITTEE AND BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE NUMBER FIVE. MY NAME
IS JEANETTE ALLEN SENIOR
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY. ON
BEHALF OF VALLEY MATCHES CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER THE
WASHINGTON PROGRAM MANAGEMENT
OFFICER RICHARD CLARKE. YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY AN HONOR TO
SPEAK WITH YOU THIS MORNING AND
PROVIDE YOU AN UPDATE UNTIL THE
HIGHEST PRIORITY REGIONAL RAIL
PROJECTS IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AT THE PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
PLANNER COORDINATOR DESIGNER
BUILDER AND OPERATOR. SERVING
APPROXIMATELY TEN MILLION
PEOPLE IN LOS ANGELES. COUNTY
WITH A FLEET OF TWENTY THREE
METROBUSES FOR LIGHT RAIL
SYSTEMS INTO SUBWAY SYSTEM. L.
A. METRO VALUES AND APPRECIATES
PARTNERSHIP WE HAVE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY. SPANNING OVER A
DECADE IN MAKING STRATEGIC COME
CURRENT INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS. TOTALLING FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
ROSECRANS MARQUARDT GREAT
SEPARATION PROJECT AND THE
LINKING A STATION PROJECT.
THESE TWO PROJECTS ENHANCE
BOTH. OUR INNER CITY AND
COMMUTER RAIL SYSTEMS TODAY.
WHICH LINKS TOGETHER OVERTIME
ACCOMMODATES THE FUTURE HIGH
SPEED RAIL. THE CALIFORNIA HIGH
SPEED RAIL IS INVESTING SEVENTY
SIX POINT SEVEN MILLION APPROX
TWENTY FINES TOWARDS THE
STATE'S HIGHEST PRIORITY GRADE
CROSSING THAT WILL ENHANCE
SAFETY AND FACILITATE THE
INCREASE THE PASSENGER RAIL
SERVICES FOR THE COUNTIES OF
LOS ANGELES ORANGE RIVERSIDE
SAN BERNARDINO AND SAN DIEGO.
ROSECRANS MARQUARDT GRADE
SEPARATION PROJECT HAS ALREADY
RECEIVED OVER TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS. OF THE SEVENTY SIX
POINT SEVEN MILLION OF PROP
TWENTY FINE. FOR PROPERTY
ACQUISITION. AND THIS PROJECT
WILL BE IN CONSTRUCTION IN
EARLY TWENTY TWENTY TWO. LAST
YEAR IN FEBRUARY TWENTY TWENTY
THE CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED RAIL
BOARD FINANCIALLY COMMITTED THE
REMAINING FOUR HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THREE POINT THREE
MILLION. AB TWENTY FUNDS
TOWARDS THE FIRST PHASE OF THE
LINKING IT STATION PROJECT AS
THAT. DELINKING ADDITION
PROJECT WILL TRANSFORM HOW OUR
INTERCITY AND COMMUTER RAIL
SYSTEMS OPERATE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. WITH THE RUN
THROUGH JACQUI VISIBILITY AT
LOS ANGELES UNION STATION THAT
WILL PROVIDE ONE SEAT RIDES
FROM AMILY WITH THE BEST OF
SAN DIEGO. INCREASING OUR
REGIONAL RAIL SERVICE BY UP TO
SIXTY PERCENT. AS WELL AS THE
COMEDY THE FUTURE HIGH SPEED
RAIL SYSTEM. THE HEARING CANYON
STATION PROJECT COMPRISES OF T.
PHASES BOTH A DAY AND PLEASE BE
ESTIMATED AT THREE POINT FIVE
BILLION THAT WILL ALSO CONVERT
THE LARGEST MULTIMODAL RAIL
TRANSIT HUB IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA TO A WORLD CLASS
TERMINAL STATION. WITH THE
NATIONAL AND INTERNATIONAL
EVENTS COMING TO LOS ANGELES IN
THE NEXT SEVEN YEARS STARTING
WITH THE SUPER BOWL FIFTY TWO
AND TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THE
WORLD CUP IN TWENTY TWENTY SIX.
AND THE SUMMER OLYMPIC AND
PARALYMPIC GAMES IN TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT. AND COUPLED WITH
A GROWING POPULATION AND ALL IT
IN ALREADY DENSELY POPULATED
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA REGION OF
TWENTY FOUR MILLION PEOPLE MORE
THAN 50% OF THE STATE'S
POPULATION. MORE CRITICAL
REGIONAL RAIL TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS ARE
NEEDED IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
TODAY. ONE SUCH EXAMPLE IS THE
HIGH DESERT QUARTER INTERCITY
HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT THAT
WILL CONNECT LAS VEGAS TO
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN THE CITY
OF PALMDALE VIA BRIGHTLINE LAST.
WITH THE POTENTIAL FOR NEW
FEDERAL AND STATE FUNDING IN
HIGH SPEED RAIL. ONLY MEASURE
SUPPORTS THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
TWENTY TWENTY DRAFT BUSINESS
PLAN WITH THE ADDITION OF MORE
REGIONAL RAIL INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
SUCH AS THE RANKING INSTITUTION
BASED BE. HI DESERT QUARTER
PROJECT AND THE MEASURING
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA OPTIMIZE
RAIL EXPANSION PROGRAM. THESE
PROJECTS PROVIDE IMMEDIATE
BENEFITS THAT CAN BE USED TODAY
AND YET LAID THE FOUNDATION FOR
FUTURE HIGH SPEED RAIL
OPERATION SHOULD ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL AND STATE FUNDING BE
AVAILABLE. IF I STILL HAVE SOME
TIME I'D LIKE TO END MY
PRESENTATION WITH VIDEO CLIPS
OF THE ROSECRANS MARQUARDT
GRDE SEPARATION PROJECT AND
THE LINK UNION STATION PROJECT.
GO RIGHT AHEAD WITH SEVENTH
THANK YOU. SHARE SHARE. I'M
ASSUMING YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO SEE
THAT NOT AT THE MOMENT NOW IF
IT'S SOMETHING WE CAN'T GET UP
NOW OKAY THERE IT IS I THINK
THAT. ARE YOU ABLE TO SEE THAT
WE CAN SEE YOUR SCREEN BUT NO
VIDEO YET. OKAY YEAH. THANK
YOU. THE LITTLE KEVIN
COLLISIONS. LOS ANGELES STATION.
WE STILL CAN'T VIDEO. TWENTY
NINE UNION STATION AND IT WOULD
DIMINISH OUT AND IF WE CAN'T
SEE IT NOW THEN WE'LL GO AHEAD
AND JUST LEAVE IT UP ON OUR
WEBSITE AND THEN WE'LL MAKE
SURE THAT OUR MEMBERS ARE ABLE
TO SEE IT AT A FUTURE TIME I
APOLOGIZE I KNOW THAT TECHNICAL
ISSUES ALWAYS COME UP WITH
DIFFERENT PLATFORMS SO.
APOLOGIES FOR THAT. OKAY WHAT.
DID YOU HAVE ANY FINAL REMARKS.
NO THAT IS MY PRESENTATION I'M
SORRY AND NOW WE TESTED OUT
THIS MORNING I GUESS IT'S JUST
NOT WORKING TODAY IT LOOKS LIKE
IT SHOWING ON MY SCREEN BUT
IT'S NOT COMING THROUGH. THANK
YOU OKAY. MY PRESENTATION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISS OWNS WE
APPRECIATE THAT. THANK YOU OKAY
SO WHAT I'LL DO NOW IS WE'RE
GONNA GO TO MEMBER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS WE HAVE SENATOR DOLLY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. I KNOW
THAT- I'VE BEEN VERY CRITICAL
BUT THIS IS WHERE WE SHOULD
SPEND OUR MONEY LOCAL. READ
REGION'S WITH TRANSFERRED THAT
TO A TRANSPORTATION RAIL IS
WHERE WE CAN GET THE BEST BANG
FOR OUR BUCK THIS IS WHERE I
THINK THE LEGISLATURE COULD
REALLY. DO A GREAT JOB IN.
THOSE HIGH POPULATED AREAS TO
BE ABLE TO MOVE PEOPLE AND I
THINK THE IMPACT TO. THE
ENVIRONMENT WILL BE BETTER WE
CAN REDIRECT THOSE JOBS FROM.
FROM THE VALLEY TO THOSE
PROJECTS AND KEEP OUR OUR-
TRADES FOLKS WORK AND THAT'S
WHERE WE DO THAT I THINK THIS
LEGISLATURE SHOULD GO IS FIGURE
OUT A WAY. TO GO FOR THOSE
REGIONAL TRANSIT- DOLLARS
BECAUSE WE IT REALLY MAKES AN
IMPACT WE CAN MOVE PEOPLE MORE
EFFICIENTLY AND HELP THE
ENVIRONMENT OVER THE LONG HAUL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
DOLLY SENATOR CORTESE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- OF IF IT'S- IF
IT'S NOT A TIMELY I JUST WANTED
TO GO BACK UNDERSTAND THAT THE
PANELISTS ARE ALL HERE STILL
AVAILABLE TO US IS THAT CORRECT
THAT'S CORRECT THANK YOU AND
NOTHING WAS MISS- MISS KIRSTEN-
WAS. TALKING ABOUT. THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN FUNDING
DECISIONS HERE IN THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE IN WHAT
MAY BE COMING OUT OF THE
CONGRESS IN THE BINDER
MINISTRATION ULTIMATELY. I
WANTED TO GO BACK TO THAT
THREAT BECAUSE IT'S ONE THAT IT
WAS REFERENCED BY NEARLY ALL OF
THE PRESENTERS. SO FAR- IN IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT- IT WOULD BE.
EXTREMELY PRUDENT FOR US-
CERTAINLY SOMETHING OF TALK TO
OUR A SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE CHAIR
SENATOR ALSO ABOUT IN THE PAST-
TO DOVE TAIL. OUR EFFORTS AS
CLOSELY AS POSSIBLE WITH THE
ANTICIPATED. ACTIONS WHETHER
SUCCESSFUL OR NOT A COMING OUT
OF THE CONGRESS IN THE BITING
MINISTRATION IN IT AND I'M
WONDERING IF. IT'S A LITTLE
SORT OF A TWO PART QUESTION IF
ENOUGH HOMEWORK HAS BEEN DONE
WITH- ARE- ARE FEDERAL.
ADVOCATES THOSE THAT REPRESENTS
IN CALIFORNIA WASHINGTON COULD
TO DETERMINE AT LEAST THE RANGE
OF TIME- NGUYEN. THAT DECISION
OR THOSE DECISIONS ON
TRANSPORTATION REAUTHORIZATION-
POSSIBLE INCREASES THE FEDERAL
TRUST FUND WINDOWS WOULD LIKELY
COME TO A VOTE. IN THE CONGRESS
HERE AND- IF THAT HOMEWORK HAS
BEEN DONE IF WE HAVE THAT IDEA
I'D LIKE TO HEAR THAT ANSWER
NOW IF NOT I'D LIKE TO MAKE
SURE WE GET THAT INFORMATION SO
THAT WE CAN. IT LEAST. CONSIDER
THE ARGUMENT THAT.
APPROPRIATION DECISIONS HERE TO
GO BEYOND WHAT'S ALREADY BEEN
APPROPRIATED IF INDEED THOSE
ARE ON THE TABLE- ARE ARE NOT
MADE IN ADVANCE OF KNOWING OF
WHAT FEDERAL CONTRIBUTIONS
MIGHT BE AVAILABLE IN THIS
FISCAL YEAR. THE OKAY AND
SENATOR CORTESE THINK THAT WAS
DIRECTED TO MS CHRISTINE. YES I
THOUGHT THAT SHE- SHE HAS SOME
THOUGHTS ON THE SUBJECT AND IF
SHE FEELS SOMEBODY ELSE IS
BETTER EQUIPPED TO ANSWER
THAT'S FINE AS LONG ABSOLUTELY
THANK YOU. HI HI HI HI
CHRISTINE SO I DON'T. I DON'T
HAVE A LOT OF DETAIL EXACTLY
WHAT THE TIMING IS I UNDERSTAND
THAT- CERTAINLY THERE BEEN
RUMBLINGS ABOUT A POTENTIAL
INFRASTRUCTURE FELL ON THAT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL AND WE NEED TO
GET SOME MORE INFORMATION ABOUT
THAT IN THE COMING MONTHS. I'M
CERTAINLY MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THAT WOULD BE- PERHAPS BE
BEFORE NEXT YEAR- BEFORE HERE
NEXT YEAR BUT EXACTLY WHAT THE
TIMING WOULD BE- I'M NOT
CERTAIN AND MAYBE THAT AT THAT
MISTER THOMPSON OR THE THIRTY
WOULD HAVE SOME MORE SPECIFICS
ON THAT BUT- MY UNDERSTANDING
IS CERTAINLY IF WE- COME BACK
NEXT YEAR WE HAVE MORE CLARITY.
THANK YOU AND MISTER THOMPSON
DID YOU HAVE ANY SORRY ABOUT
THAT CENTER CORTESE ANY OTHER
THOUGHTS MISTER THOMPSON. NO I
DON'T I DON'T KNOW WHO OR WHEN
pTHE TIMING MIGHT BE I WOULD
CERTAINLY EXPECT THAT THE
ATTENTION WILL TURN TO THIS
KIND OF THING AFTER THE
COMPLETE RELEASE BILL IS SO.
ABSORBED AND AFTER THE
STRUCTURE OF THE CONGRESS I'M
SURE THEY'RE GOING TO BE
PASSING A FEW OTHER THINGS AND
THEN THEY MIGHT TURN TO THIS. I
DO WANT TO ADD THAT MOST
FEDERAL PROGRAMS OF THIS KIND.
REQUIRES STATE JUNIOR OF ONE
KIND OR THE OTHER SO WE SHOULD
BE AWARE OF THE FACT THAT THAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
ALMOST CERTAIN REALLY NOT GOING
TO RECORD GOD TO RESCUE US INTO
A TELLER DAY. BUT IT CERTAINLY
COULD BE VERY HELPFUL. BUT IF
THERE IS A STATE SHARE WE
SHOULD BE PREPARED TO DISCUSS
HOW WE MIGHT PROVIDE IT ONE
OPTION. IS THE CAP AND TRADE
WHICH MIGHT SUFFICE IF. THE
STATE SHARE IS SMALL ENOUGH. BY
THE HELL WILL I THINK. BY
SUMMER WE SHOULD HAVE MUCH
BETTER IDEA OF THE ROLE THAT
THE BY THE ADMINISTRATION CAN
PLAGUE THE CITY TO CONGRESS TO
GETTING ANYTHING DONE. AND
CERTAIN WILL HAVE A BETTER
SENSE OF WHAT THE PRIORITIES
ARE FOR INFRASTRUCTURE IS CLOSE
TO THE OTHER PROBLEMS THEY FACE.
THE MANAGER IF I COULD JUST ASK
IF IT'S NOT IT BUT
INAPPROPRIATE I DON'T THINK IT
IS BUT IT WOULD. I WOULD I
WOULD DEFER TO. SENATOR ALSO IS
CHAIR OF SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE
WHICH TAKES UP TRANSPORTATION.
MEETING WHICH I UNDERSTAND IS
ANNUAL- IT WAS SO WE DON'T HAVE
TO WAIT UP FOR YOU A YEAR- THAT
ARE CHAIR CONSIDER A
SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE SURE CONSIDER
ASKING. THE STATE'S FEDERAL
LOBBYISTS TO COME IN INTO TO
TRY TO DO A BETTER JOB OF
PINPOINTING- THE TIME FOR A PIN
POINT IS PROBABLY THE WRONG
WORD PUT ESTABLISHING- THE TIME
FRAME THIS YEAR. OF WHEN THOSE
EXPECTED DECISIONS OR EFFORTS
MIGHT BE MADE. OF BECAUSE I DO
I DO THINK IT. IT COULD BE
CRITICAL IN. IT INFORMING US AS
TO WHEN WE MIGHT WANT TO TAKE
UP THE SUBJECT MATTER AGAIN OF
STATE APPROPRIATIONS CIRCLE
BEYOND EXISTING APPROPRIATIONS
AND AGAIN I KNOW WE TALKED
ABOUT IT BEFORE BUT IT SEEMS
LIKE MAYBE IT WAS UNFAIR TO ASK
FOLKS WHO WHO AREN'T ON THE
SPOT. IN IN WASHING DC AND
WORKING THAT SIDE OF THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS TODAY FOR
THOSE NSWERS BUT I DO KNOW
THAT WE HAVE A GOOD PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN THAT POSITION THAT COULD
ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS AND
CENTER DRAWS ON ME THAT BE PUT
ON THE AGENDA. IN YOUR
COMMITTEE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU SENATOR CORTESE AND
IT LOOKS LIKE SENATOR DID ALSO-
HAS OBLIGED TO THAT GREAT
WONDERFUL. THANK YOU FOR THAT.
ALL RIGHTS SO THAT LOOKS LIKE
IT IS THE END OF QUESTIONS I
APOLOGIZE ACTUALLY ONE MORE
CHAIRED THE RUSSELL. OOPS OKAY.
YES I'D LIKE TO ASK MISS OWENS-
WHAT KIND OF BENEFITS I MEAN I
WAS I WAS THINKING OF A L. A.
COUNTY WITH TEN MILLION BUT
THEN YOU REALLY TALK ABOUT THE
WHOLE AREA SEVERAL COUNTIES AND
THAT'S TWENTY THREE MILLION
PEOPLE WHAT KIND OF BENEFITS-
WILL OF THEIR OUR REGION IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA OR THE
AROUND THE L. A. COUNTY AN
ORANGE COUNTY AREA WE SEE FROM
THIS PROJECT BEFORE THE
COMPLETION OF PHASE ONE- AND IS
THERE ANYTHING THAT WE CAN DO
TO MAXIMIZE THE BENEFITS TO
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. IN THE
MEANTIME. THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION J. DRIVE HERE. I'M
RIGHT NOW THE BILL CAN PROJECTS
SLATED FOR PROPOSITION ONE NAY
IS APPROXIMATELY FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. SO THAT IS FOR
THOSE TWO PROJECTS AND
ROSECRANS MARQUARDT IN THE
LINKING INCISION PROJECT. AS
PART OF PHASE. ONE IT THAT IS
THE CURRENT STATE AVAILABLE
FUNDING THAT'S IN THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL BUSINESS PLAN TODAY.
THE SEVEN IT'S FIVE HUNDRED
THAT'S IT. THAT'S IT THANK YOU
GREAT THANK YOU CHAIRED RUSSELL.
OKAY DOESN'T LOOK LIKE THERE'S
ANY MORE QUESTIONS FROM
SENATORS AND MEMBERS SO WE'RE
GONNA GO AHEAD AND WE THINK OUR
OUR PANELISTS ALL OF THE FOR
BEING HERE AND PRESENTING
TODAY- BEFORE WE MIGHT MOVE ON
TO MEMBER QUESTIONS AGAIN I'D
LIKE TO INVITE THE PUBLIC WHO
WOULD LIKE TO PARTICIPATE TO
COLIN NOW PLEASE. DIAL THE TOLL
FREE NUMBER. 1-844-291-6364
WHEN PROMPTED PLEASE USE ACCESS
CODE. EIGHT SEVEN SIX EIGHT
NINE FOUR ONE. OKAY WE DON'T
HAVE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS SO- WE
WILL GO AHEAD AND MOVE ON TO
PUBLIC COMMENTS WE'VE LOOKED AT
THE GALLERY THERE ARE NO-
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
GALLERY. AND WHICH IS ROOM ONE
TWELVE AND NOW WILL MOVE ON TO
THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ON
THE TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT WE WILL
BEGIN THANK. THANK YOU LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN THE PHONE LINES
IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR WILL GIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER OFFLINE AND
PUSH YOU BACK INTO THE QUEUE.
OUR FIRST COMMENT COMES FROM
LINE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GO RIGHT AHEAD. PICTURE
GONZALEZ TURNED IT ALSO AND
MEMBERS OF THE RESPECTIVE
COMMITTEES ADDRESS ARMY DOES ON
BEHALF OF THE TRANSBAY JOINT
POWERS AUTHORITY WHICH OVERSEES
THE OPERATIONS OF THE MULTI
MODAL SALESFORCE TRANSIT CENTER
IN DOWNTOWN SAN FRANCISCO HERE
TO VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY'S TWENTY TWENTY
DROPPED IN THIS PLAN. THE PDPA
CAN AND STRONGLY. THEM BY
CLEARANCE AND COMPLETION OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY PORTION OF THE
PROJECT. ADDITIONALLY THE DRAFT
PLAN SETS FORTH A PATH TO
ELECTRIFICATION AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE WE'LL CONTINUE TO
ADVANCE THE ENTIRE HIGH SPEED
RAIL SYSTEM FROM SAN FRANCISCO
THE LOS ANGELES BASIN. AS SUCH
WE REMAIN COMMITTED TO
SUPPORTING THE VITAL CENTRAL
VALLEY SEGMENT BUT ARE ALSO
ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT THE EMPHASIS
ON ADVANCING CONSTRUCTION ON
THE BOOK AND PROJECTS IN THE
BAY AREA AND LOS ANGELES BASIN.
OF WHICH THE TRANSIT CENTER
WOULD BE THE NORTHERN TERMINUS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE AND WE'LL
GIVE EVERYONE ABOUT ONE MINUTE.
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING I'M DAVID SHARON BROWN
WITH THE TRADES. TRAIN RIDERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WE'RE
RAIL ADVOCATES WE DO NOT SEE A
BUSINESS IN THE SO CALLED
BUSINESS PLAN. THE AUTHORITY
HAS SPENT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
AND NOT IMPROVE RAIL SERVICE
ONE IOTA SO FAR. WE COULD HAVE
SPECIFIED PROJECTS FOR THAT
AMOUNT THAT WOULD DRAMATICALLY
INCREASE RAIL RIDERSHIP. WE ARE
CONFIDENT THAT INVESTING IN THE
LOS AND- BETWEEN SAN DIEGO AND
SAVE THEM FOR ORDERS- WOULD
MAKE IT FASTER THAN DRIVING ON
I. FIVE AND THAT WOULD B FAR
MORE PRODUCTIVE THAN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY LINE. WE BELIEVE
THE QUESTION THE SENATE SHOULD
BE ASKING IS WHAT LEVEL ON THE
CAN REALISTICALLY BE EXPECTED
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WITHOUT EIGHTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS THIS PROJECT CAN'T
CONNECT TO THE BAY AREA. WE
CAN'T IMAGINE CALIFORNIA BE
GIVEN FOUGHT ON THAT SCALE.
WITHOUT THAT LEVEL OF
CONTRIBUTION. I DON'T SEE ANY
ABILITY THIS PROJECT EVER GOING
BEYOND THE VALLEY. WE THANK YOU
THIS PROJECT WAS DESIGNED TO BE
FAR TOO EXPENSIVE. BILL FOR
THAT REASON WE SUGGEST YOU TO
THE L. A. AND SEVERELY LOOK THE
TRACKING SYSTEM CONTRA. WELL
MISS THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS WE'RE GONNA GIVE
EVERYBODY ABOUT ONE MINUTE I
APOLOGIZE FOR INTERRUPTING.
MODERATOR IF YOU CAN PLEASE
GIVE ME THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY AS
WELL. THERE IS A LOT I CAN'T. I
PROBABLY TWENTY FIVE I WOULD
YES OKAY THANK YOU LET'S KEEP
GOING NEXT COMMENT PLEASE OKAY.
WE WILL GO TO LINE ELEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
SENATORS MIGHT. MY NAME IS
ROLAND PROGRAM I WAS BORN IN
EUROPE AND MOVED TO TEN OF THE
THIRTY FIVE YEARS AGO. THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAY TO ACHIEVE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION. FIFTY
TRANSITION PASSENGER RAIL AND
FREIGHT ALL OF THE FIELDS
SOMETHING WE TEND TO BE
POPULATED URBAN AREAS. EVERY
HIGH SPEED RAIL COMPANY IN THE
WORLD. STOP IT WE IS A RARE AND
A CONFIGURATION OVER HIGH
CENTURY PEOPLE BUILDING THAT
HOUSED LINE. AN EXAMPLE THE
FRENCH HIGH SPEED RAIL NETWORK
COMPANIES ALL OVER TEN THOUSAND
MILES OF I THINK TO. SERVING BY
HIGHEST TRAIN TO UNLEASH
HUNDRED MILE OF. HIGH SPEED
LINES ALSO WHICH BY FIFTY AND
TIME THE PLEASE STOP THE HIGH
RAIL. FROM THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
CAR. BEFORE THE- HOLES THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. THANKS
NEXT WE ARE GOING TO GO TO LINE
FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH I AM SURE THIS IS KEEP
DONE ON BEHALF OF THE DISTRICT
COUNCIL OF IRON WORKERS ALSO
TODAY FOR JOE CRUISE WITH THE
LABORS YOU GOT PULLED INTO A
MEETING. WE JUST LIKE TO
CONTINUE TO CREATE OUR SUPPORT
FOR INVESTINGIN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY I'LL POINT OUT TO. THE
PALACE SAID THE CENTER VALLEY
DOES HAVE SOME OF THE MOST
CONGESTED AREAS AS FAR AS
TRAFFIC IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THIS INVESTMENT WILL
HELP EASE THAT CONGESTION
IMPROVING NOT ONLY OUR
ENVIRONMENT ALSO CALL THE WIVES
WORK MILLIONS OF PEOPLE WHO
LIVE IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
DISINVESTMENT HAS BEEN A
LIFELINE TO BOTH IRON WORKERS
AND LABORERS PROVIDING JOBS WE
LIKE TO SUPPORT PRESIDENT BIDEN
BUILD BACK BETTER WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS. HIGH SPEED RAIL
PROJECT IS THE- PERFECT TOP. TO
CURB. A SPACE FOR HIGH SPEED
RAIL IN THE UNITED STATES. WE
CAN LEAD TO SUPPORT THE
INVESTMENT THE CENTRAL VALLEY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. NEXT WE
WILL ALIGN FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING- MY NAME IS
BRIAN GANDHI I AM THE VICE
PRESIDENT SOUTH OF THE RAIL
PASSENGERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND NEVADA OR RAIL
PACKED. A WORD ALL VOLUNTEER
ORGANIZATION- BEEN AROUND SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT AND
WE'VE BEEN SUPPORTING HIGH
SPEED RAIL CALIFORNIA. SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT. AND I
WOULD LIKE TO DO- ENCOURAGED
THE LEGISLATURE TO ADOPT THE
CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED RAIL
THIRTY BUSINESS PLAN AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE ALLOCATION
OF THE FOUR POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS THE REMAINING PROP ONE
EIGHTY FUNDS TO GO TO THE
CENTRAL VALLEY- AND ELECTRIFIED
OPERATING SEGMENT. AND AS A
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIAN I LIVE
WITHIN WALKING DISTANCE OF. A
MAJOR MATTER LINKED ASIAN AT
BOTH INPATIENT. AND ABOUT
BULLETIN- AND BUT I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE EFFORT IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY I DON'T WANT ONE
ANY OF. FUNDING FOR THE CENTRAL
VALLEY SEGMENT- DID THE PUBLIC
CALIFORNIA RAIL PROJECT THANK
YOU- WE ALREADY HAVE THIRTY ONE
BILLION IN COMMITTED FUNDING IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA RAIL AND
TRANSIT PROJECTS. AND TAKING
AWAY FOUR BILLION OF THAT IN
MAKING THAT THE THIRTY FIVE
BILLION IS NOT EQUITABLE AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY PLAN
TO GOOD MORNING THANK YOU WE'RE
GONNA GIVE EVERYBODY ABOUT ONE
MINUTE I'M SORRY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR COMMENT DISCARDED. TO
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA NEXT COMMON
RELEASE. IT SHOULD COME FROM.FREEWAY PROJECT THERE'S A LOT
OF WEIGHT MODERATOR CAN I GO TO
THE NEXT COMMENT PLEASE WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO WAIT TOO MUCH
UNFORTUNATELY CUT PEOPLE OFF AT
ONE MINUTE. THIS CAUSES MORE
TRAFFIC CONGESTION POLLUTION
THANK YOU. MODERATOR CAN WE-
HOW MANY DO WE HAVE LEFT IN THE
QUEUE CAN YOU SEE NOW- THERE'S
PROBABLY A GOOD. TWENTY OKAY
GREAT AND EVERYONE GETS ABOUT
ONE MINUTE PLEASE NEXT COMMENT
PLEASE. THANK YOU WE WILL GO TO
LINE YEAH PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIRWOMAN IN
SENATORS HI MY NAME IS ED EVANS
OF CARPENTERS LOCAL TWO
SEVENTEEN REPRESENTING SAN
MATTEO COUNTY IN OUR MEMBERSHIP
STANDS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
HYBRID HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT.
THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. MOVING ALONG
WITH WE WILL GO TO ONE FORTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. FORTY
THREE PLEASE PUT YOURSELF BACK
IN Q. AND WE WILL LINE. THIRTY
ONE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
THIS IS OUR ROBERT STEPS ABOUT
THAT PETER ACCURATE FRESNO
COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS BUT WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL- OF THE LOWER EAST REVISED
DRAFT TWENTY TWENTY BUSINESS
PLAN. AS YOU KNOW AN
INDEPENDENT- USE CONFIRM THAT
THE MERCED FRESNO BIGGER STILL
CORRIDOR- AND IMPROVEMENTS IN
SUPPORTING THE ALTAMONT
CORRIDOR EXPRESS OF SAN JOAQUIN
RAIL- AND BUS SERVICES
OBTAINING THE HIGHEST FORECAST
EIGHTEEN RIDERSHIP AND DOES SO
AT THE LOWEST INCREASE IN COST-
THE- FRESNO CALLED ALSO
STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE REVISED-
TWENTY TWENTY- BUSINESS PLAN
RECOMMENDATION THAT THE FOUR
POINT ONE MILLION IN REMAINING
PROPERTY- FUNDS. BE DIRECTED TO
COMPLETE DELIVERY OF THE ONE
HUNDRED NINETEEN MILE
ELECTRIFIED CENTRAL VALLEY
SEGMENT AND THAT THE REMAINING
ONE HUNDRED MILLION IN BOND
FUNDS BE USED FOR EARLY DESIGN
COMPLETING ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW- ON SAN FRANCISCO TO LOS
ANGELES BASED ONE SEGMENTS- IT
IS IMPERATIVE. THAT THAT WE
MOVE FOR INCOME THE ENTRY
OPERATING SECTOR AS MANY BALLOT
ARE. CONSTRUCTION WITH THINGS
HIGH RAIL F. DELIVERING A STATE
OF THE ART PASSENGER
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM WILL HAVE
A LASTING AND POSITIVEECONOMIC
IMPACT OF THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY THANK. ALL OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR WE
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS THANK
YOU FOR CALLING IN NEXT COMMENT
PLEASE. WE WERE LINE TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
TWENTY THREE YOU ARE OPEN TO
LOCAL TRAFFIC. HELLO YES RIGHT
AHEAD WE CAN HEAR YOU WITH THE
RIGHT FIELD REP CARPENTERS
LOCAL TWENTY. TWO AND SAN
FRANCISCO WE FULLY SUPPORT THE
BUILDING OF HIGH SPEED RAIL IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU AS WELL
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. ONE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR THE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS MIKE BIEN ON THE
DEPUTY CITY MANAGER FROM THE
CITY OF PALMDALE THEY UPON
THOSE SUPPORT HIGH SPEED RAIL
AND WE SUPPORT THE DROUGHT
UPDATED BUSINESS PLAN WE
APPRECIATE THE STRONG
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE AUTHORITY
WE BELIEVE THAT IT'S IMPORTANT
TO COMPLETE THE HIGHER NINETEEN
MILES OF ELECTRIFIED RAIL
INFRASTRUCTURE CURRENTLY UNDER
CONSTRUCTION. IN TO CONTINUE
THEIR EDUCATION THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE SYSTEM TO COMPLETE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING TO
FINALIZE THE RODS FOR THE
REMAINING SEGMENTS TO ALLOW THE
RELEASE OF THE REQUESTED BOND
AND AT THE RIGHT TIME EXTEND
HIGH SPEED ROLLED ON THE L. WE
ARE STANDING READY I WILL CLOSE
WITH. THE AUTHORITY HAS FOUND
ITS FOOTING AND IS MAKING GREAT
PROGRESS PLEASE STAY COMMITTED
TO THE PROJECT AND AS SENATOR
MEN SAID DON'T GIVE UP THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FOR
CALLING AND NEXT COMMENT PLEASE.
WE WILL ALIGN FIFTY TWO. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIRMAN SENATORS MANY TIMES WE
SEND YOU WITHOUT SUMMATIONS
CONCERN CALIFORNIA LOCAL SIX
HUNDRED AND A LONGTIME STATE
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE HIGH SPEED. RAIL PROJECT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS
MORNING'S MEETING THANK YOU AS
WELL NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. ONE
THIRTEEN YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS MY NAME IS EUGENE
MORRIS WITH CARPENTERS LOCAL
ONE FIFTY TWO IN RECESS I'M
CALL INSTRUCTS SUPPORT OF THE
HIGH SPED RAIL REVISED DRAFT
TWENTY TWENTY BUSINESS PLAN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
HAVE A GOOD DAY THANK YOU HAVE
A GOOD DAY AS WELL THANK YOU
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. ONE THIRTY
SIX YOU ARE UP. HELLO MY NAME
IS RICK SO LEAD TIME-
REPRESENTATIVE WITH CARPENTERS
LOCAL FOUR OH FIVE IN SANTA DAY
REPRESENTING SANTA CLARA AND
SAN BENITO COUNTIES AND I WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR CONTINUED
SUPPORT FOR THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
PROJECT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT COMMENT. WE WILL MOVE
ALONG TO LINE TWELVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MANAGER
SENATORS MY NAME IS KAYLA AND
I'M WITH THE INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF OPERATING ENGINEERS
LOCAL TWELVE. THIS PROJECT
GENERATES HUNDREDS OF MIDDLE
CLASS JOBS FOR OUR MEMBERS
HELPING TO STABILIZE THE STATE
AND LOCAL ECONOMIES LOCAL
TWELVE STANCE WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES COUNCIL IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL. AND WE'RE TO SEND
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE ALONG
WITH THE SENATE BUDGET
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THIS
PROJECT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT COMMENT. ONE FIFTY EIGHT
MADAM CHAIR AND LEGISLATORS HI
MY NAME IS AUGGIE BILL JAM WITH
THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
CARPENTERS REGIONAL COUNCIL
RESTRAINT STANDING STRONG
SUPPORT HIGH SPEED RAIL ANY
AUTHORITIES BUSINESS PLAN. HI
SPEED RAIL HAS PROVIDED
HUNDREDS OF JOBS FOR OUR
MEMBERS IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
BUT PLENTY OF PEOPLE INTO
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS AND GET
MEMBERS FROM DRIVING OVER INTO
THE BAY AREA. SO WE THANK YOU
AMHERST IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANKS THANK YOU NEXT COMMENT
PLEASE. WE WILL ALIGN FORTY SIX
WHO ARE OPEN. I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THIS IS DAVID CAMERON AND
ON BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS RAIL
CONFERENCE IN ITS SEVENTY
THOUSAND MEMBERS IN THE
INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
TEAMSTERS ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION MEMBERS WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE AUTHORITY'S DRAFT
TWENTY TWENTY BUSINESS PLANS
AND FUNDING PLAN. CALIFORNIA'S
BUILDING NOT JUST A TWENTY
FIRST TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM
CONNECTING CALIFORNIA TO LOS
ANGELES THIS BILL IN THE SYSTEM
THAT WILL TIE THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IS THE ECONOMIC ENGINES
NORTH AND SOUTH. NOW IS NOT THE
TIME TO LOSE HEART FOR THE PAST
FOUR YEARS WE DEALT WITH THE
NEW ADMINISTRATION THAT. WAS TO
THIS. WE NOW HAVE A PRESIDENT.
THAT I HAD THE HONOR OF SERVING
ON THE TRANSITION TEAM. WHO
COMMITTED TO SUPPORTING THE
NEXT GREAT PASSENGER RAIL
REVOLUTION IN THIS COUNTRY AND-
BEING A STORY AS THE SENATE AND
THE- ASSEMBLY ISSUES SHOULD THE
COURSE AND APPROVED HIS PLAN
APPROVE THE FUNDING THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. WE WERE
LINE FIFTY FIVE YOU ARE OPEN.
THIS IS RICK HARNISH I MEAN
SECOND DIRECTOR OF THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL ALLIANCE. WE'RE A
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION WORKING
FOR HIGH SPEED RAIL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY- WE HAVE HAD NEARLY A
HUNDRED PAYING MEMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
A TREMENDOUS LEADER IN
DEVELOPING PASSENGER RAIL AND
TRANSIT NATIONWIDE- FOR THE
LAST THREE DECADES WE'RE
EXCITED ABOUT THE PROGRESS
YOU'RE MAKING ON HIGH SPEED
RAIL. AND WOULD LIKE TO
ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONTINUE WITH
A STRONG COMMITMENT TO BUILDING
HIGH SPEED RAIL. AND WE WELCOME
HELPING ARE WORKING WITH YOU TO
GAIN AN ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
PROGRAM IN ORDER TO EXPEDITE
THE PROGRAM THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. AND WE
WERE LINE. TWENTY FIVE. GOOD
MORNING ON A ROLL CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CHRIS CANNON I'M A COUNCIL
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE LOS
ANGELES ORANGE COUNTY'S
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL. R. FORTY EIGHT
AFFILIATES REPRESENTING OVER A
HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND OF THE
BEST TRAINED MEN AND WOMEN IN
THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY THE
END IN FULL SUPPORT OF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL CONTINUES
SUPPORT OF CONSTRUCTION. AND
THE COMPLETE BUILD OUT OF THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL SYSTEM THANK
YOU THANK YOU CHRIS- NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. THANK YOU WE
WERE LYING SIXTY. GOOD MORNING
AUDIBLE CHAIRS COMPLETE MATTER
MEMBERS MANY OF THEM LOVE IT
AND I REPRESENT THE CENTER I
WHILE WORKING GROUP'S SHELL
REGIONAL COMMISSION AND THE SAN
JOAQUIN JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY.
THE CENTRAL ROLE WORKING GROUP
INCLUDES ALL THE REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING
AGENCIES REGIONAL RAIL
OPERATORS COUNTIES AND MAJOR
CITIES SACRAMENTO TO MERCED
CORRIDOR. THE SALE REGIONAL
COMMISSION IS THE OWNER
OPERATOR OF THE EIGHT COMMUTER
RAIL SERVICE SAN JOAQUIN DOING
POWERS ACCORDING TO MANSION
AGENT OF THE STATE FUNDED I AM
LOOKING INTERCEDE SIR. CENTER
I'M A WORKING THE TOWN CAME
RESULT AND COUNTY ENJOY POWERS
AUTHORITY HAVE SIMILAR FORMAL.
WRONGLY SUPPORTING HIGH SPEED
RAIL AUTHORITY REVISED DRAFT
TWENTY TWENTY BUSINESS PLAN
ACCORDIONS LETTERS TO YOUR
COMMITTEE ALONG WITH OTHER
LETTERS FROM FROM MANY OTHER
CENTRAL VALLEY AGENCIES
ORGANIZATIONS AND ELECTED
OFFICIALS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
HELP. THANK YOU NEXT COMMENT
PLEASE. THANK YOU WE ALIGN
FIFTY SEVEN. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS HI JEFF THE
KILLER REALTY BROKER MANAGER AT
THE CHAMBER DISCOUNT TRANSFER
AUTHORITY. I AM PLEASED TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE CITY AND
OF SAN FRANCISCO THIS MORNING.
IMAGE BECAUSE WORKING CLOSE
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL AUTHORITY AND THE
TRANSLATE JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY TO DEVELOP THE
DOWNTOWN RAIL EXTENSION PROJECT
TO THE SALESFORCE TRANSIT
CENTER. THE NORTHERN TERMINUS
THE PHASE ONE OF THE CALIFORNIA
HIGH SPEED RAIL SYSTEM.
DEMOCRATS WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY'S REVISED
BUSINESS PLAN AND ITS REQUEST
FOR BOND FUNDS TO COMPLETE THE
CENTRAL VALLEY SEGMENT AND
DEVELOP MAKES TO THE REST OF
CALIFORNIA. CONNECTING THE
CENTRAL VALLEY TO SILICON
VALLEY VIA HIGH SPEED RAIL WILL
PROVIDE A CRITICAL LOW CARBON
CONNECTION FOR INTER REGIONAL
CONNECTIVITY WHILE MAINTAINING
AND CREATING THOUSANDS OF JOBS.
THAT CONGRESS TAKES UP
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT ALSO.
HAVE APARTMENT INTEREST POP. TO
BRING REGIONAL AND FEDERAL TO
GET FOR THE REST. IN THE- OF K.
WE LOOK TO YOUR OUR PARTNERSHIP
IT STEPFORD CAL. HIGH SPEED
RAIL PROGRAMS THE COMING MONTHS
AND YEARS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. THIS MORNING THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE APPRECIATE
THAT NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. FIND
SIXTY FIVE YOUR OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS VINCE AUGUST
OF A REPRESENTATIVES
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS LOCAL
TWELVE WE SENT A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF THIS PROJECT
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE WILL NOT
ONLY PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED WORK
FOR OUR MEMBERS. BUT- MEMBERS
OF MEN WOMEN OF ALL TRADES GOOD
PAYING JOBS AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY BEING HER TODAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
NEXT COMMENT PLEASE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR WE WILL GO TO LINE
FORTY THREE YOUR- THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR- MADAM CHAIRS- HALF
OF THE STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL- WE
BELIEVE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
LEADERS NEED TO STAY THE COURSE
AND RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
YOUR BEST FRIEND HIGH SPEED
RAIL. PARTICULARLY INVESTMENT
CENTRAL VALLEY- WOULD IT BE
REVITALIZED PARTNERSHIP THE
STATE AND THE BY THE
MINISTRATION QUICKLY
CALIFORNIA'S CLOSER THAN EVER
TOWARD REALIZING A WORLD CLASS
TECHNOLOGICAL. RECENTLY
SECRETARY TRANSPORTATION PETE
BUDGET AS WE ENTER THE
PRESIDENT BY DEVELOPING
BELIEVER IN PAST UNITY RIGHT
STATES WE LEADING THE WAY WHEN
IT COME BACK. WHEN YOU COME
OTHER. COMING TO. BY THE
MINISTRATIONS ONE MISSISSIPPI
HIGH FIGURE. CALIFORNIA'S GOAL
CONNECTED COMMUNITIES GROW GOOD
JOB. AND CLIMATE CHANGE AS WELL
AS INSIGHT. DESPITE THE PAIN IN
THE KNESSET HIGH FIGURE
CONTINUES TO BE A TRUE WANT TO
THE- ECONOMIC. GENERATOR THE
PROJECT IS CREATED- OVER IT TWO
HUNDRED HIGH. JOB WITH SEVENTY
SEVEN OF THOSE. COME EIGHT.
CENTRAL VALLEY. BERNIE READING
THE MANY MORE WHICH ARE THE
BUSINESS. THE FINAL PROBLEM
FUND PREPARATION ASK YOU TO
STAND WITH THEM AND AGAIN KEEP
YOUR HER BACKGROUND. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE ACTUALLY MISS
MODERATOR BEFORE WE GET TO THE
NEXT HOW MANY UP. A PART. TO BE
IN THE QUEUE- RAY NOW WE ARE AT.
FIVE MORE PARTICIPANTS WOULD
YOU LIKE TO REPEAT- NO WILL GO
AHEAD AND- FORWARD THE FIVE YOU
NEXT CALL. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MATT CHAIR AND FIFTY PLEASE
AHEAD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD
EVERYBODY- IS BENITO BLISS ON
MAY. REPRESENT FOR THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT COUNCIL
LABORERS. THE NEW AND JOINING
THE BUILDING TRADES IN THEIR
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE HIGH FEEL
I RAIL- JURY THE STORM FROM THE-
THANK YOU HAVE A GREAT DAY.
THANK YOU AS WELL NEXT PLACE.
THANK YOU- WE WILL GO TO LINE
EIGHT. HI GOOD MORNING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON MY CLEAN
ORDER JACKET DIRECTOR PRINCE
FRESNO COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY AND PART OF THE
FRESNO WORKS COALITION. WE'RE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE BUSINESS PLAN
PROPOSAL TO COMPLETE THEM SAID
TO BAKERSFIELD HIGH SPEED RAIL
OPERATING SEGMENT. I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT THE SINGLETRACK
PROPOSAL AND HOPE IT IS
ADDITIONAL FUNDS ARE IDENTIFIED
TO DOUBLE TRACK SYSTEM CAN BE
LIKE RESTORED. OUR BIGGEST
CONCERN IS NOT DIMINISH MY
SUPPORT FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUSINESS PLAN AND I RECOMMENDED
IT BE APPROVED THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT COMMENT
PLEASE. MOVING ALONG WE WILL GO
TO LINE SIXTY FOUR. HI MY NAME
IS PAUL GETS DORIAN I'M THE
OWNER CATCHER BRIAN MENTAL IN
FRESNO- WERE PART OF THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL ONE OF THE
SUBCONTRACTORS AND PRIOR TO THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL- A COMPANY HAD
SIX EMPLOYEES AND THANK THEM
WE'VE GROWN TO THIRTY EIGHT
EMPLOYEES. AND UTILIZING THE
TARGETED- EMPLOYEE SEARCH WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO HIRE 85% OF OUR
LABOR FORCE. FROM- PEOPLE
COMING UP PUBLIC ASSISTANCE AND
THOSE- NEW EMPLOYEES HAVE DONE
VERY WELL FOR THEMSELVES THE
GOVERNMENT CELLS. ARE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THEY HAVE NOW FULL
TIME JOBS WITH BENEFITS AND
SOME OF THEM BECOME HOMEOWNERS.
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL HAS BEEN
ABLE TO HELP THEM OUT AND ALSO
SPEED MY COMPANY WE CURRENTLY
ARE STILL WORKING ON IT BUT IT
HAS A LOT OF TO GROW. AND NOW
WE'RE CURRENTLY ABLE TO- WORK
ANOTHER PROJECT THAT WE WOULD
BE ABLE TO PRIOR TO HIGH SPEED
RAIL SUCH AS BUILDING POLICE
STATIONS AND FIRE STATIONS SO I
SPEAKER OF NOT ONLY HELP.
FRESNO HELP MY COMPANY GROW
HELPED OUR EMPLOYEES THIS HELP
IN THE FUTURE OF OUR COMPANY
AND ITS EMPLOYEES TO MOVE ON TO
OTHER THINGS INCLUDING THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL SO WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. FOR THAT NEXT
COMMENT PLEASE. BY SIXTY NINE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MATT
SHARING ENGINE AND HERE ON
BEHALF OF FRIENDS MAYOR DIE
RECORD THE FIFTH LARGEST CITY
IN THE- ORANGE STRONG SUPPORT
AND WE WERE DROPPED TWENTY TWO
GLOBAL. I REVISED CHOI TWENTY
DOES PLAN MANY INVESTMENT ALL
BEEN MADE IN ARE YOU AND THE
POTENTIAL. WE'VE STRONG IN THE-
HAVING TO COMPLY. THERE ARE
MANY TO GET TO THE FINISH AND
THAT YOU'RE BY THIS PLAN IS A
BIG PART OF THAT THEY WERE HELP
ATTRACT MORE INVESTMENT FOR
STATE CONNECT ITTY AND ECONOMIC
BENEFITS- FOR YOUR TO COME SHE
URGE THE STATE YOU CAN FINE THE
PROJECT THE REMAINING ONE ABLE
FUND FOR DEFENSE VALLEY. AND
EARLY DO AND THEN REVIEW FOR
DIFFERENT IT'S GOING TO EIGHT
EIGHT ONE THANK WE BELIEVE WILL
HELP REACH GOALS AND GIVE IT
BEST CHANCE IT LOOKS AND FINISH
AT LEAST. THANK YOUNG THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT COMMENT PLEASE.
WHITE SEVENTY PLEASE AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS ROBERTS AND I'M OF
REALTY THE REAL PASSENGER SO
SHE SONOMA CALIFORNIA NEVADA
REAL PASS IS AN ALL WOMAN TO
STUFF IT WOULD ORGANISE
FOUNTAIN IN THE SO EIGHT IN
THIS ADVOCATE. FOR EXPANDING
PUBLIC TRASH THAT. I WANTED
THEM TO AND STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE MOVE TWENTY TWENTY. HIGH
SPEED RAIL THIS PLAN OR L. PACK
ALSO RECOMMENDS THE
APPROPRIATIONS REMAIN PROPS IS
ONE EIGHT FUNDS. TO REDUCE RISK
AND PROVIDE A SECURE FINANCIAL
FOUNDATION FOR THE COMPLETION
OF THE COURT HUNDRED NINETY
MILES CENTRAL VALLEY SEGMENT.
WE'LL PACK FEELS A CONTINUED
FOCUS ON COMPLETING THE RAIL
LINE MERCED TO BAKERSFIELD AND
INITIATING. THE INTERIM CENTRAL
VALLEY OPERATING PLAN IS BEST
READY FOR IT IF A CIVIL CASE
AND IMPROVED EXPANDED EIGHTY
SAN JOAQUIN NETWORK REACHING
ALL OF CALIFORNIA WHILE LAYING
THE FOUNDATION IN A POSITION IN
CALIFORNIA'S. HIGH SPEED RAIL
PROJECT AS THE STRONGEST
CANDIDATE FOR ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL FUNDS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND MISTER
MODERATOR THAT'S BEEN THAT IS-
FIVE PARTICIPANTS. SO FAR THERE
ANYMORE IN Q. WE DO IT WILL
MORE Q. THE FLY QUESTION IN
ORDER TO COME WILL COME LINES
THREE PLEASE AHEAD. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THIS IS CHUCK REAL
HAS REPRESENT IN THE BUILDING
TRADES IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
PRESIDENT MADERA TULARE KINGS
I'M CALLING TO SUPPORT THE
BUSINESS PLAN HAS THE IS-
PLEASE ALLOW US TO FINISH THE
WORK- THAT WE STARTED A FEW
YEARS AGO- WE HAVE SINCE HAD
OVER FOUR THOUSAND DISPATCHES.
OVER TWO HUNDRED APPRENTICES ON
SITE- THIS DATA IT DOESN'T NEED
TO BE SAID THAT THIS-
PARTICULAR PROJECT IS A GAME
CHANGER FOR THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
ESPECIALLY FOR THE PAST YEAR
HOW WITH THE COVETED
RESTRICTIONS- SO I WOULD CALL
WITH A STRONG SUPPORT FROM
EVERY MEMBER THAT I REPRESENT
THE CENTRAL VALLEY FOR THE-
BUSINESS PLAN HAS IS. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GREAT
MISTER MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY
ARTISTS OF PENCE. NOT AT THIS
TIME BETTER MATTER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SO HAVING HEARD ALL
OF THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY MEMBERS
ARE THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS I'D SEEN
NONE- SO WE WANT TO THANK ALL
OF THE INDIVIDUALS WHO CALLED
IN TO PARTICIPATE. IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY WE HEARD YOU
LOUD AND CLEAR- IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE ARVEST THOUGH
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE. AND THE SENATE
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE NUMBER
FIVE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE. YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
ALWAYS VERY IMPORTANT TO US WE
WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY
IN THE OFFICIAL HEARING
RECORDS. WE THINK ALL OF THE
MEMBERS WHO PARTICIPATED AND OF
COURSE THE AUTHORITY THE L. A.
O. THE PEER REVIEW GROUP AND
OUR REGIONAL PARTNERS FOR
ATTENDING. AND PARTICIPATING
WITH US TODAY- WE HAVE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE AND
SUBCOMMITTEES ARE ADJOURNED
THANK YOU.